Hello everybody!
Sorry I took so long to start my stream.
I woke up from my nap so I had to wake up mentally and emotionally.
So I had to wake up.
Oh my god.
I was like, do I stream today?
I just really just want to play Marvel Rivals.
And then I was like, what if I just stream Marvel Rivals?
But Merry Christmas for those on the other side of the world!
Also, Crim, thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you, thank you!
For those who don't know what Twitch Pri- Oh my gosh, it's been so long since I showed my Twitch.
I also realized, wait, I should like update my like, Twitch stuff too.
Cause I'm like, ooh I tabbed out and my PC's like, no.
Wait, what is my title?
I realized I should update a lot of stuff on my Twitch.
Oh yeah, okay.
Wait, I'm gonna make a Nendoroid tag right now.
Nendoroid, okay.
And then, let me- Nightbot.
Guys, I'm doing it all live.
I realized I never made my Nendoroid.
Okay, nightbot.tv.
Authorized.
Wait, is one my monster?
You make my Nendoroid tag.
Oh wait, maybe I should make my own tag.
Alright, new command.
Nendoroid.
I have a Nendoroid now!
Bye, bye, bye!
Okay, what are the links?
I have a Nendoroid, but like what are my links to Nendoroid again?
Alright, don't worry, I'm gonna find it.
Okay, I have like- Okay, here we go.
NA international, there we go.
Create.
Oh, command name- Wait, I already have it?
Oh shit, someone else made it!
Yay!
Alright, cool.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's great.
Someone else did the job for- Oh, thank god.
I have mods.
I was like, gonna make it and it was like, command is already created.
And I was like, oh shit, nice.
Alright, so, I am- I think it's safe to admit that I have a really, really, really big issue with Marvel Rivals in the terms of- I definitely have a problem.
I- King, thank you for the 1,000 bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh yeah, sorry, I forgot to show.
If you don't know what Twitch Prime is, it's when you have to- You can subscribe to your favorite Twitch streamer for free!
As in me!
So you don't have to pay extra, because you already paid like, I don't know, 60 plus dollars to Amazon already.
So you might as well use that free Prime subscription!
Other than that, yes, I know it's like, super late at night now.
I did not celebrate Christmas Eve.
I never- Not never, but like, I didn't grow up celebrating the- Oh my god, I knew shilling works.
Look at all these Twitch Primes.
That's why it doesn't hurt to be a shameless shiller.
Oh, look at all that free money.
Damn, look at all that free- Thank you guys for the free money, I really appreciate it.
Pace, Lil, and Zman, and Tara, thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you, thank you!
Anyway, so, we have basically two hours until it's Christmas, but I normally don't celebrate- I normally don't celebrate the holidays, because I didn't grow up celebrating the holidays.
So like, I don't see Christmas Eve, or Christmas, anything special, in general.
So like, it was funny, because I was like, where is everybody?
And then I forgot people, you know.
Normal people spend time with their family during this day, so that's why I was like, oh, so that's where people are.
Because I was like, waiting for people to be online to like, play Marvel Rivals for me.
Because I was like, I didn't wanna- I didn't wanna like, solo, because I was like, I hate soloing Marvel Rivals.
It's just- It's just way too painful.
Like, as a support player, soloing in Marvel Rivals as a support player is like, fucking terrible.
It's not fun at all.
And then, but like, um, if you're duoing with somebody, at least they share the exact same pain as you.
And then, at least it guarantees that you're not playing with another support player.
Like, that's really all I care about.
Like, I just want somebody to share- Oh my god, Quan!
QuanTumblr, thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you for the- wait, wait, is this the real Valorant?
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a- wait a minute, let me- Oh, is Valorant giving bonus subs?
Oh, so like, does it mean that like, if you gift a sub, if you gift subs, then Valorant will give you- Oh, it's a Valorant!
I love how they're doing a Twitch promotion when I'm playing Marvel Rivals.
Oh, they give free subs!
Guys, they give free- oh my god, I love free stuff.
They give five subs- okay, five subs for every five subs, I think.
Yeah, yeah, every five subs you do, they give the sub.
Oh, it's like bonus too!
Oh my god, let's farm Valorant!
Oh my god, thank you!
Hat and Clogs and Valorant and Ramiel for the gifted subs, thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, nice, we're gonna farm Valorant.
Guys, they have enough money already.
One skin is like fucking $40, and like, we know people are farming that skin right now.
Medi, thank you for the five gifted subs, thank you, thank you!
Tron, thank you for the five gifted subs, thank you, thank you!
Guys, it's okay, like, if anything, this is like nothing to them, honestly.
This is like nothing to them.
They're actually trying to bribe you to play- it has to be like five, I think.
Yeah, five subs triggers the gifted.
Tron girl, Nexi, thank you for the five gifted subs, thank you, thank you!
But yeah, normally I don't- I don't celebrate, uh...
I normally don't celebrate, uh...
Oh my god, thank you guys!
Kaz, Mike, thank- buddy!
Oh my- yes, take all their- take their skin money.
Honestly, like, what we farm from Valorant- from the Valorant gifted promotion is like literally 0.1% of what they make in general.
From one- one skin, from one skin that they release, it's...
It's 0.1% of their wallet.
Fever, thank you for the five gifted subs!
And, uh...
Psycure, and Fillion, and, uh...
Pitesize!
Thank you so much for the gifted subs, I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much, thank you for the love!
Merry Christmas and Christmas Eve to all my Dragoons!
But yes, like I said, I normally don't celebrate the holidays, because my family never really celebrated the holidays.
Especially Christmas.
At best, like, I never really got, like, Christmas presents.
My parents would just be like, here's some money, or like, oh hey, what do you want?
And then they'll just, like, if I say I want something, they just buy it for me.
Uh, like...
I think, like, after Christmas.
So, like, I never really saw it as, like, anything, like, special special.
Um, and then sometimes there's a Christmas dinner, and sometimes there's, like, Christmas buffet.
And sometimes there isn't.
But it was just never, like, a super special holiday for me, because, like, I never really...
Um, I never really had a chance to actually celebrate the holidays.
And also, I live alone.
So, like, you know, like, what do I do?
I walked my dog.
I, like, woke up.
And then, like, did my... did, like, work stuff.
And then walked Doki Amber Doge.
And then, like, took a nap, because I was waiting for people to be online.
And then I woke up, and then nobody was online, because it's goddamn Christmas Eve.
I can't believe it.
People would rather spend time with family than grind...
Than get... than do the grind.
I'm not dedicated enough.
You know what I'm saying?
Like...
Oh my god.
They're not dedicated like I am.
To Marvel Rivals.
How fucking dare they.
If you don't pick Marvel Rivals over your family, then you're not... you're not in it.
You're not in it for real.
Whoa.
How dare they.
They don't like... they don't love rivals like I do.
That's a weird way to pronounce addicted.
Lacrosse says thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
And OshieSpark, thank you for the 5 gifted.
And Pelo and C.
Sensetsu and Quantz.
And Minler and Vivrian, thank you so much for the gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, I am a true FPS geek.
This is why I'm a... even though this is a third person, this is exactly why I'm a third person.
I'm your FPS VTuber of the year.
I am that dedicated to the grind.
Get a VTuber that's willing to grind Marvel Rivals on fucking Christmas Eve.
I would totally play Marvel Rivals on Christmas.
But then I realized that maybe you guys aren't into that.
I was thinking about it.
I was like, do I do it?
I was like, no.
No, I shouldn't.
I was like, I shouldn't do this to the dragoons.
I shouldn't.
I literally played Marvel Rivals at the concert.
That's a little bit too much.
That's a little... that's a little bit too fucking much.
Maybe I shouldn't do that.
So like, I legitimately, I could play Marvel Rivals and stream Marvel Rivals every day for the next month.
Like, until the season is over.
Guys, I just need you to know, this is only because it's season one.
The moment season one is over, I'll be okay.
It's just that season one... season one, I need to be top 500 in season one.
You don't understand.
It's the first season.
Like, I have to be top 500.
It's season...
The first season, I have to be top 500.
Like, you don't understand.
Like, that's where my... that's why I can't stop.
Like, that's exactly why I can't stop.
It's like the first season.
So like, I'm too far gone.
I have to be on the leaderboards, guys.
Like, I'm desperate.
I really need to be on the leaderboards.
Chat, I...
So after the season is over, I'll return back to normal.
Like, things will be okay again.
Like, my head can't do variety.
But like, I forced myself this week to do variety.
Because I was like, Yo, could you really want to lose like 80% of your audience?
Is this how you want to ruin your career?
For Marvel Rivals?
And then the 50% side of me was like, It'll be... yeah.
Sorry, no.
The 49% of me was like, You know what?
Would it be that bad?
But then the 51% side of me was like, No, you shouldn't.
That's a little...
No.
After everything you've built, Doki, You're really going to ruin your career for Marvel Rivals.
So I was like, Okay, okay.
You gotta put some variety this week, Doki.
You gotta do some variety stuff this week.
Also like, Tomorrow, I originally had something special planned for Christmas.
Like a special upload.
But the video ended up not being done in time.
Because there was a lot of edits I wanted to do.
And obviously, They couldn't make it in time for the Christmas upload.
Because they wanted to spend time with family.
And it was a hard decision.
I was like, I don't want to force them to work days before Christmas.
And oh my god, look it's...
Oh my god!
Thank
you!
Thank you for farming Valorant for me.
I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate us farming Valorant.
Maybe at one point, we'll hit the 1% of the Valorant wallet.
Oh my god, thank you again!
Anyway, so...
So I was like, No, Doki, you should...
You should not...
You should play other games, you know?
You should play stuff that, you know...
The Dragoons actually want to watch you play.
And I was like, alright.
We'll add variety.
I'll scratch my Marvel Rivals itch off stream.
I hope I end top 500.
I really do.
Because like, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
But I've been getting games.
I legit...
Okay, so for those who don't know.
I've been playing with other streamers, but I don't stream.
Because I get really distracted when I'm streaming.
AKA, I'm streaming right now.
But I'm going to get super distracted when I'm streaming ranked.
So when I'm playing off stream, I'm more focused up.
So I had several...
I had a game.
We actually bumped into people.
If they're losing, they would DDOS the server.
They would DDOS the server.
So they won't lose any rank points.
It was so fucking crazy.
And then my team called them out.
Like, we got them on our team.
The next game.
And then we called them out.
And they're like, I don't know what you're talking about.
We don't do that.
It's not me.
I don't know what you're talking about.
And then because we called them out.
They didn't DDOS the server for the second game.
Because we were about to win.
And then our servers got DDOS'd.
And then people on our team was calling out that guy.
And then like...
And then we called them out the next game.
Because we got them on our team.
And we were intentionally not trying.
Because we were like, fuck you guys.
Because apparently, they got into Shroud's game several times.
And kept DDOSing the server when they were losing the Shroud.
And then so like...
So we knew that it was them.
Because chat was telling us.
The chat was telling my friends.
Who I was playing with.
That they were purposely DDOSing the servers.
For Shroud's games.
And then so we called them out on it.
On our game.
And then they were like, oh we were talking about.
We didn't DDOS the server.
And they were three stacking too.
One of the DDOSers was three stacking with two other people.
They were so fucking bad.
Because they literally can't lose.
They only win from...
They don't DDOS when they win.
So they were so fucking bad.
Because they were so easy to kill.
Because they don't have any game sense at all.
Because they are literally climbing from DDOSing the servers.
And then.
Because they don't lose anything when the servers get shut down.
So when we called them out.
They were like, woah I don't know what you are talking about.
And then they don't DDOS the servers.
So they were like, see we lost it and the servers aren't DDOSed.
And we were like, are you fucking kidding me.
Because they were like.
Woah look at that.
Now you lost points.
And we were like, do you think we fucking care.
We can get our points back so easily.
Well not me.
My friends.
Not me because I'm a support player.
But my friends were like, do you think we care.
It was a sacrifice I had to make.
It was a sacrifice.
I had to make.
But my friends were like, do you think.
Do you think we care.
We can get our points back.
Me I was like, well I can.
But like, yeah fuck you guys.
I was just like, not me.
But like, yeah.
I care.
But like, yeah fuck you guys.
Doki in the background.
I care.
I care about my rank points.
So yeah.
So basically those are like.
My adventures.
Of more of a rival ring so far.
Oh yeah, also story time.
I'll talk about this tomorrow.
But like today I walked dad.
I walked dad, Doki and Brioge today.
And then like.
What happened was that he found.
Another.
There was another dog in front of us.
And he was so excited.
And then he was a tiny dog.
He's ok with tiny dogs.
Because he's like, I'm bigger than you.
So like, I'm in charge.
So like basically what happened.
Was that, he, also.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
So basically they were he was sniffing him and then like he was like Yippee another dog and then like he didn't bark at him So I was really happy because it was like honestly some 80 80 20% whether he's gonna bark at them or not 20% of him not barking at them because he's a wiener dog.
So every dog is technically bigger than him.
Anyway, so What happened was that?
basically uh He was sniffing the other dog and he's like
He sniffed him and then he tried to pee on him I was like
NOT NEAR GRANDSON!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?!
I was like, PLEASE!
Oh my god, if it were near Grandson it would make sense, but then he tried to PEE ON THE OTHER SMALLER DOG!
And obviously, the other smaller dog instantly backed off and was like, What the fuck?
What the fuck, you fucking freak!
Like, yeah!
That is so... bro wanted to claim and he's like, You're smaller than me, you're mine now!
Like, he's so fucking freaky!
That was the first time!
I've never seen him done that before on any other dog before!
This is the first time he tried to pee on another dog!
I didn't know what to do, I was like, I'm so...
And I walked away, I'm like, I'm so sorry!
And then I pulled him and I just walked away, cause I was like, what do I say?
Like, I'm like, what do I do after that?
And I just walked away!
I didn't know what else to do!
He's just like... I don't even know what the owner said, I was so embarrassed!
I literally was like, no!
And then I walked away cause I don't know what else to do!
I was like, this is... this is not it!
This is not it!
Um, but yeah, anyway, like I said, I bumped into like, so many...
Um, I bumped into so many support players, I would get like, three to four support mains on my own team.
So I have to like, play with other people to guarantee that I have someone that is not a support player.
Like, I can't, I legitimately can't.
This is like, solo queue hell for me.
There's so many support mains in high elo, I can't.
Like, where did you guys...
Why are you in my lobbies?
And then my friends would be like, how do you get so many support players?
All I get were DPS players.
And I'm like, bro, I wish I just get DPS players.
Bro, I've been avoiding, I use my voice chat for support players cause I'm so tired!
I'm so tired of getting support, other support mains on my team!
I'm so tired.
So, so I have to like, I actually like, avoid support players and I only get three slots too.
Also like, a lot of people recognize me in high elo, it's crazy.
They're like, is this the real DokiBrit?
Oh my god, Doki, is this you?
Sometimes I don't say anything and then sometimes I grease them with my, with a response.
Sometimes, sometimes I don't know all people if they ask me if it's me and then sometimes I'm like, I feel nice today.
So like, I don't say anything so they'll always be like, oh my god, is it?
Or like, is it really her or is it not her?
Will I ever know?
And then I like to have them like, think about that.
They'll be like, even though like, technically you can't have, you can't have the same name.
So like, so like, it's obviously me because you can't share a name.
But like, if they can't, if they ask me if I'm the real Doki and they still don't recognize the fact that I'm literally the only one that owns the tag DokiBrit, then they deserve to be DonaWald.
They, they, they deserve to be DonaWald.
If they like, are absolute that they know it's 100% me, then I'll be like, ah yes, then you definitely watch me.
That's so true.
If they're like, if they're like, is that the real you?
Then you're getting DonaWald.
We would never, exactly, you would never make, you would never hesitate.
If you're a real Dragoon, you won't hesitate.
You would know it's me.
Also like, um, I've had several, okay, so I bumped into people in my team or like, um, against me and they would be like, um, oh my god, Doki, I'm a huge fan.
Can like, can like, um, can you say, like, can I respond or something like on my team?
Or like, they'll be like, oh, can I have you added?
And I would be like, if we lose this game, I'm banning you from my chat.
And then we lose, I'd be like, sorry, I'm, guess, guess you're banned.
And then, and then, no pressure or anything.
No, no pressure.
And then, and then, and then if I get them on my team again, they'll be like, please, please, can we, can, please, am I banned?
And I was like, if we win this game, I'll unban you.
Clutch or ban.
And then if I get farmed by a Dragoon, I'd be like, I'm fucking banned.
And then if I get farmed by a Dragoon and they say something in the match chat, I'd be like, well, guess I'm banning you.
I was like, how dare you, how dare you farm me.
Real Tokyo behavior, that's what happens if you acknowledge me.
There is no justice.
That's what happens.
The rank warrants are that serious, guys.
I am that committed to the grind.
How dare you farm me.
But yeah, that's how it's been going so far.
I love my role rivals.
Honestly, I've never been this addicted to a competitive shooter in a fucking long ass time.
So this is like, I'm feeling the passion right now.
Also, now I can play other characters because Luna Snow keeps getting banned.
They always ban Mantis and Luna Snow now.
So now I can actually play lowkey, guys.
I can actually, I'm feeling way less bad about Tokyo's queue time now.
These two are like always banned.
So now I can play lowkey, I don't know how to play Adam yet, but apparently he's also really, really good.
I can play lowkey, Rocky Raccoon and Cloak and Dagger.
I'm still learning Adam.
Yeah, people ban supports on high elo.
Because there's literally, these two are the only defensive ults.
These two are the only ones that can save the team.
If any of these characters ult, we have these two to save the team.
But because they ban these two, all these characters with the 5 million fucking aggression ults can kill all of us.
So it's whoever team, whichever team does their aggressive fucking ults first and we don't have a defensive ult.
And it's fucking terrible.
Yes, Cloak and Dagger ult is insane.
But like, the thing is, people don't stand on her ult sometimes.
That's the issue.
People don't stand on her ult.
Like, there's like, stand here and they don't stand here.
Like, it's just stand there.
That's all you do.
But they don't.
They run away.
And I'll be like, look at this blue area.
Stand in the blue.
Like, stand, like, like, basically you can outlive so much stuff if you stand here.
That's all you need to do.
Stand here.
But yeah, that's really all I want to rant about.
Let me check.
Let me check if people are...
All right.
Let me see.
Let me see if anybody is online to play right now.
If not, we're going to lose our GM2 on solo queue.
Okay, that's my life update.
So yeah, I've been enjoying the break a lot.
Because I get to play Marvel Rivals.
Sorry, I did get some work done.
I got some work done.
But like, also, I have been playing Marvel Rivals like 10 plus hours a day.
Which is really nice because I was like, yippee!
I did, but they were like, oh yeah, message around this time if they're ready.
So, um, so I've been going to sleep at like 6 to 8 a.m.
every day since I had my break.
I'm sorry, I have a problem.
I can't help it.
And so I really like Marvel Rivals.
I'm sorry.
I just, I just really, really like Marvel Rivals, guys.
I just, I just, I'm that committed to the grind, everybody.
I know, I have a problem.
Time is like non-existent anymore to me.
But I wish I could get sponsored by Marvel Rivals.
I wish I can...
Wait, do I have drops on this?
Because I feel like everybody's like, drops?
Let me check.
I'll look at drops again.
Okay, drops.
Is there, do I have Marvel Rivals drops?
I don't know if that's like for everybody.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it is enabled.
By the way, I have drops.
It's enabled.
I don't really know what it does.
I don't really...
Oh, you get sprays.
I don't really care about sprays.
But like, you guys care about...
I care, okay.
But if Marvel Rivals sponsors me, I care so much about sprays.
I...
And the Magneto skin.
Oh, shit.
If I get sponsored by Marvel Rivals, I will buy the Battle Pass.
That's how dedicated I am.
I will buy the Battle Pass if I get sponsored by Marvel Rivals.
I love Marvel.
Okay, like, but I'm literally like...
Okay, I feel like I converted so many people into playing this game because like of my fucking addiction.
During my meet and greet at Holiday Matsuri, people like went up to me and was like, oh my god, like I got into Marvel Rivals because of you.
And I was like, oh my god, I'm like so addicted because like watching you play Marvel Rivals and then it got me into it, so into it.
And I'd be like, oh, I'm so sorry.
I feel like I'm like the...
I told you, I said this before.
I don't know if I said this at the panel during Holiday Matsuri, but I was just like, I feel like I'm like that picture on the cigarette carton on the packaging where like, don't smoke because this is what happens to you, but people still buy it.
That's me right now.
Don't, don't play Marvel Rivals or you get super addicted just like her.
And the people still, people are like, oh my god, like, um, people...
Oh my god, oh my god, get it now.
Okay, okay, one of my, one of my friends was like, I don't have a, they're like, I don't have a name change right now.
They're like, I don't know if I want to play today.
I don't have a name change.
And I was like, how bad could it be?
Oh my god.
Okay, I understand now.
I can't understand.
Okay, all right.
Because like, it's like seven days.
They're like, I don't know what we should play on.
I'm like, I don't know what I should play on stream because I don't, I don't have a name change at the moment.
Oh my god, I'm the only GM too?
That's gonna be rough, buddy.
Oh my god, okay.
That's fine.
That's fine, we're fine.
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm batting.
Okay, Hela and then Hawkeye.
Hela and then Hawkeye.
No, there is, hero bands are in Diamond Up.
I'm so fine.
And then, oh, they got Hawkeye.
Um, we'll ban, uh, Dr. Strange, actually.
Dr. Strange.
Yeah, Dr. Strange.
No, it's like Diamond and Up, so...
Um, so it should be okay.
I hope they don't ban Psylocke.
Um, Strange is so broken.
Oh, they banned Psylocke.
Okay, that's...
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's totally okay.
The reason why I was like, I hope they don't ban Psylocke is because my duo plays, I mean, Psylocke.
Oh my god.
And so I was like, oh man, that'd be pretty rough.
But like, they can flex.
All right, 1, 2, 3, thank you for the...
For the donation.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, I'm one button away from purchasing a very nice PC case.
But you be convinced on hitting the pay button because I have way too many PC case.
Am I gonna regret this midnight purchase or will I be able to just...
Okay, but like, does the PC case have my face on it?
I feel like that's justification enough.
It has my face on it.
I'd rather they ban a healer because I can flex.
Like, that's right, exactly.
And when it's...
We have like, technically, it's limited edition.
So when all the stock is gone, it's gone forever.
So that's all I'm saying.
Um, do you really want to get FOMO'd?
Do you?
All right, do we have one?
Okay, I'm gonna put it on the story.
All right.
All right, guys.
It's okay, guys.
If we lose, we're not GM2 anymore.
That's okay.
I've accepted it.
I've acce...
Guys, it's okay.
I'm okay, we don't...
Oh, I shouldn't have pressed shift.
I'm like, I'm already throwing, technically.
I'm actually throwing already.
That's fine.
Groot.
I am Groot.
Please.
Please, let me see you.
Let me see you!
I am Groot.
Nice.
I need to not play against Groot players or play with Groot players because literally every time I have a Groot player on my team, in my head, I'm just like, I am Groot.
I am Groot.
Like, I can't...
I can't help it.
It's like, literal brain rot.
Like, for me, all I want to say is just, I am Groot.
And like, when I play off stream, my duos would be like, please stop.
Please stop.
I can't.
But I can't.
I'm so...
I can't stop.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
Get in my dance.
I'm dancing.
Oh, I'm fucking, I'm fucking, I'm dancing my heart out.
We're
forced into it.
Oh my god, we're actually in the fucking Cloak and Dagger ult.
Just cause we're forced into it by Groot.
Thank fucking god.
Guys, no heals.
No heals.
Oh my god.
Please, we have no heals.
Don't do this to me.
We have Nidalee for so long.
What the fuck, you're a killer.
Please.
I am Groot.
Okay, I don't wanna...
I'm not looking back.
I'm not gonna look back.
Okay.
There we go, he's low.
As long as I don't look back, we're fine.
All right, nice.
Yay, yippee.
I almost said Overwatch.
I love Marvel rivals.
Go, Groot, go.
There we go.
We did it.
Oh my god, Sylvanas, thank you for the 50 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for farming Valorant subs for me.
I...
They have too much money, so let's just farm it all.
Unlike Amazon, who's like, going negative from buying Twitch.
I should say that clearly on Twitch.
Like, you know how like, Twitch did that special promotion too?
But like, you guys didn't know.
Amazon's literally losing money with Twitch because it's not sustainable.
Because like, having a platform is like, not...
It's not as sustainable as you think it is.
But Valorant is very sustainable, so...
At least like, Valorant's not losing money from this.
I mean, YouTube...
It took YouTube like, years before it became profitable.
Uh, because like, buying servers is like, so expensive in general.
We have Black Panther?
I think like, Twitch for them is just like, an...
Oh shit, okay, we got it.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
They have a Wolverine!
Oh!
Bro, they're so armed!
We can't let this guy die.
If he dies, he gets it again.
We can't.
We can't let that happen.
Wait, where's our Thor?
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I dropped!
No!
I accidentally dropped!
Oh, it's because our Thor swapped!
I got like, Wolverine jumpscared into falling down.
Why the fuck did our other tank swap?
We were doing so well!
Sorry, I got like, I legitimately got like, jumpscared from...
From the Groot, so like, it fucked me up.
It actually like, fucked me up.
I was just like, what the fuck was that?
Did he get anything?
I don't- I don't even know.
Oh shit, I'm backing up.
Oh, I'm backing up.
This is why I don't normally stream ranking.
I get so distracted in general.
Um...
We really just need another tank.
That's- That's really it.
What happened?
Is it Glenn?
Glenn.
Glenn, buddy.
You were doing great on Thor.
Like, what?
Were you like, you know what?
Fuck having an easy game to win.
You know?
Fuck that shit.
I don't want to fucking win this easily.
Jesus.
Okay.
Are we okay?
Are we- We're so healthy.
We're- We're so okay.
Please, just- It's just Magneto.
Please.
Now it's just Wolverine.
Okay.
Thank- Okay, we used a bit too many ults there.
We- You okay, Grunt?
Are you okay?
What's the real challenge?
He was like, no, that- That game was way too- That round was too easy.
I want to earn my rank here.
Bro, I'm here for- Okay, like, some of my friends, they were like, Oh man, I'm happy when the games are just good.
But I'm like, I'm not.
They're like, uh, when the game's like, real- They're like, oh man.
I wish- Oh my god, bro.
Oh my god.
I'm just- Oh my god, as long as you're- I can't- I can't- No!
I can't keep you alive anymore!
I- I can't!
Just- I can't keep you alive anymore!
Oh my god!
They're like- They're like, oh man, I told my friends, it would be like, I don't like easy games.
I like- It's so boring.
And I was like, I like winning.
I was like, I don't fucking care.
I don't care if it's easy.
I like winning.
Like-
Again, true.
I don't care.
They're like, man, when games get too easy.
It's so boring.
Or like- Or like, man.
And then like, I get crazy.
If it's like, win-loss, win-loss, win-loss.
I get fucking crazy.
Because I was like, it's so frustrating.
But then, my friends would be like, man, like, the games are good though.
Like, I'm like- Wish games were easier.
Winning above all.
A win is a win.
Oh, now he plays Thor!
Okay!
Okay, buddy!
Oh, fucking K!
He's like, alright, now it's a real challenge.
Now, this round, this game is an actual challenge.
Let me play another tank now.
Went over having fun.
Yes, a real game.
He's just like, now, now it's fine.
Yeah, we'll bring the second Seer for the tanks.
I'm gonna wait.
I don't care about good games.
I just wanna win.
A game is good when I win.
That's basically it.
If the game is- Is he alive?
Wait, he's alive!
What happened there?
I was like, what the fuck happened there?
God, he's alive!
I'm just going to hide.
Whoa!
No!
Oh my god!
I didn't mean to fucking hit that!
I'm so sad!
I'm so fucking sad!
Let's try to fucking get cover!
Oh my god, that's terrible!
I'm so depressed!
Oh my god.
That was absolutely depressing for me.
That was so depressing!
Oh my god.
Groot, please, Groot.
You're gonna take a million fucking damage over there, Groot.
I'm so fucking scared for you.
I'm mad!
Goodbye.
I don't live there anymore!
You can have...
You can have the area.
Where...
Oh, he killed two!
Why are you up there?
Oh my god!
Guys, please!
Oh, the double support!
Oh, no!
Oh my god!
Oh, where am I?
Where am I?
I don't know!
Oh my god.
I couldn't tell where I am anymore.
All right, that's fine.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
That's fine.
Everything is so A-okay.
Everything is...
Oh, no.
Oh, no, that's a lot of...
Okay, I froze Magneto.
Can we do anything with that?
I'm scared of, you know...
That...
That was unfortunate because nobody was actually near my ult when this happened.
Wait, what?
Okay, just keep me up.
Just keep me up.
I'm just gonna be over there.
All right.
Okay, Magneto.
I know you would like the thrill of almost losing, but like, Magneto, please.
Oh my god!
He's so low!
Please, just focus on him!
Oh my god!
He's so low also!
Please!
Oh, he actually gets healed!
What a freaking freak!
Oh, that's huge!
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go!
Oh my god, that's crazy.
We just gotta keep our Groot alive.
Damn!
Oh.
Guys, I don't know if we can keep our Groot alive anymore.
Is this worth it?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh!
I heard that too late.
That's fine!
I baited!
I baited Bucky ult!
It's fine!
That's...
It's worth it.
It's so worth it.
It's fine!
We baited Bucky ult!
Haha, it's fine!
Okay.
They don't have Bucky ult.
That's fine.
Just don't die here.
Cause...
I think our Groot dies here.
I don't know why they peek when...
I don't know why our Groot...
Like, I don't know why.
Why did he peek?
Haha.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This is last fight.
I can't...
I don't... I don't think I can build.
Guys, guys.
I don't feel comfortable in this choke point right now.
I...
I don't...
I don't feel comfortable.
Oh.
Guys, it was great being GM2 for a second.
What the fuck?
Why didn't we ult?
I don't understand.
The records.
Oh, that was actually...
Reports looking for not knowing.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, I...
I don't know.
They were all terrible.
I'm not gonna lie.
They were all fucking terrible.
No, our...
Our Thor was pretty...
Our...
Our Thor was like, I'm gonna play DPS.
Like...
Like, he just made the game so much harder...
Than it needed to be.
Literally, he did not have to play fucking tank.
Yeah.
He's having a hard time during Christmas.
Yeah, he is.
All right.
That was...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That...
Guys, it was nice being like GM2 for like...
Like for two hours.
It was a good time.
I...
I had a great time being GM2 for two hours.
Oh my god, there's so many people like I've like talked to.
I'm just gonna be like, Hey Drake, pick Kayder.
No Psylocke today.
Remember when...
Yeah, remember when we saw myself in GM2 for like...
A couple of seconds.
Those were the good old days.
I don't care what they ban.
I don't want Hawkeye on my fucking games.
I...
I can't.
No, it wasn't two hours because I slept, guys.
I slept and I was still GM2 because I didn't queue.
So technically, I was GM2 for like...
At least 10 hours.
I...
I was GM2 for at least 10 hours.
That's something.
Okay.
All right.
I like messaged my duo.
I was like, why are you not playing Psylocke?
Because like they're a Psylocke main.
And then they're like...
They're like, oh, I'm practicing new heroes.
Do you want to win or is it okay if I...
I was just like...
But if you want me to win...
I was like, can I get back GM2 first?
And then I was just like, can I get back GM2 first?
And then you can practice.
And then they're like, okay, but after this Ironman game...
They're like, okay, but after this Ironman game...
That's crazy.
Bro, you're getting greeted by everybody right now.
I was like, bro, Psylocke's finally not banned.
Why aren't you on Psylocke?
I fucking love that character.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, that's fine.
That's not fine.
That's 100% not fine.
Oh my god.
My positioning is pretty bad right now.
They have an Ironman as well, which is scary.
Okay.
Yeah, we can't do anything about it because they have an Ironman with this fucking orb on it too.
Okay, here we go.
Holy shit!
Okay.
Alright, I froze him again.
Come on!
You should be out of mech now.
Get him out of mech.
Okay.
I'm pushing up.
It's so free!
Where's my Ironman?
There it is.
There we go.
Can't see you.
No, he's out of mech form!
Oh.
Oh, I hit him.
Oh, I even hit him too.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, get back in the mech.
First banner.
Back in that mech.
My positioning is so garbage right now.
Like...
It's actually pretty bad positioning.
I need to get better at positioning.
There's just so many maps.
So it's like...
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Oh my god, it's an Ironman off.
It's an Ironman off, but it's not even a 1v1.
It's like...
It's like a freaking...
Trying to 1v1 and then the rest of us is just here.
Oh, okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Yippee!
Let's...
No!
Oh my god, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
I'm so healthy.
Oh my god, I'm so healthy.
I'm not healthy anymore.
I'm not healthy.
Oh, that's like the scariest shit.
It's fine.
This is an Ironman off again.
Yo, Jarvan, don't clip that.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
We still have a support that's still alive.
Alright.
Guys, guys.
Guys, they're sort of capping for free, guys.
But that's okay.
We all make mistakes here.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think he's okay.
He's okay.
Oh my god, this is not...
This is not...
There's no hold.
Sorry, I thought there was a...
I forgot that there's a hold now.
So I was like, don't worry, I have cover to...
Dodge all that.
I did not have cover.
I'm so bad at positioning on this map.
I don't know how to position myself properly on this one.
That's not how you position yourself.
It's fine.
Okay, I'm well up.
Guys.
Okay.
That's fine.
What am I getting hit by?
Okay, nice.
There's a hold.
I always forget the hold.
I always...
I always forget the fucking hold.
Oh, they swapped a penny.
Drivers clip that.
I love all the Marvel Rivals memes.
This is my favorite meme that I like sent to my friend.
Because I thought it was...
I don't know, I'm sorry.
I'm just fucking...
There's something wrong with me.
All my...
I closed my eyes and all I think about is Marvel Rivals stuff now.
That's all I think about trying to...
No, where is...
Oh yeah, like this meme.
Guys, I'm gonna send you guys Marvel Rivals meme now.
This is...
I'm like, I relate to that.
Oh wait, I know...
I understand that reference.
I'll be like, I know that reference.
So true.
I really like that meme.
I'm too far gone.
No, I am.
I'm way too far gone right now.
Like...
Like, there's no saving.
Oh my...
What is this positioning?
Like, where's my...
Why is my stream there?
I'm so confused.
I mean, okay.
Hi.
Are you having fun?
Are you...
Did you...
Did you have fun?
I didn't even...
I hope...
Bro, okay.
You got that, Luna.
You got that.
Wait, who?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Like, what do you mean I got that?
I'm not gonna push up.
Okay, goodbye.
Okay, we're gonna...
Also, when I stream, I like, I'm...
I think...
Oh no.
Like, you look at me and I look at you.
When I stream, my hands shake more, too.
Because I'm more nervous.
Because you guys are like, watching me.
Because you guys watch me and then my hands start shaking.
Because you're like, you're like, observing.
You know?
You're like, observing.
And you're like, trying...
I'm being observed.
So, my hands shake more because...
Bro, what the f...
Bro, okay.
I'll kill him myself.
But like, what the fuck?
Bro, I'll kill him, too.
I'll fucking kill him, too.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Our Mantis also got involved.
That's every stream.
I have like...
This is high elo.
It's different.
I haven't streamed high elo rank in a long time, too.
I haven't streamed GM rank before.
So, I get like, more nervous.
That's why I'm like, missing more.
Don't worry!
Oh, okay.
We don't need to worry, apparently.
We definitely don't need to worry.
Alright, they're born again.
Oh.
Okay, guys.
I'm fucking rolling out.
Did you have fun, Psylocke?
Did you have fun?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Yay!
We did it!
What the fuck?
You have no fu...
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Technically, we are all playing Rivals on Christmas.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Travis put him on the naughty list.
Holy fuck!
On Christmas.
You have no family.
Oh my god.
That's actually insane.
Straight to the naughty list, bro.
On fucking Christmas?
That's actually...
Oh my god.
Bro!
What happened on Christmas?
Is he for you?
We're all messed up.
Well, we all saw it, too.
We all saw it.
Travis twisted his balls.
Technically, I can report him.
Wait, does Xyphel got to GM3?
He was top 500, like...
Yesterday!
Oh no, is he too...
I think he's doom queuing.
And he was...
He was Eternity yesterday.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he has to...
This guy has to be doom queuing.
There's no way.
He was literally Eternity.
He was Eternity yesterday.
He's 24 out.
Bro, he's been streaming.
Oh my god, he's been streaming Rivals for 24 hours.
Holy fuck, okay.
Oh my god.
Don't ban Hawkeye for us.
Shield tanks, we should get rid of them.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
He's in Duty.
You guys think I have a problem.
At least I stop after 10 hours.
Oh my god, he's literally at the 23rd hour mark.
Shit, okay.
Oh my god.
There are bigger fish in the sea.
Now, now I think you're normal.
Yeah, I played 10 to 15 hours but not...
But that was off stream.
I could never stream 24 hours.
Bro, I literally saw him in GM 1 this morning.
I saw him in GM 1 the second morning.
Also, TsunamiCat, thank you for the raid.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Brother, it's Christmas.
It doesn't happen.
Oh my god.
Happy Merry Christmas, everybody.
Merry Christmas.
So, hello everybody from Tsunami's cat raid.
My name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
But today I'm on Twitch.
Because I want to stream Marvel Rivals rink right now.
And I usually...
And it's like a guerrilla stream.
So that's where I do my guerrilla stuff.
So like, this is what I do.
I don't climb up the stairs.
And I won't do it like quick.
I just do this.
I don't think he knows you can't jump there unless you're...
I don't think he knows you can't jump there unless you're Luna.
This is quicker than using the stairs.
And I don't have to...
I don't have to like travel up.
Travel behind for it.
I don't think he knew that you can't climb that unless you're like...
Unless you're literally on Luna.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna put my thing on...
I need to put it on the Venom.
If the Venom's gonna dive like that.
There, I froze him.
Oh my god, bro.
This team is way too split for me to do anything right now.
Okay, look at me.
No!
No, Mantis!
Okay, that's bad.
Does he have...
No, please.
Oh my god, please.
Do not hit him!
Why did you hit him?!
If he didn't hit him, I'll be okay.
Oh, thank god I lived.
No, Venom!
Okay, Venom.
Venom!
Okay.
That's...
That's fine.
I'm gonna use...
That's so fine.
Okay.
Don't...
Oh my god, how many times do I have to freeze this guy, honestly?
Wait, okay.
I'm just gonna leave.
That's fine.
That's...
That's so fine.
I'm alive.
Venom!
Luna's my favorite, but like, I can play any support.
It's just Luna's way too good.
And I trust myself on...
I trust to make an impact on...
Well, I trust on every support I can make an impact, but...
Literally, like...
Like, look at my team right now.
They're not...
They're not feeling...
I don't think they're feeling it right now.
Okay.
We can kill him, right?
Oh, hey guys!
Hey, guys!
All right.
Hey, everybody!
I hope we have...
We have Mantis ult for...
Psylocke ult, but like, okay.
That's fine.
I...
I was really worried about this team.
Not gonna lie.
Like...
This...
This team...
Was not giving me any inspiration.
Shit.
Get shit on, I guess.
I don't know what the fuck to get shit on.
All right.
Okay, I need to be on the Venom.
Oh my god.
Venom, please.
Venom.
Venom!
Captain America!
Captain America as well!
Please!
They have Psylocke ult.
Psylocke.
Oh my god, he's alive!
Holy shit, he's alive!
So proud!
Poor Venom.
Venom!
You're swinging so bad!
Where are you?!
My sensitivity's not...
It's not high enough for this!
I fucking feel like I have ADHD!
Okay, here we go.
All right.
It's fine.
We're so fine.
I don't!
I actually don't have ADHD!
But like...
This Venom moves like he has like...
He's fucking riddled with ADHD right now, or Adderall.
Like, the way he's fucking moving.
Holy fuck.
Please, we can definitely kill Venom!
Oh my god, he is hyped up in so much fucking Adderall.
Jesus.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh!
I'm ready to...
Dance!
Oh my god, we gotta run!
Guys, we gotta fucking...
All right, we're all full HP.
Captain, please!
Captain!
I'm running!
We have zero shields!
I'm fucking goodbye design for...
Goodbye.
You are not living.
There we go.
I swear...
I swear!
God!
Holy shit!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god, please!
He came back!
Oh my fucking god!
Oh, he came back!
That's so fucked!
That's actually so...
Oh my god!
Why did you come back?!
Bro!
You guys!
I don't wanna deal with this!
Okay.
All right, Venom.
Venom has the thing.
He has again.
He fucking 100% has it.
Oh my god, please.
That's good.
But they have again after.
I can feel it.
Oh my god, design for...
We're gonna make it.
We're so...
I wanna use my fucking frozen freeze.
Please, just burn him.
He's so low.
Oh my god!
You're still alive?!
Yay!
He really...
I don't know I'm alive!
I don't know!
I don't know why he came back!
Oh my god.
Wait, that's 0 deaths?
I don't fucking...
How?!
How the fuck that's 0 deaths?!
Oh my god!
I feel like I've been jumping...
Jumping around every time!
Bro, how?
Literally every time that Venom dies me, I just...
Freeze him.
And then I run away.
Because I'm like, I'm not winning that fight.
I literally freeze him and I'm like, bye.
Oh my god.
I was just like, bro, fuck you, come on.
I'm not dealing with that.
That's why I was like, why did he come back?
Why the fuck did he come back for me?
He was 1 HP, I was 1 HP.
And then, like, right as we hit main, dive and I'll try to save a bubble for you.
Venom!
I don't even know where that came from.
I just know everybody keeps making that 19 inches of Venom joke.
I've never watched the Venom movies.
You keep literally saving the Xynos mental.
What if I avoid him?
I know, but it's not gonna work.
He's at the 20!
Guys, he's at the 24 hour mark.
He is not, like, he is not okay at the moment.
There's a higher percentage that he's crashing out.
He's literally at 24 hours of marble arrivals.
That is not...
He was...
The fact that he was eternity in the fucking morning.
Not morning, like, yesterday is what's, like, concerning.
That's what I'm concerned about.
I'm sure he's fine.
All right.
Let's see, Trudas?
Seriously?
I thought I had a problem.
That's why I'm like, maybe I should...
Like, the Xypho's an amazing player, but, like...
If in the morning I saw him at eternity and now he's in the GM3, that does not make me feel confident.
I am a passenger princess.
Yeah, that's like when I was playing, like, 12 hours...
Like, 11 hours of...
11 hours of rank and I was not okay.
His 24 hours is my 11 hour mark on stream.
And I was 100...
I was not okay, guys.
I was absolutely...
Like, I was losing a lot.
My first, like, miss on the freeze.
Yay!
Make way for the princess.
That has been a really bad loss for me.
Honestly.
Yay!
I mean...
Plus 17?
I don't understand how...
I don't understand how the...
The point system works.
I feel like I should've got 20...
Plus 20 for that.
Remove his whimsy.
Oh, shit.
That was an instant kill.
Okay.
That was so fast.
Wait, no, I won.
I won't be that fast.
Nacho, thank you for the 100 bits.
Thank you, thank you.
Ecom, thank you for tier 1 sub.
I really appreciate it.
It doesn't make sense.
I don't know.
Yeah, no, he's been playing for...
That's why I was, like, surprised.
I was like, whoa.
That's why I'm...
I'm just like, whoa.
Like, how the fuck...
How the fuck was he in that deep?
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
On Christmas...
Well, for me, I just don't celebrate the holidays.
That's why I'm fucking playing.
Like, that doesn't matter for me.
1, 2, 3, thank you for...
1, 2, 3, and Revi, thank you for tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god, is that the real Doki?
Did they say that?
No, okay.
There's a lot of Dragoons in GM.
I was very surprised.
I was incre...
Like, I was...
I'm sorry.
I don't mean to...
I'm sorry, that sounded so fucking condescending.
But, like, I'm just...
Guys, I was so surprised because I was like, you guys watch me?
Even, like, I was like, whoa, you guys watch me?
Oh my god.
It just makes me so happy that, like, gamers, like, watch me.
You know?
Like, a lot of, like, GM players were like, oh my god, I'm a huge fan, Doki.
So, like, usually, you know, I'm just surprised that, like, high-ranking gamers actually, like, like to watch me even though I do, like, the dumbest shit.
So, it just makes me really happy.
Like, you guys are really good at video games and you like watching me too.
Travis Gracef, rawr.
No, I'm just...
I'm just really happy, guys, that high-heeled gamers are, like, fans of me.
I bumped into so many, like, GM Dragoon players.
I bumped into a top, like, a top...
This guy that peaked top five and then he added me and was like, oh my god, I'm a fan.
He's like, do you remember Niko from four years ago?
Like, he's my best pro.
Like, oh my god, have you ever won a duo or anything?
And I'm like, what the fuck?
Like, that's crazy.
Yeah, yeah, this guy peaked top five in my rivals and he, like, we got him against...
In a team game against him and he was like, oh my god, like, I'm actually...
Oh my god, I'm fucking...
Guys, that was a terrible portal.
Oh my god, thank you for the 10 subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, I'm gonna...
There.
I don't want to be in that portal again.
And they're like, oh yeah, if you ever need a DPS, like, duo or, like, player in your stack, like, invite me.
And I was like, bro, you peaked top five.
Like...
Bro, I'm just a fucking VTuber that's just playing this as a fucking hobby.
Because I'm so down bad for Marvel Rivals.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
I'm fucking leaving.
Okay, goodbye.
Goodbye.
You had to die for that.
All right, I'm sorry, Rocket.
I did my best.
Yeah, but like, you know, this is like...
I do other stuff too.
Like, I can't...
I don't come...
I can't commit my...
Guys, I don't think this is a win.
This looks...
This does not look great.
I need to cross.
I need to cross the road and look at both sides.
I'm just gonna do simple geometry here.
Guys, where the fuck are we going?
Oh, I thought I had this.
Okay.
Guys, I...
I don't know.
I'll do this to save us.
All right, how the fuck did Dom from stat in this?
Guys, this team is not it.
100%.
This is actually not it.
Where are we...
Where are we going?
Like, what?
Oh wait, we got kills.
Nice.
Hey, we got two kills.
Guys, I...
Guys.
Guys, this is...
Whoa.
I don't think this game...
This team is a little special.
Not gonna lie.
This is a very special team.
This is definitely a very special team right here.
Oh my god.
Like, what do I do?
I can't do anything because I'm supporting.
Yippee!
Whoa!
All I can do is just...
Oh, this is where I die.
Yeah, I think...
Yeah, we have one fight.
No, I don't even think...
I don't even...
I don't even think we would win...
Like, win the defense round if we make it.
All right.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
This is...
Guys, we gotta...
We gotta go, girl.
We gotta go.
All right, I'm on it.
I'm on it.
Whoa!
Okay, stand!
Stand!
Literally, stand on my arm!
Okay.
All right.
He flew up.
Like...
Like, what's the point?
What's the point of flying up?
Like, he flew up!
Like, why did you fly?
I had ult right here!
Okay.
This is our...
This is the only reason why I hate playing Cloak and Dagger.
They don't know...
They don't know how Cloak and Dagger works.
Well, it works and we're like literally in GM Diamond queues.
Like, how do you not know how Cloak and Dagger well works?
You actually have to scream at your team and be like, Stand on it!
There's blue on the floor.
There's blue glue.
Just stand.
Stand on it.
It's not that hard.
It's apparently very hard, apparently.
I'm not gonna look at this.
Did he get anything?
Apparently, like...
He's one.
He's so low.
Please.
He's so...
Oh my god.
Oh my...
It's not worth it.
I don't think this fight is worth it.
Yeah, I'm just gonna die to this fight.
It was not worth it.
Alright.
Uh oh, next fight.
I waited.
I knew that was an unwinnable fight.
So that's why I waited.
So sick.
Oh my gosh, I've been...
Well, it's like...
I'm not sick.
It's just my cough comes and goes.
But it's not as bad now.
I'm a...
It's a little better because I haven't...
On a break.
So like...
Okay, guys.
You think they're gonna stand on my glue?
Let's find out.
Alright.
Oh my god!
They're standing!
We didn't need that rocky raccoon ult!
But that's okay.
I'm not gonna judge.
There was a guy right here.
Is he gone now?
He was gone now.
Okay.
I thought there was a guy right here.
Alright, simple geometry.
You see like the...
Heals bounce off.
So I can literally do that and it heals them.
Okay!
Oh, okay!
Holy shit!
That pop!
Oh my god!
He jumped into the ult!
That's crazy!
That's actually so smart!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god!
That's like crazy!
He literally jumped into hell!
That was a really smart play, not gonna lie.
I'm gonna suck.
Oh, sorry!
I'll heal.
I'm gonna heal.
I'm gonna be a support player.
I'm gonna be a support player, guys.
Oh my god!
I'm actually...
Nope!
JK!
Goodbye!
Guys, turn around!
Turn around!
There's a security screen!
There's a fucking surgeon!
All right.
There's a surgeon behind us.
We should have broke his hands when we could.
Damn, dude.
He has a fucking wild vision stick.
We shouldn't have let him.
I am a surgeon!
Yeah, we should have kept his hands broken.
All right, this is technically last fight, so...
Guys, this is scary.
Oh my god!
My ult's gone!
There's too much damage!
You know, we made it pretty far for like, where we had to do.
Like, where we came from, that's pretty good.
We went through a lot.
Yeah, pretty far for what it was, chat.
That is...
That was pretty far.
Maybe it's...
Bro, I've only been grinding at these hours.
I've only...
I've only been playing my pro rivals at these hours.
I have not been playing at like, actual hours.
That's the thing.
I try to play decent hours, but it's the same quality of game.
So I was like, this doesn't matter.
Except at this time, I have people to play with, like...
I'm like, I'm the duo partner that people call up on when there's like, nobody else online, bro.
Because I'm a support player.
They're like, why would you ever...
They're like, no, none of the actual gamers are online at this time.
I know my place.
I'm the last...
I know my place, chat.
I'm not even plan B.
I'm like, plan Z.
Guys, no, I've accepted it.
I've known my place.
That's why I'm at...
I'm playing Marvel Rivals at this hour.
Hi, that's so cake.
I've accepted it.
This is why I play at these hours.
So I didn't...
Exactly.
It's like, this or solo queue, chat.
Like, of course I'll take this.
Hey, Rocket.
I'm gonna stay on the ground.
Rocket can't pick me.
I'm gonna stay up here.
I feel safer up here.
Jesus Christ, okay.
It'll be fine.
Penny, please!
Penny!
Oh my god!
Penny, please!
I can't outlive her!
Fuck you, punish her!
Why did no one push up?
I don't understand.
We have the same support line.
Penny, please!
Oh my god.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay.
Bro, Penny is really good at this map.
It's just...
I can't heal.
I can't.
I don't have enough heal output for this.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, bro.
He's just gonna...
I'm just...
I'm fucking...
Oh, Christ.
Again!
Oh, that's...
Guys, that's two ults.
It's fine.
I just didn't think we need the Penny ult.
That's for sure.
All right, I'll take the high ground here.
Oh my god!
I didn't fucking wait for one second because I wanted high ground!
It's fine.
He has his eye.
He has eye right here.
No!
Oh!
Okay!
There we go!
Okay, bro!
There you go!
Oh my god!
You're so alive!
You're so healthy!
Oh my god!
You have life insurance!
All right, there we go.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
I don't think we need ults for this for now.
I'll do it later.
Okay, now.
You're so healthy.
You're so healthy!
Oh my god!
I'm a fucking gamer!
Okay!
All right, let's go.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
That's right.
I'm fucking gaming.
That was coming at me.
That's right.
FPS.
Okay!
Yeah, I don't think...
Yeah, let's...
I'm leaving.
All right, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can...
I'll give you the reset.
I did that for his reset.
Oh, did he not get...
Did he not hit him?
Oh, he didn't hit him!
I was gonna say, where the fuck is your reset?
You should have got a reset there.
Bye!
Goodbye!
I'm sorry!
Yeah, that's the sacrifice I have to make.
Did I get far?
Oh, goodbye, Penny!
You're so fucking staggered.
There's no way I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
I'll patch you up.
I'll get you next time.
Goodbye.
You better stop that evil!
Ew!
Bro, there's nothing I can do.
Like, what do you want me to do?
I'm just a little guy.
I'm literally just a little guy.
I think I improved a lot, though.
He's not looking at me.
Oh, thank god!
Okay!
We lost two, though.
That's okay.
No!
Oh, god.
Oh, my...
No!
I had one percent!
I did the...
Okay, it wouldn't matter if I lived.
We were all dead, anyway.
It didn't matter, chat.
We were all dead during that part.
I tried.
I did.
Gsharko, thank you for the thousand bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
Will we see Marble Rivals pros where you do?
Can you mention the future?
No, I don't think Marble Rivals pros know who I am.
I'm just...
I'm just a little guy.
I'm not that...
I'm, like...
Oh, wow!
Please!
Ah, please!
Ah!
Oh, my god!
It's actually huge!
Please!
Bro, where is he?
Where is he?
Holy shit!
Oh, my god!
That was the biggest ult of his fucking life.
And I was the only one that could secure it for him.
Jesus Christ, that was a huge ult for him.
We have...
We have to hold this for two minutes!
Yeah, I...
Yeah.
Yeah!
Oh, I'm trying my best to keep you alive, Rocket.
Hahaha!
There we go!
Please, give me, like, a little poke.
Give me...
Give me a little...
Literally one fight and that's it.
We have, like, one fight to live.
I'm playing out of my mind right now.
I'm, like, sort of locked in, but sort of not.
Like, because I'm...
I'm never locked in when I'm streaming.
I'm just gonna let you guys...
I'm gonna be brutally honest with you guys.
I'm gonna be so truthful right now.
If I'm online, it's not...
Oh my god.
This is bad.
Please, play on this.
Please.
This is literally it.
Play...
Play on my ult.
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the reload.
I gotta reload.
Can...
Maybe kill him?
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh no!
No!
There was nothing!
I was so low!
I was so low already.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking heading over.
I'm heading over.
We have again!
No!
We didn't touch!
Oh my god.
I was so...
I was playing such a good game too.
Oh my god.
I was actually playing an insane game.
Holy shit.
That game was actually insane.
My team didn't touch.
Fucking feels bad.
Yeah, I played really well.
I think I played really well there.
Minus 25!
I got lost more than I came.
Oh my god.
Wait, I think Mac is ready.
All right, let's see.
I don't know if he's on now.
Oh, he is!
All right.
Okay, is he...
Did he just get in the game?
All right.
I queue up one more then.
Um, since I think you just started.
All right.
All right, we're gonna three stack.
In these hours.
All right.
Here we go.
No, it's not!
We're doing great!
It's not!
We're doing so good!
We don't need clown music.
I'm actually like playing the most insane game of my life right now.
Even though I'm not locked in.
I'm like not locked in.
I'm playing fucking insane.
Okay, I'm doing Hawkeye.
We got Hella?
Who the fuck said we got Hella?
I'm actually doing well.
Are you...
Fucking, I'm banning Hawkeye.
There's no way.
I...
I refuse.
I refuse to play against a Hawkeye.
Like...
I...
I don't care we wasted our bans.
I don't trust the enemy team.
I like...
I don't fucking care.
I cannot play against a Hawkeye.
Like, it actually tilts me.
It tilts me so hard.
It's actually one of the most tilting...
One of the most tilting characters to play against.
That's why like...
Oh my gosh.
It's...
It's so...
Like, it's not fun.
It's basically like...
Yeah, it's fun when you have the better Hawkeye.
But it's not fun when you're Hawkeye...
When your own team's Hawkeye is dog shit.
It's not fun.
Also, some guy, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
The way you say Hawkeye sounds like hot guy.
I mean, Jeremy Renner?
Jeremy Renner though?
Okay.
You guys might think like I'm playing really well, but I'm actually like...
Not...
Not locked in when I'm streaming.
When I'm like playing off stream, I play even better, which is pretty...
I'm just surprised that like I'm doing as well as I am on stream.
I think one of my favorite things about the Spider-Man meme is like people were like...
Um, Spider-Man, do something!
And then they're like, Spider-Man does not kill.
Jeremy Renner?
Fucking everybody was a Jeremy Renner kind of...
Oh, um...
I remember Venom was like, follow me, guys!
I did not follow.
I did not...
I'm scared.
I did...
I did not follow and I'm scared.
I'm scared right now.
Oh wait, he's one.
Nice.
Might need to work on my positioning 100%.
I think that's like my only...
My biggest weakness is my positioning.
I have good aim, but I don't know where the fuck to stand.
Like, sometimes...
Someone break this.
Someone please break this.
Please.
Okay, I can't break stuff right now.
Jesus Christ.
You guys okay?
Are you guys okay?
Are you...
Oh my god, are you guys okay?
Are you guys okay?
Are you guys...
Guys...
Are you guys healthy?
What...
What am I playing against?
What is this?
What...
That's okay!
Okay!
What the fuck is going on?
They're not okay.
They are not okay.
RoboKitty, thank you for the five gift subs!
Thank you, thank you!
I need them to break this.
I don't...
Like...
I want to climb.
I'm just a...
I'm just a dancer at that time.
Like, I'm just...
I'm literally just a dancer.
I can't...
Oh my god, he's so low.
Like, who's...
Where?
Where are people?
Where's my team?
Oh my god!
Just...
Dance here!
I can't find anybody.
I'm so good.
Where is everybody?
Oh my god, please!
I'm gonna stand here.
I feel safe in here.
Please just stand here.
Oh my god!
Where is everybody?
What is...
Where is anybody?
There's a gem!
Thank you for the five.
I hope you jump off.
Oh my god, you're so dumb!
Please!
What's going on?
Shit.
My boy Gem...
I don't know!
I don't know what happened!
What the fuck was that game?
I'm fucking...
What is this game?
No, our...
Their team is much worse than our team.
It's very surprising.
I'm like...
This cop is...
The fucking most terrible cop I've ever seen in my life.
And the third cop was somehow worse.
I don't understand how it was worse.
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
That is actually crazy.
This is a GM Diamond game.
Like, how the fuck...
How the fuck was it worse?
That fighter could've beaten anyone.
Okay.
He could've beaten me.
Like, I fucking don't understand this team.
Like, how...
They end up having a worse comp than that we have.
And like, there's no working together here.
There's absolutely no cohesion.
Hey, do you think he'll help me?
There we go.
He's one.
How?
How did we win this team fight?
We had three people that was literally looking at Iron Fist alone.
He dodged my fucking...
Please, that's crazy.
Please.
Please, just kill this magic.
Oh my god.
Yeah, look at...
I see the hit markers, but like...
That's fine.
I'm just gonna farm all the charge off with damage, I guess.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is going on?
What's going on?
Where's this fucking party?
From this...
Shit!
Okay, I'm alive.
I'm so alive.
Guys, being alive was so much more important.
That was so much more important.
I don't care.
I have to live.
That was targeted.
That was actually a hate crime.
Hey.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't know what your plan is, sir.
Oh, just to beat up...
Beat up her.
I'm fucking running.
Oh no!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Oh my god, I'm sorry for looking at you.
I'm so sorry.
I shouldn't have looked.
Oh my god, why did I look?
Don't keep, please.
I didn't know.
I didn't know that was gonna happen.
I just wanted to get out of there.
Please, Venom.
Venom!
I can surely heal without worrying about my teammates, right?
Oh, I should heal my teammates.
Oh.
Sorry.
I missed.
Sorry, I'm fucking...
Oh my god, sir.
Oh my god!
From one hit to the next!
Okay.
Like, I don't know.
Let's just...
Oh my god, like, what do I do?
Literally from one...
From one flanker to the second flanker.
Like, I just...
I just die.
Like, literally, it's just...
It's just you die.
Please, just kill him.
How does he have so much...
I'm just leaving.
Go.
I'm capping.
Guys, we didn't cap.
Oh, it's just Venom.
I like how we, like, shot four people and then none of us capped it.
We literally killed everybody and no one capped.
Alright.
We did that...
What the fuck was that game?
What the fuck?
Alright.
Alright, my duo might leave.
But that's okay.
We got...
We got Mac in.
Oh my god, did I got plus 16?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I got plus 16.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
How the fuck did I...
Oh, it's because I was in a diamond...
Mostly diamond lobby.
That's why.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, now I know.
It's because I was in a mostly diamond lobby.
That's why.
I was, like, so confused.
I was like, how the fuck am I getting lower ELO?
Okay, this time I really shouldn't get low ELO for this.
This is a GM3.
It's a GM2 lobby.
Yeah, yeah.
This is fine.
Do we just ban Hulk then?
That guy is a terrible Hulk if he's...
Okay, I'm banning Hawkeye.
I don't fucking care.
I'm banning Hawkeye.
I don't care.
I'm not playing against the Hawkeye.
Do not make me play against the fucking Hawkeye.
I swear to god.
I would...
I'm gonna freak out.
Bro!
My dude roasted me.
They're like, you're level 37.
Get a fucking life.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I can play Mantis.
Wait, is PvC xQc?
Oh my god.
Do we have xQc on our team?
All right.
Do we actually have to comp?
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm higher.
Okay, let's see.
Where's my push to talk?
Oh my god.
All right.
Let's see.
Mikebot.
Yeah, I'll put it at 75.
There we go.
All right.
I don't want him to yell at me.
So I'll comp.
His chat's gonna yell at me because I'm comping.
There's no winning.
I had to don't comp and I get roasted and then I comp and also get roasted.
Like, there's no winning.
There's no winning.
Real.
But if I win, then there's a win.
Then it'll be fine.
Yeah, if I win, then I get less roasted.
Upload.
Kill my clone.
All right.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
Now damage boost.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
I need to be careful because they have Ironman.
Ironman's so fucking scary.
But like, good play.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I'm trying to heal.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, you're so far from heals.
Okay.
I have to heal this.
I ulted.
Just push up.
Okay, it's fine.
Fuck one.
We're absolutely sublime, by the way.
Oh my god.
Behind us, behind us.
No, no, it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm backing up.
Oh,
goodbye, guys.
Where did he go?
Oh my god.
I don't know where he went.
I don't- where did he go?
Where did he go?
I was like, where did he go?
I was trying to fucking- trying to kill him for- Oh, she's low, she's low.
Hulk behind us.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's a huge ult.
Nice.
We could stagger Bruce if we want to.
Nope, guess we don't.
Oh.
I mean, of course he's on kick.
He literally had- gets like a fucking million dollar deal.
I would be on kick if I get a hundred million dollars.
I won't be on kick.
I mean, honestly, no.
Guys, I'm gonna be truthful with you.
If you get a hundred million dollar deal to stream on kick and it's not like an exclusive deal, I would 100- Like, I'm sorry guys, but like...
A hundred million dollars is a hundred million dollars.
I don't have heals for you.
Nope.
He has I ult.
And Ironman.
Yeah, I'm gonna be truthful with you guys.
Because if it's not an exclusive deal, like, it doesn't matter.
Careful of I- Ironman.
Goodbye.
This is funny.
Goodbye, you guys.
Goodbye.
Oh shit!
Okay, I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I can- I can ult this.
I ulting, I'm ulting.
Jeff's low too.
Wait, no ults, no ults.
We can fire him and leave him in Bruce form.
Or not.
Yeah, it's not.
We don't need it.
We don't- Careful of I.
Minus, minus!
Oh my god, it's okay, I'm okay.
I'm cocooning.
Oh, Mac, I can't keep you up.
I'm on him, get him, get him.
Goodbye.
Hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk, hulk!
He's solo.
Behind me?
I have Ironman.
He's half.
I'm on point.
See you guys.
I'm low.
Oh, I'm low.
Is he asleep?
Oh, he's solo.
Oh, I might be dead.
He's low, he's low.
I have ult here.
I'm gonna use it to stabilize.
Let's see if we can get picks here.
Um, Mantis one, Mantis didn't click once.
Find me.
Hulk one, Hulk one.
Strangers low.
Strangers low, but I don't know if I can live.
Strangers one, strangers one.
Hunter is half.
Let's go!
Yeah!
I'm so locked in.
I'm locked in.
I don't want to get flamed.
Yo, is that Albert Lally from Apex?
What's up, bro?
You're cooking, hold on.
Do you have a lot?
If I lose, it's not my fault.
You come stacking with the boys?
I'm just playing with Dirk.
Are you trying to play or what?
I don't know, I was just gonna see.
Bro!
I'm playing with Dirk.
Oh man, never mind.
Wow!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my God!
Bro!
It's alright, I told you I'm plan Z.
Guys, I told you guys.
I was on plan Z.
Holy crap!
I know my place, I've accepted it.
I have accepted my fucking place in the hierarchy.
Oh my God, I've accepted it.
This is my place.
Strange is low.
Hulk is sleeping.
Bro.
I don't have heals, I don't have heals.
Hulk is half, Hulk is one.
Strange is asleep.
Strange is half.
I'm gonna use this to engage.
Strange one, strange one, strange one!
Behind us!
Oh!
Oh hey, I'm back.
Guys, it's okay, I know my place.
I'm plan Z.
I'm plan Z, it's okay.
This is why I play these hours.
It's okay, I've accepted it, guys.
I've accepted it.
I say as I cry.
I close my eyes and cry.
Guys, I've accepted it, I swear.
Oh my God, that's crazy.
Oh my God, I'm alive, I was not paying attention.
I cannot hit you.
Strange is half.
Jesus.
Oh my God.
Panther behind us.
He's half, he's half, he's one!
Uh-oh.
I fucked up my sleep there.
Strange can die.
Hawkeye's ult.
Yeah, he has ult.
I have sleep, he's asleep.
Hawkeye's half.
Oh no.
I always get hit by the back.
I never live.
Always gets me.
Oh my God.
I can use my mantis ult to engage.
Oh, we got help here, Starlord.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I damaged booster, Starlord.
Strange is asleep, Strange is one!
There's Iron Man in front.
Hawkeye, Hawkeye, Hawkeye.
I'm ulting.
Okay, we should have three on cart.
Three on cart.
We can shred mantis.
I'm asleep.
That's huge, that's huge.
Iron Man behind, Iron Man behind!
No!
I'm spawning in back now.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
I still sleep.
Hello?
Where's Banner, Bruce, Bruce?
Yippee!
Alright, we did it.
Oh wait, we didn't do it, we didn't do it.
I'm fucking running in.
Yippee!
We did it.
He ulted.
Winners don't get flamed.
Yeah!
That's the only reason why I try.
I don't want to get flamed by xQc.
I would never join comps unless I'm like, do I want to get flamed or not?
And I'm like, I don't want to get flamed.
Are you fucking...
Are you serious?
I just needed 21.
Oh my god.
That's fucked.
That was so...
I can't believe they did that.
Okay.
Alright, let's...
Let's see.
Let's turn...
Let me just...
You know what that means, guys.
It's time to...
Turn voice chat off.
You know what that means.
Where is it though?
Where is my fucking thing?
Okay.
Voice chat.
Where the fuck... Oh, it's communication, right?
There you go.
There we go.
Thank you for 10 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you.
Back to this.
That's crazy.
Back to the grind.
Alright.
Let's see.
I mean, we do have a third.
Alright, we're one off the GM too.
Grind never stops.
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
Holy fuck.
Also, Pyroblast!
Thank you for 10 gifted subs!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
I'll never forget.
Oh my god.
Three instant... Three insta...
Fucking...
DPS pings.
I love it.
That's what you love to see.
Nah, I'm good.
Guys, I'm okay.
I'm so okay.
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
Thank you for those who were needed.
For the messed up roads.
Okay, I've accepted it.
There's tears behind...
Clenched out tears behind my eyes.
She lied as easily as she breathed.
Oh shit.
Whoops, sorry.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I was like...
I swear to god.
I hope that player is fucking garbage.
Compared to...
I play Rocky Raccoon.
Because we have...
Literally have two fucking...
Please call for infinite.
If you can.
Tears don't fall, they crash around me.
No, basically...
xQc asked...
Mac if he wanted to like...
Stack with xQc.
And then...
Mac was like...
I'm with Doki right now, unless you want to join us.
And then xQc was like...
Nah, I'm good.
It's a TLDR.
It's a TLDR of what happened.
No!
I was just like, it's okay.
I've accepted my place in...
In Marvel Rivals.
Most likely, this is a bad armor pack.
Just because like...
This might be a bad armor pack.
If they TP behind us, we're fucked.
Let's just hope I don't get fucked up.
Alright, I'm just putting this for Hella.
It'll be fine.
They're not gonna break my walls, right?
They're not gonna break it, right guys?
They're not gonna...
They're not gonna break my...
They're not gonna break my fucking tower, right?
It's fine.
They're not gonna break it.
They're not gonna break this.
That's the only thing I'm worried about.
They're just gonna break this.
My little thing here.
It's fine.
They don't know I'm up here.
They're okay.
It's safe.
I'm in my safe place.
I'm in my safe place right here.
It's fine.
I'm so healthy.
You're so healthy too.
You're so healthy.
I need to reload.
But you're so healthy.
You're so fucking healthy.
Oh my god.
Look at you go.
You're so healthy.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Okay.
You're still so fucking healthy.
Fucking here.
I just come in and go goodbye.
There you go.
I'm doing my job.
I'm doing my fucking job.
Let's go.
Back to my hidey hole.
The thing is, they can and they...
Okay, wait.
Did they break this?
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize this was broken.
I didn't realize they broke it.
I was like, wait a minute.
What the hell?
Okay.
There you go.
Come fucking live.
Live.
There you go.
You have infinite.
Oh my god.
Okay, we don't stand there.
Oh, that's a lot of stuff.
That's a lot.
Whoa.
I'm alive, but at what cost?
Good luck.
Alright.
Yes, I leave now.
Goodbye.
You know what?
I'm proud of us for living that long.
I don't have...
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm fucking crawling.
I'm a little rat.
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god.
Where did he come from?
I was a little rat.
Just a little rat having a good time.
Riding around.
I'm okay.
I need to wait until...
I need to wait until our fucking punisher is here.
Alright.
Use your infinite!
It's time!
Just shoot!
That's unfortunate.
That's so unfortunate.
That really is so unfortunate.
That he didn't...
He didn't just shoot.
Oh my god.
It's midnight!
Merry Christmas, everybody!
Merry Christmas!
Oh, is he Ironman?
Okay.
We have Ironman now.
We don't have a Hulk for this.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
You have infinite too.
Oh my god.
They have everything.
I'm staying here.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
That is not fine.
That is absolutely not fine.
I'm not okay.
Oh my god.
I lived for as long as I could there.
Guys, I think like...
I think we're getting DPS.
Oh, somebody's not doing their job.
Who is it?
Who's not doing their job?
I tried to fly up!
They don't know!
They knew.
I tried to...
Somebody's not doing their job.
Somebody's not.
Somebody's not doing...
Oh wait, they got...
Oh, 1 minute 45.
We have four DPS players.
And like...
Two of them are not doing their jobs.
I don't need to say their names.
I can literally just...
Damn, that's fucking...
They're like, you need Alvron.
Wait, is he gonna...
Okay.
Alright, I'll be cloaking daggers then.
Guys, I knew...
That's so fucked.
I needed like one point.
That is actually so fucked up to me.
I needed one point to be GM too.
That's so fucked up.
That's fine.
I'm fine.
I'm okay.
I don't need a comm anymore.
I'm so okay.
Guys, I just want to be GM too again.
That's really it.
We just need one good win streak.
And then we're fine.
Just one.
That's all I ask.
What the fuck?
Oh, he's like right behind us.
I was like, what the fuck was that?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, that's... yeah, that's awkward.
I feel like we need infinite right here.
I mean, he'll do it by himself over here.
Hey, guys.
I'm worried about us getting flanked over here.
Woah, Groot!
Woah!
Woah, you're fucking crazy.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I healed, though.
I healed.
Not like I didn't heal.
I did my job.
I think he might be dead.
Unless...
Geometry.
Oh, wait.
I shouldn't be fancy with that.
I was like, what if I just...
There we go.
Let me just...
Guys, I just think it's a team dip.
Not gonna lie.
I lowkey just think this is a hella team dip.
Like...
I think they're just better.
This hellion is just...
Guys, why did we not ban the two heroes that everybody always bans?
Guys, this is exactly why we banned those...
Those two exact heroes.
This is exactly why.
Goodbye, Hella.
Please don't look, Hella.
Please.
This is exactly why you banned Hella and Hawkeye!
I don't fucking care!
I don't care what other characters we play against.
It's always whoever has the better Hella and Hawkeye.
And my rank warrants, I do not want to throw all my rank warrants into two people.
Jesus Christ.
And I don't want my entire life dependent on two fucking people.
No!
Jesus, let him block him!
The rank warrants.
God.
That's okay.
We know this is just a team diff.
We know this is literally just...
Oh my god, Mac, are you winning?
I was.
It is what it is.
It is what...
Guys, I don't even...
Oh my god.
Groot, please.
Groot, Groot.
I can't heal all of that!
Literally, I don't do anything else but heal.
I don't do anything else but heal, you guys.
Please.
I swear to god.
Guys, all I do is just hold left click, guys.
I don't know what you want from me.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I don't even want to ult this because I feel like...
But like, what if Magneto just fucking dies?
What if he just dies?
We gotta keep going.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go, I guess.
It's fine.
That's fine.
I guess we'll just keep going.
Just keep playing.
Do you not like playing DPS?
Not in Healers Shooters.
Healers Shooters, because I'm...
I was originally a support main in Overwatch.
Like, knowing...
God.
Hella is always behind.
Like, I don't know what to say.
She is always behind.
Alright, there we go.
Goodbye.
We are Groot.
I'm fucking solo'd.
Oh my god, please.
Yeah, I have a feeling we're gonna die there anyway.
Alright, we just live.
I was not out healing all that shit.
I wasn't gonna heal that.
Simple geometry?
Is it gonna hit them?
Let's find out.
It's like...
When you're playing DPS and your support doesn't heal you as DPS, it's more tilting for me, because I play support.
Because I play support in high rank.
So I'd rather just play...
I don't wanna learn DPS just because of that.
It's just way too tilting to play.
I don't know, guys.
Like, I'll just commit to it.
I'm just gonna stand here, I guess.
This is where we live now.
Oh my god, but who's gonna fucking...
Oh my god, that was insane.
That was insane.
Oh, he's coming in.
He's coming in!
Oh, nope.
I was gonna die to that.
There was no living there.
Oh my god, let's keep going!
Let's keep going!
Let's go!
I'm not tired.
I feel like I have a lot of energy playing this.
Let's try to keep three on for time.
Alright, here I go.
I'm coming over.
I'm fucking coming over.
He's slowly floating over, guys.
There we go.
Your cloak is here.
Your cloak is here now.
Don't worry.
I did that.
I fucking knew it.
Okay.
Good luck, everybody.
Good luck, everyone.
If you live, you live.
Good luck, you guys.
Good luck.
I lived.
That was pretty neat.
Alright, let's go.
We're gonna use this.
I give up.
I can die.
Alright.
Oh, that's ours.
That's theirs, too.
Oh my god!
Stop!
Okay, you're...
Whoa!
You're alive.
You're so healthy.
Whoa!
I'm never letting go of left click.
Please.
No.
Hey, guys.
Hey, let's all chill.
I'm alive.
Yeah, I...
The fact that we made it this far is good enough for me.
It's good enough.
Honestly, this match should have ended during the first point.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, let's see who was the most under... I actually don't know.
Because we swapped DPS and everything, too.
Oh my god.
I love this game.
Wait.
Are you R or no?
I'm gonna make Mack leader.
I can't be leader.
It's just the lobby.
You're leader.
Because I'm bad at this.
Alright.
I made him leader.
I don't wanna deal with fucking readying it up and everything.
Too...
If I get 22 points, I make it in.
We're just gonna put it all on the fact that maybe I'll get 22 points.
You know?
Maybe I won't get fucked over.
That's not too much to ask for.
I just need 22 points.
Can't be that bad.
22 points?
Whoa.
That's fun.
I believe.
I didn't get the...
Don't say that, guys.
We just gotta...
We're just getting 22 points.
Can you actually hear what they're saying?
What voice chat people were saying?
Or was it too quiet?
Because I turned it up all the way to the max, I'm pretty sure.
Let's see.
Yeah.
I could turn it up even more.
Barely?
Okay, it's still too quiet.
Alright, I'll turn it 100 then.
I didn't know you guys could actually hear them.
Oh, so you didn't hear when fucking xQc was like, nah?
So, you know, that's good.
That's fine.
Thank God.
No, we heard that!
Okay, out of everything, you could hear...
Okay, that's actually fucked.
You could hear that, but not anything else.
Not anything else.
We should've just lied to her.
I like how like, you could hear everything else, but you could not hear anything.
You could hear the fact that he fucking roasted me.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
It's okay.
It's fine, she said brokenly.
Alright, this is it.
This is it, guys.
How do we have two fucking two Iron Man players?
That's crazy.
That's fine.
I'll never have another Hawkeye.
I don't care.
I don't care if I have a Hawkeye main.
I don't fucking care.
Okay, Bruce Banner.
Oh, fuck off Oh, because we have two Iron Man one tricks.
That's actually crazy.
Okay, I'll tell you the story about the banning thing.
I got over it within a day, but I was so sad that day, because like I was having a really bad day already.
Oh, yeah, I remember why I had a really bad day.
I was like, I'm gonna use a form of escapism and play Marvel Rivals.
And then so I was like, we have a duo and then like basically what happened was that we had a Groot one trick and no, I got over it really quick because I needed to vent that out because I was like really fucking sad about it when it happened.
Like I literally was crying like when it was happening.
Because like it was like I was already having a really bad day.
So like I didn't need that extra shit.
So like I was just like okay, I'm gonna...
So we got a Groot one trick and it was so funny because we had two Groot one tricks and then and then like we were all like teasing the two Groot one tricks and everybody was like locking in Groot but then we banned Psylocke.
It was like five people chose to ban Psylocke and I was like, he he what if I ban Groot?
And then I ban Groot but it's not majority.
Banning wise is not majority.
It's literally like, it's random chance.
It's like a probability.
Like it's literally a probability for bans.
So it's not even like majority.
Oh my god, yes we got him.
So that's why I was like it was so fucked because like literally I'm Groot.
And then like obviously my team got so fucked.
I didn't know that.
I thought because this is the first time I had a ban that was like not Oh my god.
That's fine.
I'm just gonna I'm gonna fight on point because like I'm scared.
Like I'm scared.
And then so like I was like, oh okay we should be fine right?
But then it actually it flipped to... Jesus what?
Like why?
It flipped to Groot.
And then my team was so mad at me.
They all like yelled at me and was like leave.
Just leave.
And were like yelling at me and was like you you threw the game.
Just fucking dodge.
And they all kept sitting on spawn and they wouldn't play the game.
And I was so like depressed and sad about it because I was like I didn't know.
I even like apologized I was like I'm so sorry.
I didn't know it was like Oh my god Please let me look at you!
Okay I I couldn't.
I was looking at I was looking at the Ironman If I knew I would have pressed.
I was looking at the Ironman so like couldn't And then And then like they were like sitting in spawn.
Like two people were sitting in spawn and was like just yelling at me to leave and everything.
So that's why like it like fucked me up cause I was like I had like a really bad day.
I was like and I like cried because of it because I was like I don't know anything Please get down!
Okay Okay I can't save that They used Lunala too so that's fine I guess.
I'm leaving Goodbye Whoa!
I'm so scared He wants to get me
So yeah that's basically what happened Yeah he's fucking dead And then like even like my duo was like oh you're trolling Why did you do that?
And I was like I didn't know!
So like really That's why I was like really sad about it.
But I'm okay now I'm okay now.
Cause if I didn't have like a really bad day I would've been okay.
Like I would've been like uh fine Like I wouldn't care.
Like I'd just be like whoop that's- AHH Okay I'm gonna focus up
And then yeah like I literally like left the queue.
I left the- like I left the game cause everybody kept like telling me to leave so I just left the game Miss Miss Oh
Alright Okay I'm gonna try My team.
My team's not doing so well My team's not doing so well Yeah.
And then I didn't realize my fucking thing.
My tweet went like lowkey viral in the Marvel Rivals community.
Cause it ended up being a fucking debate about one tricks in I was just like I was just ranting about my day like I was just playing I was just like I was just ranting about my fucked up day.
Yeah It ended up being like non- like Marvel Rivals play like community was like it got into the algorithm Are you fucking- okay I actually need to focus.
Sorry guys.
I I actually- I need to focus guys.
I almost fucked that up Okay Lock in.
Lock in.
Lock in time.
I'm sorry.
I'm not locked in Okay
Alright.
Lock in time This is incredible I have to put on a show because our Magneto would have died and now they're gonna have They're gonna have Bucky out so I'm gonna- oh that's huge that's huge That's so huge Oh god Oh god Not again Oh my god Oh my god I'm running.
I'm running.
I'm running I'm running.
I'm running
Oh I'm running.
I'm running.
I'm running I'm running Oh Bucky is so low though
Oh he's so low
Nice that's two Can we go?
Alright
Please Please kill him There we go Oh fuck
Okay Alright Just Please fight him He's right here.
Just whip him
No I missed
Oh my god please I don't know what's going on I don't know either Me too I don't know what's going on either I don't know.
I'm so scared They have spider-man too Yeah you need to counter spider-man You're gonna dump on me every time Just focus spot heals please Oh that's fine that's better for us
Oh spider-man Dude their mantis is playing way out of position Wolverine coming in He's up Lucky Lucky one Getting healed Watch out strange Everything will be fine I feel so healthy Everything will be fine Luna Look at me Tire lock on our left side
Is our lock behind now?
Literally inting me.
Oh my god.
Just 1v1 me.
Bro, please!
No, I couldn't!
There's a...
Okay,
I called out a silenced...
And I got...
Nothing.
And she was in the air.
Double shit for me.
We had to do so much!
We had to do so...
Okay, I did lock in.
I was trolling the first half, not gonna lie.
I was actually...
I was trolling the first half!
Okay, I'm locked in for real.
I had to rant out what happened there.
Alright, this time...
This time...
I'm not gonna...
No, I'm not gonna troll the first half.
I was not locked in.
I literally have the orb on him.
She's definitely gonna go Psy.
So like...
Probably gonna be Psy...
Wolverine, right?
Right.
It's fine.
When will Ironman...
Why would Ironman ult the support like they did to me?
That was so sad.
That was so fucking sad.
When will...
When would I...
Just watch that happen to the other support?
But yeah, that...
That...
When that happened...
That's when I learned it was not majority vote.
Like...
You would assume it was majority vote.
But it's literally random probability.
It was like probability.
And it flipped to my...
It like...
The fact that it flipped...
To like...
They're not portaling?
No, they're not.
I'm so confused.
I'm trying to like...
Be aware of what they're gonna...
I'm like a little scared.
God,
I can't see.
Please.
I had to get off high ground for that.
I was so scared.
They are portaling to the left here.
There's people behind.
This is the place to watch.
Oh, my frames are dropping here.
There's someone behind us.
There's... My frames are dropping.
He's on health pack over here right now.
Oh...
I'm sorry, I got you.
I don't got you, I guess.
Oh my god.
What?
Okay.
Jesus.
Oh no, I got fucking pushed.
Just back up, back up.
Oh, this is bad.
I don't think I can live, can I?
That's fine.
Until I see...
Oh...
Okay.
I thought I could get it off.
Look at the cart.
It's all good.
Oh my god.
That's bad.
I didn't realize he was gonna ult that.
You always knew to ult the Psylocke ult.
That's unlucky.
One heal, one heal, one heal.
Oh my god.
That's unlucky.
Okay, we got it.
I'll let Mac ult first then.
Knowing that.
Yeah.
Be like...
For me, I would always do Luna, Psylocke.
Cause it's just...
Mantis does not guarantee...
Oh!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm getting 2v1'd right now.
I don't know, whatever.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Yeah, dude.
Play Iron Man.
Oh my god.
Wait, dude.
We do have 2...
We have 2 Iron Man 1-tricks.
How?
Okay.
What are the odds?
Actually, what are the odds?
What are the odds of having 2 Iron Man 1-tricks in a lobby?
I think that's it, yeah.
That's crazy.
Okay.
I'm scared here.
Oh,
fuck!
Why can't they do that?!
Why does that happen to me?!
Every time!
I don't understand!
It always hits me!
Guys, I didn't want to be GM too.
Right now.
I didn't want...
Iron Man 2...
Jarvis type Iron Man...
Guys, I fucking love this game.
Oh my god.
At least it's minus 18.
You know, at least it's minus 18.
12 deaths and...
Okay, not gonna lie.
Elka should not be saying shit because he literally had perma-orb this entire time.
Like, he had...
He had like...
He...
Oh my god, I'm surprised I even hit 20k healing.
He never...
He got to live throughout everything because I literally orbed him throughout it.
True.
He can't save.
I have less deaths because of it.
I'll join VC after the next game because I feel bad.
At least the Iron Mans avoided each other.
That's the best part.
They avoided each other so I don't have to deal with that bullshit.
Okay, I was gonna say another Iron Man player.
Okay, I can join VC after this game.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy.
That's actually...
I can't believe...
I can't believe we had two Iron Man 1 tricks.
Okay, I...
I locked in after the first half, guys.
You can't admit that I didn't lock in after the first half.
It's just...
My team couldn't...
My team couldn't do anything with it after that.
We got no Hulk players?
I like how I complain about all the support mains.
Now I actually just have DPS players.
You know, I assumed that I would have one tank player on my team.
Alright, I'll go...
I'll go...
I'll go Cloak.
I don't know if I wanna go Cloak or...
Okay, he went Loki.
Okay, guys.
Guys.
Come on.
Come on, guys.
We just need one more healer.
Guys.
Come on.
Let's all be flexible here.
Let's all be super flexible here.
Wow.
Come on, everybody.
Let's just...
Guys.
Yippee.
So much support.
Yeah.
We totally got this.
That 99 was so fucking cursed, honestly.
That 99 was the most cursed shit.
It just went downhill after that.
After I got 99, it went downhill.
Alright.
Here we go.
I run.
I don't think he's gonna realize that there's not gonna be a lot of heals.
With...
With fucking...
Loki Iron Man.
Oh my god, he's alive.
Holy shit.
Okay, nevermind.
Didn't matter.
Oh my god.
Okay.
They still captured?
Who got off?
Who fucking got off the point?
Oh my god, Hawks.
No!
Please.
Please, Outcast.
I have to pretend nobody other... no one else exists.
Please.
I literally got all in one fight.
Okay.
Alright, I'm going in then.
Alright.
Let's fucking go.
Woah!
Okay, I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh, they have Born Again.
Guys.
Guys, I don't know what else to do.
I don't know.
I don't know if I have enough healing for Adam... Adam... Loki.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Merry Christmas.
They're taking us away from me.
Oh, alright.
Cool.
I think we just gotta avoid...
I know there's a few people I would definitely avoid.
We just got...
We just gotta channel our voice properly.
This is where people die.
Oh, he gave up.
I like how Mac just stood still.
Oh.
Oh, there's nothing I can do.
We need two... Yo, someone else go healer.
We need two tanks.
I don't play healer.
I'd rather tank this.
Now all the support players are gone.
Hey guys.
I don't need to be GM too.
I do.
I do need to be GM too.
But hey guys.
Guys, I just need one good win streak, guys.
That's all I need.
Please.
I have a Christmas karaoke tomorrow and I did not prep anything.
I literally just going in for it.
I'm fucking blind.
I did not prep a single thing for my...
I literally decided what I was going to do like today.
I literally just was like, what do I do?
Oh man, my original plan got delayed.
So like, what the fuck do I do?
Wait, did we make a portal?
And then...
Like...
Nothing was said?
I'm just going to stay here.
I feel safe down here.
He did not feel safe down there.
Hey.
Oh my god, he has a turret.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking...
I don't even know if he's going to live.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
I didn't want to be down there anyway.
Where is my team?
Guys, I think...
I think this is a team diff right there.
Like...
Simple geometry, guys.
Yeah, this is definitely a team diff right there.
No, it's literally just a team diff.
Where the fuck does this portal go?
What the fuck?
Guys, can we not kill one guy?
Can we not?
Okay, I guess not.
We can't kill one guy.
I like how Iron Man player is not playing Iron...
No, there's no...
The reason why there's no reason to play Iron Man...
Is that there's no Hulk.
Plus the fact it's the worst fucking support for Iron Man.
Legitimately.
There's no reason to play Iron Man with this support lineup.
Because like, he's not going to get healed.
I literally can't look at him because I'm main support.
Alright, I float away.
Alright.
It's okay.
It was just a GG by character select.
That's really it.
It's just...
It happens.
Yeah.
There's... There's like...
There's nothing you can do.
It just happens.
Like, I... What do I do?
Now it's three more games.
Now...
Now, why does Grandmaster look like Silver?
Because people have egos.
People have fucking egos.
That's why.
Just don't heal next time.
No one wants to be support!
What do you mean?
You can't say, just don't heal next time.
When no one was willing to play support.
Like...
Holy shit.
4722 damage and you talk.
That's actually crazy.
I can't believe he said that.
I can't believe.
He's like...
It wasn't blaming me.
It was blaming our other support partner.
Because like, our other support literally failed.
He literally failed and was like...
And then he was like, can somebody else go support?
I'm a tank player.
Or, I'm a tank slash DPS player.
And he was the only tank DPS player that was willing to fail and flex.
And then, oh yeah, we got a call.
Got a call.
Okay, I need to get my mute button because I like talking to you guys too.
I need to register the mute button.
Let's see.
Because that's why I also don't like streaming when I'm in a stack sometimes.
Because I like talking to you guys while I'm playing.
But then, I know people would just mute their own.
But then it's like, you know, you're muting.
You have to mute and talk at the same time.
And play.
And there's just so many buttons.
I hate that.
I hate that there's so many buttons.
But people are like, you gotta do it.
Unassign.
Toggle mute.
What's a good button for toggle mute, guys?
What button should I use for toggle mute?
I guess F?
Is there anything on F?
Does Loki...
We have to do cloak and dagger.
Loki...
Loki raccoon is not strong enough.
I swear to god.
I was gonna say we cannot keep doing another.
Maybe F?
No, they always ban those supports.
It's just...
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'll do F.
So like, I can just press F next to me.
I can't do it because like, my...
Let's see.
Is there anything on F?
No, okay.
That's good.
Alright.
I can toggle mute.
I have toggle mute.
I gotta remember whenever I'm toggling mute.
Hello!
Our games were fucking terrible.
Yeah.
Oh wait, I don't know if they can hear you.
Because I don't know if I have to screw this up.
Oh boy.
Where are you?
Are you...
Are you Ironman?
Okay, you're not getting healed.
Because we're low-key and we're low-key cloak and dagger.
Yeah, it'll be fine.
Oh my god, my toggle mute doesn't work so you're gonna hear me talk to my chat.
That's fine.
I think my... I forgot to do mine too.
My toggle mute doesn't work.
Oh, please.
No, my beam ran out.
I'm just saying, you're not gonna live a lot because our heal situation is not great.
It'll be okay.
Really?
I don't feel good.
I don't know, this team comp is fucking terrible, not gonna lie.
Punisher low.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking start left-clicking.
They're very low.
Thor one, Thor one.
Nice.
Alright, hey, we lived.
Sexy, good shit.
Did he just say you were sexy?
Damn right.
Damn.
I...
I was hitting crazy backshots on their backline.
Cool.
Did he get... did he get pregnant?
Oh, maybe.
Oh my god.
Oh shit, there's two, there's three, there's three.
Come here.
I'm so dead.
They have no healers, what a bull.
Oh, we're not... I can't heal.
Thor, chase me.
Uh, you have no healers too.
So you have to fight without a healer.
Loki and I are coming over now.
I'm gonna ult when I'm in.
Is it worth ulting?
Actually, no, you guys got it.
I don't think so.
Oh, maybe it is worth it.
Yeah, I'm gonna ult, I'm gonna ult.
Stun on my thing.
Oh.
I'm just trying to hit Rakan with my ult and he didn't die.
Okay.
We got the cloak, but...
I don't know if we can live.
Oh my god, why is my toggle muted now?
Okay, it only works if I tab into my Discord.
Yeah, you have to restart Discord and launch it as admin.
Oh!
That's what I was doing the other day.
Okay.
Alright, that makes sense.
I'm gonna heal you.
Just wait and get a full push.
Alright.
Oh.
Fine, they have...
They have...
They have Eye, Thor and Eye.
I'm fucking dead.
Yeah, I couldn't... I didn't know where you were.
I didn't know you were looking for me.
He's so low.
Starlord's actually one.
Please heal me, Loki, please.
Come, Starlord.
I got you, I got you.
I'm healing you through the Thor and Strange.
Oh!
No, he Eyed me.
I'm dead here, I think.
Strange is low.
I'm trying to keep our Loki up.
They have one healer, they have one healer.
I have ult.
I'm ulting him.
Stand in my ult, please.
I got Punisher with that.
Thor one, Thor one, Thor one, Thor one.
Starlord's one.
He's one, he's solo.
I got him.
There's still a rocket around here, though.
He's dead.
Alright.
Damn.
Okay, chat, the reason why he has reverb is that I have him unmuted in-game.
Please, pick me, ding it!
Okay, fuck you, I guess.
Who cares about you, I don't.
Um, I don't know where you are.
I'm looking at 200 people at the same time.
And then our fucking Loki got Bruce Banner'd.
I don't think our Hulk plays Hulk.
He definitely does not play Hulk.
I killed one.
No, I'm out of juice!
Oh!
Where are you?
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I...
You're getting punished, sweetheart.
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Who's over there?
Oh!
Fuck it!
Fuck it.
Um, Loki fucked up his ult.
That's fine.
Cloak is one.
Alright, I'm cloaking for it.
Cloak is low.
Cloak is so low.
Standing by ult because they also have ult.
They have eye.
I'm looking to pick us apart.
Please, Hulk, please!
All you do is feed!
I can't heal you, I have to heal my feeding Hulk.
I assassinated the support, that's all I can do.
Oh my god, Dean, please don't die.
Please!
Okay.
Okay, that's cool.
He didn't do anything with that.
Okay.
Kobe!
Messed it.
That's cool.
That's alright.
That's fine.
Strange can die.
Oh, that's not fine.
Hulk is half.
Starlord behind.
I don't know what to do here.
I'm dead.
Yeah.
Starlord's in ult behind, Kurt.
I don't know what to do here.
You're doing so great, you're fine.
I'm not.
Okay, I'm going to restart my Discord.
I'm trying.
No.
Alright, restarting Discord.
I'll be right back.
I'm going to do the same thing.
Alright, let me restart.
Oh my god, I can't even...
I can't close the application!
I have to force quit it because I'm in game!
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, I can.
I just need to tab out.
Oh my god.
That's why my frames are dropping.
I had people...
I had max stream on this entire time.
I'm...
I'm going to freak out.
Alright, we're on as admin.
Nice.
Oh my god.
That's why my frames are dropping.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay, I should be able to tab mute.
Hello?
Okay, let me try.
Yes, it works!
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Guys, okay, now I can talk to you guys.
I can...
Now I can talk to you.
Oh my god.
I'm a professional streamer, everybody.
Oh yeah, I'm supposed to fix this group too.
Wait, can you guys hear him or do I need to up the volume, chat?
Do I need to up his volume?
I actually don't know.
Let me know.
Can hear?
Okay, I'll up it.
Up it by like 40.
Alright, I'm...
We're so ready, we're so locked in.
Alright, now I'm locked in.
Wait, can you say something?
I want to check if the volume's okay.
Yeah.
You'll hear me yapping.
Okay, guys, what about now?
Okay, now I can...
Oh my fucking god.
You good?
Alright, nice.
Left, thank you.
Okay, I'm healing, I'm healing.
I have to look at a million people, but I'm doing it.
That's better.
Alright.
Oh, this is why I don't like playing with Magneto when like Mantis and Luna being bad.
This is why.
This is fine.
Is he too loud?
Okay.
Oh my god, I...
I'm fucking healing, I'm healing, I'm healing.
I'm trying my best to keep everybody alive.
Okay.
Okay, good stuff.
We're not on Hulk anymore.
Yeah, that's like... I don't know if that was the choice.
I think I'm dead here.
Yeah, I'm just gonna jump off.
I'm just gonna jump off.
Okay.
That's fine.
I had to because... I had to because like there was nowhere for me to go.
I literally was gonna get staggered if I walked there.
That's alright, guys.
GM2 was really cool being there for a bit.
It was really fucking cool.
Ever since our third left, everything went downhill.
Always just play.
It was all downhill.
Okay, I thought they were closer, not gonna lie.
I legitimately thought they were closer.
Guys, why are we giving so much free space?
Fuck, I'm walking in.
Down in Darkblade?
Okay.
I'm in!
Whoa!
Surely Thor dies.
Oh my god.
Don't fucking...
I killed their Sarlord.
Nice.
If you need... Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
He's low.
The strange is low.
Hey, I'm so excited to hold this for four minutes.
This is gonna be great.
I'm so excited.
Guys, being GM2 for like...
For like the start of the stream and everything going downhill?
That's fine.
That's so fine.
I love Mario.
I feel like the strange is about to look for an eye.
No, 100%.
No, he is.
He has an eye.
He does.
He got one guy, but I think that one guy's dead.
Okay!
Woo!
Okay.
Okay, that's cool.
Does anyone touch?
Can anyone touch?
I don't know.
I'm heading over here.
I'm not getting out, but I'll head over.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh yeah, I also have a third coming in.
I think we might need it.
Yeah, we might.
We might need some reinforcements.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
It's okay.
It was really cool being GM2 yesterday.
It was really cool.
It's alright, I'm back in GM3 as well.
We're back.
Okay.
Alright, let's not get... don't queue up.
I got a third.
Alright.
Oh wait.
Oh wait, give me leader so I can invite.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, can I not invite if I'm leader?
Oh, is it because he's in game?
Oh my god, get the fuck out of that game.
Get... when is game over?
I thought he was ready.
He's like, next game I'm ready.
Alright guys.
I can't... oh wait, he's in practice range?
Why can't I invite?
Oh, because he's in... okay.
Do I... oh wait, he's...
Oh, he's ready.
Okay, get out of practice range.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh.
I'm gonna make him leader.
You're... you're leader.
Alright, let's add him to the call.
Okay, I'll add him to the call.
Alright, things will be different now.
Things will be so different.
It'll be so... okay, we're the three GMs.
Okay, no, we have an extra GM player, I was gonna say.
Okay, we're gonna climb this time.
We had some bad luck.
We had some...
We had some really bad luck earlier, but it'll be different now.
Our other third left and then things went downhill.
You're...
It'll be different, right?
You'll be the third that brings it back, right?
Yes, we win these.
Alright, okay.
Who do you play?
I play...
He plays everything.
A lot of things.
He basically can flex to anything.
No, they banned Psylocke.
Fuck.
Okay, you can flex too.
I saw you flexing.
I can flex, but like...
I'm banning Hawkeye, I swear to God.
I'm not playing against a Hawkeye.
Oh, dude, it's gonna be a 50-50.
Please, I know.
Ruben, why did you ban Hella?
I'd rather play against a Hella than a fucking Hawkeye.
Oh, thank fucking God.
We're gonna play with a fucking Hella in the lobby, bro.
I'd rather play against a Hella than a Hawkeye.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
I'll play whatever the team needs.
Oh, they banned Psylocke, my baby.
Alright, I'm playing...
Oh my God, I really don't want to.
They don't have flankers, right?
Oh my God.
Wait a second.
It's gonna be okay.
Like, there's no way it can get worse.
Alright.
I'm playing tank, I guess.
We lock the fuck in, we win these.
Play what you want.
Oh my God, that's so kind of Imdrubbq.
Oh my God, do you think he actually is?
He's picking Thor on defense, so maybe.
He's picking Thor on defense, he's gotta be.
What could possibly go wrong?
Nothing will go wrong.
I don't mind being Diamond 1 again, I've been there so many times.
I'm like okay with that.
We're not falling that far today.
I literally need three losses to be back there.
I'm okay with being back there, guys.
No, no, no, we're not going back.
I'm so sad that they always ban Luna, man.
It's like, they don't want fun.
Where's our Thor?
Oh, there he is.
He's fucking in there, bro.
I need to heal our Thor.
Oh, there hell is one bottom left.
Oh, I should grab Mega.
Jesus Christ, okay, alright, Panther.
Oh my God, I'm a hero.
I'm trying to keep our Thor alive.
I'm trying to keep both our tanks alive.
Thor is dead, Thor is dead, Thor is dead.
Unbelievably dead.
You're so dead too, maybe.
No, no, no, I live these, I'm here.
But I do got a kite.
I'm dead?
Punisher.
I don't think we can contest.
Are we contesting?
Yeah, we don't touch, we don't touch.
Yeah, I was gonna say, there's no way.
Oh, wait a second, John Power?
You're dead.
Nope, no, I live these.
Okay, but I don't.
No, no, no, you also live these.
Do I?
I got you, I got you with the Zarya bubble, don't worry.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna ult forward.
Okay, big.
I'm gonna do it.
He ulted forward too.
Hold up.
Just play my thing, just play my thing.
Okay.
I'm in it.
I don't know, oh, they are rocket.
I'm solo healing, I'm solo healing, I'm solo healing, I'm solo healing.
There's top right, top right, top right.
Oh, I'm dead to Hella.
I'm backing up.
Oh my god, guys, I'm gonna fucking freak out here.
There's a Hella turret left, I can't heal you guys, there's a Hella turret left.
I'm chilling, I live these.
You're not chilling, you are so not healthy.
You're not healthy at all.
Neo, next time I live those.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're on Strange now, okay, we're good.
Oh, thank god, he figured it out.
Thank fucking god, bro.
Oh, I'm getting killed too, I'm getting killed too.
Nice!
I'm coming over.
Alright, I'm gonna shift out.
Oh, we're down one then, I think.
They have no DPS with them, they can walk up.
I'll help pick top left.
Yeah, I don't know, I think our Strange might...
Oh no!
From Trunk, you could have just...
Oh my god, please!
He's alive.
I'm running here to help him real quick.
I'm not ulting this, I'm not ulting this.
I'm just...
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
I got you.
I'm dying over here.
Please kill the Penny at least.
Dude, I'm like babying over JonPower.
I gotta make sure this guy lives.
Guys, we're alive!
Bubbling him up, cooldown.
Oh my god!
And the Barbarabas!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And someone help Jon!
I can run.
I wish I could!
Jon!
Please!
Rocket, why?
Why did you just run?
Jump hook.
I need help on left.
There's a Hella behind us.
Wait, who's back there?
Our Rocket looked at two DPS players.
You know, I'm...
I'm dead.
I can ult on point.
Where am I going?
What is over here?
There's nothing over here.
Is it worth ulting on point?
Is it worth it?
Maybe?
No, never.
No, it's not.
The stream just blocked me on point.
Dude, why is there no health pack over there?
Guys, I think I'm dead.
I can try and...
I can cloak you.
I can try and cloak you guys.
Wait, I need to give that guy a little...
They're cloaking you guys.
JonPower makes it out.
Jon is...
Oh, please stream.
Guys, I love...
I can't wait to fight this for minutes.
I'm going to ult it for it.
When the car is closer, I'm going to do it now.
This is the turret...
They're bastion turreting on car, bro.
Yeah, I ult it for it.
I ult it for it.
We kill him.
He's one.
I killed him.
I'm very low behind you.
Hella behind you.
I can't look.
The hella and cloak are just flanking together with the cloak.
Oh, that's huge.
That's huge.
Yeah, but I can't do anything about it.
What the fuck?
It's just literally me and Magneto.
And it's just going to be me.
Oh, that is insane.
Mac, I saw that.
Little three-tap person.
I saw that.
I'm dead.
Okay.
Dude, their cloak is a demon.
What?
Yo, what's up, guys?
We're locked from the right side.
Oh, wait.
He trapped us in spawn.
Yeah.
We can't go.
This is...
I mean, I literally can't do anything because I'm always healing.
I'm literally stuck in spawn.
Oh, no.
John.
John's doing stuff.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
I got all of them dead.
Yeah, I am so good.
I'm healing.
It's just you and John.
I'm doki.
I got you with a shield!
Okay.
Now we live these.
I'm so good.
I have health all of a second.
I'm ulting her.
Yeah, just hope...
We have all the tanks alive.
And Rock is literally healing.
My shield got shattered instantly.
I have bubble in six.
I have all in four percent.
If you guys can live...
Guys, point, point, point, point, point, point, point, point, point, point, point, point, point, point.
I got it, I got it.
No!
I got killed by Penny.
I'm alive!
I couldn't get in.
I got killed by Penny.
Oh, man.
I think like...
I don't know.
Why is it three and seven?
I think it's because he's drunk.
No!
All right, team.
How many shots have we had tonight?
I'm going to go low-key.
I think...
I don't think Cloak's the answer.
I don't think...
I don't think Cloak is the answer.
He's drunk.
Oh, no, bro.
You know what, dude?
Maybe I should have gotten Captain America when I was on board.
Maybe that's what went wrong.
Maybe, yeah.
Maybe.
I don't...
I think we know who to avoid, that's for sure.
Do we want to let him solo tank and I go DPS?
We can try.
Sure.
At this point, anything can work.
Like...
We need...
We need anything.
Today the real Degens are playing because it's Christmas.
They're on Penny and Strange, right?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll go Punisher.
I could go Adam, actually, with this.
I don't know.
Oh, their Strange is low already.
I'm gonna fucking walk.
Fucking turret.
Alright.
We're healing you.
We're healing you so hard.
Woah.
Oh, their Penny is low.
We're healing you so hard.
Oh my god, you are...
Ah, shit.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't feel too good.
Oh, fuck.
It's alright.
This is not...
This is just the warm-up game, right?
No, no, no.
We're winning this game.
Okay.
Okay, I'm shooting him with my clone.
Turret's gone.
Punisher's dead.
Nice.
He's gonna get revved.
Yeah.
I'm reloading my heals.
Okay.
I got a little scared.
I love the Punisher.
Alright, this is it.
We just...
Oh, here.
I got you.
Yeah.
Hey, see?
Look.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Everything is so healthy.
Oh, perfect.
There's people behind us.
There's a health pack.
The hell is that?
That guy's a freak.
What is that guy doing?
Yeah, I don't know what the fuck he's doing.
I don't know.
Guys, I just realized my mute button is on F, so every time I press F, I fucking switch.
Wicked.
Yeah.
Whoops.
SuperFishy9000 is eating shit right now.
Penny's one.
I am healing.
I'm gonna clone you and then see what happens.
I'm gonna peel one.
Okay.
Hold on there.
Alright.
I'm hella now.
Yeah, hella no bird.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
It's gonna be so funny because they're gonna be like, wait, why do we have another hella?
Dude, she almost shit on me, bro.
Battlefield ready again.
Alright, MS3 on part.
They are not taking this high ground.
They're TPing, they're TPing.
Oh, they're TPing, nevermind.
I'm ulting.
I have...
I killed the Punisher.
No!
I got killed by their hella.
Oh, their Penny and their Cloak are low behind us.
Yeah, but we lost both supports.
Yeah, they just had...
Wait, I misclicked.
What did he do?
He...
I think he ulted.
Did he ulted?
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
He's just a silly little guy.
Maybe they'll shoot this guy.
They shot him.
Oh, their hella is just chilling top right.
Ow.
Oh, they have a Bucky now too.
The Bucky is running it down.
It's fine.
So is our Strange, but that's okay.
Their Cloak and hella are playing together up top.
Oh my god, that guy...
There we go.
There we go, I kept our Strange alive.
Surprisingly.
I'm pushing the hella top right.
Oh my gosh.
Hella one, hella one.
Hella dead, hella dead.
Strange!
Guys, we lost one.
I'm solo.
I can't.
I literally used all my resources on the stage.
You are...
You're gonna be solo healing for a little bit until our Raccoon comes back.
The HTC!
What is wrong with my Qs?
What the fuck, man?
Why?
It's okay.
I'm okay.
This is fine.
Their Bucky's one.
Dead.
Thank you.
Everything is fine.
I have ult soon and then I'm gonna copy hella.
Oh, he's back!
I feel so safe.
Okay, where are you?
Hella's one bottom left.
She ulted.
Okay, this is the...
It's a very bad ult.
Unless...
It's fine.
They all...
They rocket Raccoon just as I wanted to.
I wanted them to rocket Raccoon anyway.
Their Bucky's low.
Okay.
We're fine.
We have...
See?
We're so fine.
Penny dead.
We're so okay.
We're so talented.
See?
That's how you know we're gonna win this game because we had a DC and we still won that point.
No, he came back when we won the point.
He came back when we won the point.
I don't know what you're talking about.
He didn't DC at all and us winning that?
We're winning this game.
Also, I might be dead.
No, you're fine.
You're fine.
I'm healing you guys.
Yeah, I think Lowkey was the play here.
I'm keeping you up.
Depending on that.
Oh my god!
Go, Jon Power!
Go!
He's dead.
No, Jon.
But it was so cool, Zoe.
Oh, I cancelled his ult with my fucking E.
Nice.
I didn't know I could do that.
I put up a...
I got close, I got close.
Okay, I'm ulting.
I have to...
Oh!
Strange is one!
Strange is so low!
Hello, dad.
Oh my god, Strange was actually so low.
I'm on HP.
Do you have your Deku?
Oh, yep.
I got you.
Penny does.
Nice.
Strange above.
Strange left.
Jon Power!
You're gonna be okay, Jon Power!
It's okay, he didn't hit that, but it's okay.
And then I have my invincibility here.
I'm trying to focus Hello.
Oh my god, please!
Get me off!
Oh no!
No!
I thought that was the smart...
I literally whaled on point and I thought that was so smart.
Fuck.
Oh, he got killed!
No.
But I still died because you got killed.
Dude.
All I did was stagger you by carrying that guy.
He had me!
I staggered me because of it!
Why did you have to get a kill?
Dude, I ulted that and got the hell out of ult and that's it.
I'm so sad.
I did the whale, but then the strange...
I did the whale on the point and the strange blocked the whale.
Uh-oh.
Goodbye, world.
I had my...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I clutched that.
We have to go, though.
We have to go.
Run, I'm dead.
They have no tanks.
They're at him chasing.
Not the fish!
The fish one-tap me from below!
The cloak is low behind!
No!
It's not us.
I don't think it was us.
I don't think we were the problem.
It was oppressing tab.
That shit was not us.
That was not...
Alright, who were we avoiding?
We were actually gaming there.
Like, all three of us actually played our part.
We all played our part in this.
I was...
Dude, I was tank for the first half of the game, and Jon Powers just not cutting it, bro.
He got picked, at least.
Just not when it matters.
No.
That was a warm-up game.
I just got on.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
Guys, I don't mind being Diamond 1 again.
It's fun down there.
I am negative 11...
No, no, no.
I'm negative 11 into GM3.
We are not losing this game.
I'm avoiding.
I'm drunk.
Why would you avoid the guy named...
I'm drunk, dude.
You have Void down, kid.
Liz, he was...
They were popping off.
Maybe I should have stayed on Magneto so I could keep bubbling him to prevent him from inting.
I think that's...
I think you actually clutched it with that, too.
Fuck.
That was fun.
Please don't ban Psylocke.
I'm going to shit my pants.
It's fine.
Who are we banning first?
Hawkeye.
Don't fucking...
I don't want to play...
I don't care.
I don't care if they ban Hawkeye as long as I don't have to play against Hawkeye.
It's fine.
True.
I like how I accidentally picked Hawkeye, but that's...
Like, my character select is on Hawkeye.
Okay.
We can come back from this.
Oh, no.
We do come back from this.
We can come back from this.
I don't want to know what it's like to be GM2 again.
Okay.
Now we ban Hela.
There's no chance I'm playing against Hela.
I just don't want to do that.
Why did they ban Psylocke?
I'm going to shit my pants.
I don't want them to ban Psylocke.
Every time I play with a Psylocke main, their Psylocke gets banned.
No matter what I do.
Dude, how are they supposed to know that...
They don't know.
How are they supposed to know that I'm a Psylocke player?
That's the thing.
They don't know.
Dude, I'm going to get that Moon Knight banner.
Everyone's going to start banning Moon Knight because they're like, Oh, this guy, he's a Moon Knight player.
We got to ban his Moon Knight.
And then I get Psylocke every game.
See?
It worked.
That's why they didn't ban Psylocke.
I didn't have my Psylocke banner equipped.
I'm a genius.
There's always a gamble between Luna or Mantis or Psylocke.
I want to say, I don't mind Mantis, but Luna...
She stays in ult for 12 seconds!
12!
Sucks to be you, I guess.
She just busts it down for so long.
It's so annoying.
Sucks to suck.
Alright, how's the volume, by the way?
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
No empathy?
Guys, I'm down like five games.
Like, I have zero empathy right now.
I need five games to even recover.
By fucking you, though.
For a roof?
Okay, okay.
That's good.
Oh my god, Mac, back on the magic?
Desperate times call for desperate measures.
Magic's not even your best character, what the fuck are you talking about?
It's not even your best character!
We're portaling, by the way.
By the way, my two DPS players are not memes.
No, dude, I'm taking an off angle, you don't get it.
You don't fuck with the vision.
I froze the Hulk.
Where are they?
Hulk is one.
Oh, I need help.
Oh, I need so much help.
Oh, no way.
There's no way.
Guys, we cannot lose to Nutsack Jones.
All I'm seeing is that...
My DPS players did not take the portal.
I'm taking an off angle.
I'm taking my portal!
Is this a West Coast server?
It is, I have 130 ping.
I have 67 ping, I am West Coast!
To be fair, the server routing here is not great.
Yeah.
Let me know when you're ready to engage and I'll hop on over.
Yeah, I'm here.
I usually just help pressure tanks.
Black Panther!
I'm just beating the Panther's ass, or trying to.
I can't.
Oh, my God.
I cannot keep him up.
I have to ult, too.
We had to ult in the backline.
We had Nutsack who would die.
Nutsack Jones can die.
Can he?
Maybe.
We have no support ults, by the way.
I have Panther and Hulk on me.
I just have Panther.
I'm going low-key, fuck this.
I can't.
My other support doesn't help me.
Yo, kill the Hulk.
This guy is just a wall of meat, bro.
I'm going to do one more death and I swear to God...
No, you are not Ayagamoto-ing me.
If they don't support me, I'm going low-key.
I'm ulting her.
Oh, help her.
Help her fucking swing.
Magic's gotta die.
I swear to God, I am helping her.
I help her, guy.
There we go.
I did the thing.
Guys, I hate playing with a support partner that doesn't fucking peel.
At the moment, my support partner doesn't peel for me, I go low-key.
Because that's the only way to survive.
It's literally the only way you can live.
Like, I can't.
I legitimately cannot deal with that shit.
I don't get covered, nobody... I'm not playing.
I'd rather be a character that can survive.
I guess I go for it.
Change is low.
Oh, have point, but we're one away.
I'm on point, I'm on point.
It's Black Panther.
I'm gonna die because I sacrificed myself to be here.
Okay, Black Panther on point.
He's like actually one.
He's about to fight, yeah.
What the fuck?
Okay, what is this guy doing?
I hate this.
Nice, that's a good sentence.
Oh my god, the things I do to help my team.
They have Lunal, right?
They do, they do.
I'm gonna see if I can force it.
Here comes the pain.
If you force Lunal, you're the goat.
I don't think I can.
I have to do this.
Oh my god, you exploded.
Oh, I got my one.
You all exploded.
You exploded.
I'm backing...
I don't know how he lived, but I don't think I'm gonna live.
I definitely don't live.
I definitely...
Oh, I live.
Oh, there's Black Panther's one.
That's a huge ult.
Please!
Oh, this is even more huge.
I'm gonna pop my ult here.
I don't know, I don't think you should.
Nah, it's a good ult.
Oh, is it?
Nice, okay.
Magic slow, magic slow.
Magic slow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Hulk's lunging my meat.
Get him off of me, bro.
I get my ult pretty quick, so it's fine.
Okay, that's good.
Nice.
It's just that easy.
Honestly, me dying is alright, then.
I can have three people on me at all times.
But it's okay.
Because everybody is on me, so you guys can kill the backline.
I don't need to be alive.
It's so nice they used Luna ult at the end.
Oh, man.
Guys, I don't need to be alive.
This is so free.
I stand near the cloak, I die.
I position myself away, I die.
There's no winning.
I just die.
I don't know where to position myself in a way where I don't die.
They have Caitlyn backline for the first minute of the game.
Yeah, just being an absolute little bastard.
Just terrorizing their supports.
For the greater good!
After we portaled and we lost the teamfight and I didn't take the portal, I was just like standing there.
I wasn't even shooting them because I couldn't engage on them.
You just watched us die like that?
That's fucked.
I just watched you guys die.
I'm playing for Kaydee, fuck you guys.
I wish I could play for Kaydee.
Oh, fuck, he's right there.
Hey guys, there's a Black Panther.
Panther's breaking my neck.
Don't know where he was.
That's a lot of dead people.
Panther's one health.
Wait, do we win this?
Yeah.
Okay, there's a Black Panther.
I don't think we win this.
I think I died to this guy.
Nah, I'm him though.
I'm fine.
There's a Black Panther behind us.
I got Panther.
Thank you.
Oh, their Nutsack Jones is low.
I forgot his name.
Stalker's range.
There we go.
We have one.
We're down.
We're up one.
Never mind, we're even.
I just ran it down.
You know, when I say we're up one, I didn't think you would do that.
Oopsie daisies.
My bad.
Hulk is one.
Hulk is low.
Psylocke is one HP on health.
Hulk is low too.
I'm coming back.
Um, I have fucking Panther on me.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry, Cloak.
Please, Cloak.
Oh, he's so low.
I'm gonna ult this.
I'm ulting.
I like this ult.
Um, it runs.
Oh my god.
I'm backing out.
My thing's over.
I'm trying to get Hulk off here.
Oh, he's so low once he finishes ulting.
Hulk is off.
Support's coming back.
You guys can contest point.
Yeah, I'm engaging.
Okay.
I'm trying to help right now.
Hulk one.
I got Hulk off.
I'm killing both of them.
No, we have to flip the point back.
Okay.
That's a good fight.
I hate playing against this team.
I don't hate my team.
I hate playing.
They used Cloak.
I don't know if they used Cloak, actually.
Yeah, I don't know if that was them or us.
It was us.
Oh, they did?
Okay.
I'm, like, 78% sure.
I'm not 100% sure.
That's a passing grade.
They have Black Panther ult, though.
They have Black Panther ult.
Our Stringy's ult.
No!
Fuck, I knew it!
Oh, thank god.
Our supports are little.
Nice.
Uh, there's a guy down here.
Psylocke.
Nutsack Jones is kind of eating the shit.
Lowkey.
Nevermind.
I have to reload.
I have ult, too.
What is that guy doing?
No!
I couldn't!
You only have, uh...
Poke heals.
I'm coming back!
I'm gonna try to get my ult as soon as I can.
I'm coming back.
You guys can live.
I have support ult.
I think it's winnable.
No, I'm dead.
I'm here!
Fuck, okay!
Um, this is bad.
I didn't think...
That's...
I think we win that?
Maybe.
Oh, wait!
That's fine!
They used I, too.
We totally killed Black Panther here.
I might die, though.
We can reset.
Psylocke's one.
He's just getting healed.
We should reset here.
We're down two.
I don't think we should fight this.
We're down three.
I'll just take height.
I'll just farm my ult.
I'm trying to save the strange, but he might...
He's fine.
He's back.
They used I, so...
They don't have I, but they might have support ult.
And they used Psylocke ult, too.
I froze somebody.
Oh, no.
I froze.
I'm trying to send their supports.
I have Black Panther on me.
Oh!
He's low.
He's one.
Yeah, but we're down.
We're down.
I don't think it's worth it.
We gotta play against next round.
I think...
I'm gonna see if I can farm my Luna ult, then.
Okay, we go into this fight with 6 ults, so we're good.
Yeah, but we gotta make sure we don't ult everything.
Yeah.
Uh, I'll use Psylocke ult to force Luna.
Yippee!
Okay, I'll just kill everything after the Luna's down.
Yeah, sounds good.
We're gonna do it the other way around.
We can use mine.
I'm not sure.
Which one do you think has more kill pressure?
What?
Which ult do you think has more kill pressure?
Mine or his?
One of us has to force Luna ult.
Ideally, Ruben's ult would have more kills, because...
Okay.
He can kill the supports easily, but it really depends on the positioning of people.
Because he can't kill people if there's more than three.
Yeah.
And their supports have been playing a little spread, which has made it hard to ult both of them.
Then we should just use...
Yeah, you can force ult then.
I am having a rough time this game.
I feel like I'm not getting peeled at all from my other support.
So I have to play my life every time.
And I can't...
The freeze is so hard for this one.
This guy... The guy that plays Black Panther is so difficult to freeze.
Got you.
Thank you.
Oh, nice.
Black Panther top left.
He is just...
Wait, that's really good.
Oh, Black Panther won!
I got Black Panther.
I'm not using anything.
I don't think we should.
Nah, this is good.
I don't think we should use anything.
I can actually die from that.
This is really good.
Dude, I just blew everything.
Yeah, that's good.
We didn't use anything.
Psylocke, Cloak, Eye, Luna.
And they swapped off Psylocke to Magic.
Oh, wait, no.
That's bad.
I didn't mag.
They might force my ult then.
Because I'm just going to get hard.
Like, me and the Cloak are just going to get hard dived.
Change dives.
Nice.
Magic ban.
Wow.
And we only used one for that.
I'm scared, guys.
I'm so scared.
I'm so...
Yo, literally scream whenever you get dove and I'll help out.
That's every time!
I want you to fucking yell at me whenever you die.
Okay, but now I'm paying attention to it.
What do you mean?
I'm getting dove!
There we go.
See?
Okay, everything is fine.
Their Luna's one!
Strange is low.
Strange is half.
McNeil's low too.
McNeil's one.
I'm good.
Don't worry about me.
McNeil's low.
Oh, he lives!
I don't know, but I'm trying to make sure you guys are alive.
Black Panther on the right!
Help!
He's on my team!
I'm ulting, I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I'm ulting this.
Don't, don't, don't!
Don't mean, okay?
We're okay.
That's a lot of ults.
I'm backing up.
Nah, but like, what if I win this though?
Oh my god, they're all behind me!
They're coming for me!
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
That's fine, that's fine.
Our tanks are...
Our tanks are okay.
Our tanks are okay!
It's fine!
Everything is fine.
This is it.
This is where our win streak starts.
It's not just that simple.
I've honestly never had an easier game in my life.
Oh my god!
That was the hardest game in my fucking life!
Dude!
That felt like a silver game.
What rank are we again?
I literally am getting, getting fucked right there.
That was just so free!
That was, I'm surprised I even passed 30k healing with the amount of pressure they put on me.
It's just too easy.
Guys, I...
That game actually sucked so much.
I've never hated...
I've never hated this game before.
I told you to do it.
You're just tuning it out.
I like how that was the first time I ever got saved by you guys.
I've never got saved before.
Oh jeez.
That was...
Yes,
Hawkeye.
I refuse to play against a Hawkeye.
We always lose.
I've never played a game since I got to Diamond with Hawkeye unbanned.
And the only reason why I've ever played in a game with Hela unbanned is because the other team assumed we would ban Hela.
We should ban Hulk second.
If Hela's open, I'll just...
I'll gap there, Hela.
Do they have a Hulk player?
The Ironman-Hulk combo's just broken.
Do they have one?
I don't know, but I would just rather never play against Hulk.
I'll just put Hulk.
He's got the highest win rate right now in the game.
Guys, do we know any Hulk 1 tricks?
That we can...
I'll vote for Hulk.
No!
Fuck!
My baby!
Guys, do any one of us know a Hulk 1 trick that wants to stack with us?
Maybe you...
Alright, I'm voting Hulk right now!
No!
I mean, if you play Hulk, I can...
I've never played Hulk before, no.
Okay, I was gonna say...
Fuck.
Okay, Cable.
You play Tank, right?
Cable?
Alright, we'll find out.
Cable, you're not gonna make me solo tank, right?
He's gonna make you solo tank.
I hope he does.
It's okay, I'll front line with you.
You'll be okay.
Thank God.
Okay, but he's on Strange, so like, what if I just go with third DPS?
You're the bastard now.
You're the problem.
I guilt this guy into playing Strange, and I'm like, you know what, dude?
What if I just go with third DPS?
I mean, what's the worst that can happen?
What if I just pick Spider-Man?
What if I just run it down the entire game?
Yo, guys, I'm actually the greatest Black Widow player on Earth.
So...
Alright.
Magneto time.
Also, I'll bubble you off cooldown, and you just beat them up.
Are we portaling?
We're portaling.
Portaling.
Cable's daddy's gonna portal.
Alright, guys.
Let's see if I live.
Now we're defending.
They pushed up.
There's no one in high ground.
You're just gonna have to do it, brother.
Alright, bet.
He's low, he's low.
Oh my God.
I'm high-bubbling.
Not now.
In two, one...
Jesus Christ!
What the fuck?
How are you guys...
I'm scared.
Wait.
Nah, don't be scared.
I got you.
I'm scared.
No, wait.
I shield you.
I think you have to die.
How did everybody die so fast?
Oh no, they have a panther too.
This is not a good magic game with our comp.
Alright, what are you gonna play?
I'm not sure.
I'll figure it out.
I might assassinate someone.
I'm either about to force an ult here or...
I froze somebody.
He shifted out.
I got you.
My panther's low.
Oh my God.
Okay, I just leave I guess.
They used two ults for it though.
So we can chill.
This guy's getting pocketed.
I can't fucking win.
Even though he's horrible.
Oh my God, I won!
Yeah, your magneto helped you.
Or not magneto.
Yeah, you're a Dr. Strange.
No, yeah, it was the magneto.
I did that.
I'm taking credit.
Yo, this magneto's running it down high key.
I'm trying to save our Dr. Strange right now.
Oh wait, we have two picks.
We should go.
Yeah, we got two picks there.
I'm trying to help you guys over there.
And I'm gonna go back to the main point.
Use my main point.
Nah, but like, what if I kill Aethel?
Alright, I die here I guess.
Okay.
I got thrown a whale and then a magneto ult to finish the job.
That's so fucked.
Oh, that's beautiful.
Guys, what the fuck?
That was so fucked up.
That was actually so fucked up.
Oh, shit.
I've never had an easier capture in my life, I think.
In particular.
That's a hate crime right there.
Wait, am I a terrible person for making us play double shield?
Holy shit.
Bro, like...
I'm gonna save.
Oh, fuck.
I knew this would happen.
Like, I don't understand.
What did I do to deserve that?
ArtStrange is not this fucking Narnia right now.
There's a magneto on me.
Okay, that's unlucky.
I might be dead through this, unless...
I'm ulting too.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, I can't save you down there because there's trees!
Nah, but like...
Nice.
If you can get in here, I can heal you.
Did you get the biggest magneto ult of all time?
I got no one, actually.
There's a tree.
I can't heal anybody through it.
Kill the magneto.
Magneto on point.
What are you doing?
Woah, what am I watching?
I just wanna live.
Oh, I just took ArtStrange's portal.
I thought it was theirs and I was about to have a sick flank.
Fuck, I'm walking back to spawn.
ArtStrange is flying into them.
The meat wall's down!
We can kill this guy!
Oh, thank god.
I hate the meat wall.
I don't think we can win this fight.
I don't think we're winning this.
We gotta back up.
All I know is I have gold limbs, so I'm chilling.
I don't know what to do Sometimes I feel like I'm getting targeted so hard.
What have I ever done to deserve that chat?
I killed myself.
I was greedy.
At least I'm honest.
Alright, I'm back.
Hopefully we don't start engaging.
There's a namor.
Namor's frozen.
I don't know what to do with it, but he's frozen.
That is... okay, bro.
They have Groot ult.
Yeah, they almost...
They don't have a Groot.
He's going in.
Namor's behind you guys!
Okay.
Groot slow!
Groot slow, yeah.
No, she froze me.
It's fine, we cap point.
This Magneto ult is gonna go crazy.
Alright.
There's a Magneto in front of us.
There's a Magneto on point.
Please, don't...
Magneto's behind you, Ruben!
Magneto's one!
My bubble went to someone across my screen.
There's a Magneto to our left!
I'm gonna freaking freak out.
I got freaking scammed.
I swear to god.
Uh-oh.
I don't like that.
I blocked it.
I'm him.
Who is this one Magneto?
Thank god he's actually dead.
Oh, he cancelled Groot ult!
Nice.
They have no tank ults.
Oh my god.
This Magneto lived for twenty fucking years!
How many times do I have to scream Magneto?
What are they doing up there?
To my team!
There's teams to our left.
It's okay.
Meat Wall's here to save us.
I'm opening the meat.
Pause.
There's more over here.
Wait, what?
Fish guy's like one.
There's a Meat Wall separating you from...
It's okay.
Meat Wall is my friend.
I love Meat Wall.
Meat Wall will always be here for me whenever I need someone.
Meat Wall will never let me down.
Meat Wall is the most reliable friend I have.
Meat Wall will always be there to have my back.
Protect me from evil.
Just shoot the Magneto!
I'm so sorry, what?
I'm just trying to do the shoot to Magneto.
I'm still alive!
Oh, he let's him live!
I do the fucking Meat Wall.
Yippee!
The Magneto just runs around!
Oh, but it's fine.
I'm fine.
I feel like I was more locked in when I wasn't in voice chat.
No, I am.
I mean, I was definitely more locked in.
I'm fine.
I'm playing like an idiot right now.
I'm my own worst enemy.
It's more fun.
I'm definitely more like my gameplay and positioning is so much better when I'm in VC.
When I'm in VC, I'm not locked in.
I fucked it up.
Don't take that.
Nah, you think they're gonna TP up there onto Doki?
That would never happen.
Nah, they would never just assassinate Doki.
No, don't say that, please.
The Magneto literally W-keys into me.
They're walking?
Nice.
Wait, they're walking or are they taking portal?
They're going left.
Okay.
I'm moving to the right then.
Oh, yeah.
I'm looking perfect.
Oh my god, you got the pig.
Killed one.
Oh, fuck!
You're so healthy, you're so healthy.
I'm glad they made Sigma into a hero in this game.
Do you guys see the human torch Lee?
I think Sigma's cool.
I think he's a pretty wicked guy.
Do you guys see the human torch Lee?
Yeah.
Dude, he looks kind of wicked.
I can't wait for Mr. Fantastic with his tanky body.
And he has a team up with Storm.
Yeah, that's sick.
Who the fuck plays Storm?
Who the fuck plays it?
That's going to be my next main, what do you mean?
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk!
Nah, dude, Storm's taunts are up, I'm telling you.
Oh, they have Moon Knight.
They have Moon Knight now.
He's low, he's low!
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk!
Hulk half, Hulk half.
Fuck him up.
Oh, I died to Moon Knight, but I killed Groot.
Yeah, Moon Knight's not one.
Nice!
Oh, I got hit.
I forgot his name.
The Skull Dude with the leather jacket got leaked too.
The Skull Dude with the leather jacket?
Ghost Rider's going to be in-game?
I'm pretty sure.
I saw people saying he got leaked as well.
I saw the new outfits.
The new outfits are really cool.
Yeah, the new magic skin looks sick.
Lunar New Year or Chinese New Year?
Yeah, yeah.
Or the Year of the Snake?
I like the Mantis skin.
Oh, left side, left side, left side!
Oh my god!
I'm good, I'm good.
I'm fine, I'm altered.
I'm fine.
He didn't get anybody, he didn't get anybody.
He's so stupid.
I bubbled our guy who's basically invulnerable.
I'm a genius, I tell you.
I froze the...
Jeff look, Jeff look, Jeff one, Jeff look.
They're just pressing buttons, I think.
Oh, and he presses another button.
He's literally just pressing buttons.
He presses another button.
I froze, oh wait, never mind.
Dude, they used Moon Knight ult, they used Jeff ult, they used Magneto ult, they used Iron Man.
Bro, they used everything!
Except for Magical.
Yeah, so they'll have Magical up next.
Magic's asleep.
Oh, they have Iron Man now.
Oh, they've had an Iron Man and he just hasn't been doing anything.
I didn't even realize they had Iron Man.
No, yeah, he used his ult last fight too, he's been there for a while.
Ah, that's chill.
We're fine, right?
Are we fine?
I'm trying to help you, Athol.
He's half, he's low, he's one.
Knock him up.
He's out of mech.
I'm good, don't worry about me.
What is this, where are you going?
What the fuck?
Why can't these be our games, Mac?
These are our games!
No, you should have seen our games earlier, Ruben.
Our games earlier were not great.
They were pretty bad.
I was playing out of my fucking mind on those games.
That was like my fifth time playing Magneto, that was great.
I literally am playing worse right now versus the games we lost, because I'm not focused.
I think it's a magic gap, I just can't win if I'm not on magic anymore.
I mean, there's no other explanation.
Because I played Moon Knight earlier.
Bro, I need to avoid every single person on their team.
Oh no, yeah, their team was a little special.
They were a bunch of little silly guys.
Their magic has like 7k damage.
I didn't get to avoid anyone, that's chill.
Oh my gosh, I feel like we should have avoided their magic.
Magic Lily has 7k damage.
Yeah, I mean, we didn't get any of them.
Are you sure?
Okay, we didn't.
Okay, that's good.
That was getting me a little worried.
Oh hey, there's the cable guy.
He was a decent strange, I think.
Yeah, he was.
Oh my god.
Guys, is this what it's like to win on stream?
Is this...
Is this what it's like?
I don't remember what it was like.
It's been so long.
It's actually been so long since I...
Stop cursing me!
God fucking, I went through so much!
Okay.
I went through so much.
I went through so much, guys.
Is this an Adam game?
Mantis Adam?
You think?
Am I throwing if I play Adam?
The one character I can't play?
I think it is.
Nah, it'll be a learning experience.
That's true.
No!
You should have been like, I got Psylocke.
Can you guys get Hella?
You should have said that.
Oh yeah!
Yeah, I played Deadlock with...
Was it him that I played Deadlock?
I don't remember.
Chat, was it him?
I've collabed with so many people.
I'm getting like...
My name's mixed up now.
Oh, it was!
Yeah, he played Deadlock with me.
He was pretty good.
On the plane of rain.
And then...
To be fair, every pro player in every different type of game is playing this now.
Yeah.
Like, it doesn't matter what game.
I like how Valorant players are trying to learn Kyo shooters too.
I think it's pretty funny.
It's cute.
And then they're saying how they try to go back to Valorant and they're like, I don't know what to do.
I can't play Valorant anymore.
The aiming is so different.
No, they're literally like, I'm losing streaks in Valorant because the aim is so different versus Marvel Rivals.
And I'm like, good.
Fuck Valorant.
I say as I get gifted subs from the Valorant promotion.
Yo, Valorant!
They have 100 gifted subs!
Yo!
Dude, you know what I'm so sad about?
They fixed the infinite money glitch from September.
If you had 70-30, you would profit 25 cents every single time you gift yourself 5 subs.
25 cents at least!
So then, if you got bonus subs more than one sub, you'd get even more money.
And they patched it.
You can't give subs to yourself anymore and farm infinite money.
It's so sad.
Alright, I'm trying out Adam.
Let's see how it goes.
Let's see how it goes with Adam.
I don't have, like, his...
Uh oh!
You're fine.
They portaled somewhere?
I don't have soul link yet.
Oh my god.
No heals on point.
I'm setting up a turret.
It's okay.
I'm charging it up.
Ho ho!
Fuck!
Okay.
I just accidentally pressed E.
Whoops.
Guys, I'm, like, a little scared.
Oh, I got shit on.
I don't have heals at all.
Oh, but, like, I can spawn in.
Okay.
I should not have cocoon.
Yo, plus one death?
Let's go!
I should not have hooked you.
I thought I could stall on point.
Alright, I'll swap off after my ult soon.
Uh oh.
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
Okay.
I'll wait for all of us before I do a soul bond.
Oh, he's so low!
Are you okay?
No.
I missed my E on the fucking Punisher.
Oh!
What?
What is this?
Are we fighting?
I guess.
Our tanks just went through.
And we reset.
Oh, we reset?
Okay.
Okay, that's bad.
Wait, no, wait, we win these!
I'm getting just gunned down by an AA gun.
Alright, I swapped.
I guess Look, Adam is not it.
Oh.
I legitimately thought we could make Adam work because it's meta.
But it could be me not knowing how to play Adam.
Who knows?
I have my Punisher ult.
Dude, okay.
Okay.
The Mantis ulted.
I get shit on.
Strange Ironman.
I killed Punisher.
Yeah, but we're down, we're down.
We have one... I don't know.
I don't know if we can get a fight in.
No.
Stop.
What do we do?
Well, we have a Punisher now to shoot.
Wait, can you play Starlord?
Starlord is a great counter to Adam.
I can get a summon.
Are we able to touch?
No, I don't think so.
I think if we shut down the Ironman with Starlord Punisher, then like...
I think the biggest problem that round is just we kept staggering in and like, losing ults when like, nobody's there.
Like our guy.
Our strange guy.
He went and ulted when it was just two of them there.
He's just trying his best.
Yeah, no.
He's gonna do his best this round.
And then we win.
Trying his best.
We're just not gonna die so that we can't stagger in the first place and then there's no problems.
Yeah.
Would I be a Turbo Griefer if I picked Widow here?
Yes.
I mean, that's a pretty decent point for it.
Okay.
Just so you know, I'm not Mantis so you gotta ask.
You have to ask the Mantis for damage boost.
Mantis, just pocket me a little bit.
I'll get a fix at the beginning.
Can Widow get damage boosted?
Yes.
She one shots.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why like, Widow players only play if there's a Mantis.
Because she can actually one shot and like, kill people.
Okay, they're all top right.
Are you getting damage boosted?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
I just got ran at by this range.
I got...
I'm backing out.
The hog literally ulted into us.
Goodbye!
Oh Jesus.
I don't think he's gonna live.
Okay.
You guys are about to get ran at.
Oh, their punish is so low.
Okay, we're fine.
Yeah, I have my punish going for this fight.
We have a strange...
Not strange, we have a captain.
I killed the Ironman.
Nice!
I got you.
Alright, Captain America is fucking going at it.
I'm trying to keep our Captain America alive.
Mantis one.
Change this half, change this half, change this half.
I forced Mantis ult.
I might be dead.
Oh, please.
I'm so dead.
I'm so dead here.
Yeah.
Kill Mantis.
Oh, that's huge.
I couldn't.
Oh my god.
Four people ran at me.
I think our...
I think...
Our kicks are not having it.
Mantis one.
I'm keeping you up, Mac.
Nice!
We should push up with that.
Just fight on point.
I'm coming back.
Where is it?
He was...
He was trying something.
I'm gonna ult on point.
If we get engaged on.
Guys, this is...
They have strength and iron mantle.
They're gonna do that combo.
I'm trying to wake...
My auto attack doesn't wake people up.
My bad.
I didn't know you were there.
Okay, I guess I use this then.
Just in case.
I'm getting hard ran at by Hulk right now.
Yeah, yeah.
I can't do anything about it.
He stunned me.
Hulk behind you guys.
I'm healing you.
I come back with punish roll.
This is winnable.
The Hulk is back.
I'm getting solo ulted by Strange.
What is this?
I'm okay.
I stayed on point for so long.
Guys, we have to fight on point.
Mantis is so low.
They're investing so many resources into trying to kill me.
Yeah, thinking you ran out.
Punisher one.
I'm coming back now.
I have to heal the tanks right now.
Please!
What the fuck where did I get hit from?
Wait, Iron Man's projectiles go through walls?
No, they blow a hole in the wall the first one.
Wait, what?
He literally shot me through the wall.
Splash damage.
Oh yeah, they splash.
Yay, okay.
Got you.
As best as I could.
I mean, I have support ults too.
I'm just gonna stay with you.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I think it was just a tank stiff.
Yeah.
I think.
I think it was just tank stiff.
Oh man.
Their tanks just freely walked up to us.
Yeah, they were like, I don't know what to do there.
It did help that when Adam first fight, but...
And we lost 19.
I'm not mad.
He lost 19?
Yeah.
I lost 21.
Damn, get fucked.
Um, I have you know, I invited you to this...
I was supposed to be invited to this stack and I can kick you out whenever I want.
I just wanted to remind you that.
No!
I just wanted to remind you that you're the plus one here.
Fuck!
Listen.
Winstreak time.
Look, Mac literally gave up playing with xQc to play with me.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
He's gonna eat me.
That's my fucking goat right there.
Okay, watch.
They don't ban Psylocke.
They're not gonna do it.
We ban Hawkeye and then I play Psylocke.
Cool.
Anytime you get to play Psylocke, you can actually play the game.
I can play the game even if I'm not on Psylocke.
Typical Psylocke player.
I am obsessively addicted to Marvel Rivals.
I'm just trying to get it back.
That's a good ban.
I'm banning Hulk.
Ah, shit.
Doki, ban Hulk.
Wait, I ban Hulk?
Ban Hulk.
Make it 50-50.
I always lose coin flips, so Hela will get banned.
Oh, they ban Hela.
Hela's banned anyways.
I'm not a one trick.
I'm just sad when I'm not on Psylocke.
Everyone else is so much less fun.
You should try to learn magic.
This character is hella fun.
I should.
I like how you lied and said, I don't tank.
Dude, I'm just so sick of tanking.
I like how you lied.
What do you mean?
You barely tanked today.
I tanked so much the past few days.
I don't know.
I was too nice yesterday.
You were way too nice.
You literally played fucking support.
What was wrong with you?
I was playing Rocket and shit, man.
This is why we don't climb.
You're not greedy enough.
You're not selfish enough.
You're right.
I don't fucking care if we have two other support mains.
I still lock in support.
You gotta ego the other people.
You have to ego.
See, who's more desperate for fucking points?
You or them.
Definitely not me.
You have the insta-lock.
Who the fuck cares?
You know you're better.
I guess not.
I'm just walking.
Is the bridge open?
I don't fucking know.
Yeah, they're main.
They have Punisher.
They have Punisher and they're main right now.
Okay.
I'm gonna see if I can one-shot one.
I'm not one-shotting one, but I did kill their Rez.
I'm with you.
There's a Psylocke behind!
Sword us!
Oh, I knocked him over the fucking group wall.
Okay, he doesn't die then.
I'm playing on point.
I'm looking at point.
Psylocke's still behind.
I have to walk off.
There's Psylocke still behind.
And the Punisher's just reshooting me.
Psylocke has Orb on.
Where's our tank?
Oh, our tank's dead.
Psylocke behind!
Psylocke behind again!
Can you keep snowflake on me, Ducky?
Yeah, I can.
Our tanks are here.
There's someone on the right.
There's a rocket on the right.
Oh my god, Psylocke's so low!
I'm back, I'm back.
I have ult here.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I'm dancing!
I'm gonna dance!
Please kill them while I dance!
Kill this...
Strange is low, Strange is low.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
She's one!
I had to reload my hands!
No!
Why don't you have infinite ammo in your hands?
I don't know.
Honestly, we should have more infinite ammo in our hands.
Yeah, Groot has to reload his arms like a fucking boxer.
Yeah, like what the fuck?
And then Jeff has to eat to reload water?
Like, what the fuck does that mean?
Nah, that makes sense.
How does that make sense?
Where does he get the water?
How does he swim in the ground?
Cause he's a magic shark.
Magic shark?
Fuck.
Um, I can't peek that because I have...
Wait, he's low.
In there.
Psylocke behind me, Psylocke behind me.
He's gonna...
Goodbye.
Oh no, what the?
Thank you for healing me.
Their raccoon is so low.
Psylocke got nobody with it.
Yeah, what a bum.
Couldn't beat me.
I don't know where the Psylocke went.
She went invisible again.
I'm playing up.
But the tanks aren't taking damage, so...
Yeah.
Chunk the shit out of Thor, there.
Portaling to my right.
Portaling, portaling.
Watch for eye, watch for eye.
Um...
I don't think...
We live this.
I'm frozen too.
We don't live it.
We both support are down.
No, I got shotgunned.
He's a land shark.
Exactly!
He's a magic shark!
I got...
I have ult for this fight.
Okay, that's good, that's good.
They don't have Psylocke ult, so I'll just engage with it.
Okay, okay.
And they use strange ult, so they literally have no DPS ults.
Oh wait, no.
They have punish ult, so... I don't know.
Oh my god, I got nuked by an RFC.
Oh my god.
We have to wait, then.
Wait, this is so chill.
We can just wait.
Oh, but we lost Groot, we lost Groot.
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
I guess we go.
I guess we go in.
And I ult Groot.
That was...
That was ambitious.
Yeah, I'm ulting on point if you want kills.
Coming back.
I have no more ult.
Strange is low.
Psylocke is low, Psylocke is low.
Psylocke one.
Strange, strange, strange.
Please.
Luna to the left, Luna to the left.
He's trying to run away.
Oh, goodbye Luna.
Okay, that's huge.
I want to cut.
I want to cut all trees.
I want to burn them all down.
Yeah, I want to burn all the trees down.
Oh my god, Human Torch should absolutely do bonus damage to Groot.
Oh my god, that's why I didn't release Human Torch.
It should do like times five bonus damage to Groot only.
Yes!
Human Torch looks at Thor and he just incinerates.
You only play Human Torch if there's a Groot player.
If you're a Groot player, you're just about to ban Human Torch every game.
Please, Groot, I want to play Groot.
Please, I don't want to get burned down.
Yeah, but then that wastes a ban slot.
True.
Literally, a Groot one trick is throwing the entire game just because he's wasting an avoid slot.
You're right.
Do you think they're going to nerf Hela in any meaningful way?
I don't think they're going to nerf them.
I think they're only going to nerf them after Season 1.
I don't think they're touching the characters until then.
When does Season 1 even start?
January.
January something.
I just know it's in January.
Maybe like first or second week of January.
No, fuck Groot.
I don't care about Groot.
Groot is actually like hell.
A good Groot and a good Hulk is like terrible play again.
Oh my god, that's huge!
That's actually huge!
I'm fucking dead here though.
We're up one.
Okay, never mind.
How did everybody die?
I was just hitting that penny the whole time and she just wouldn't die.
That was such a huge ult.
That was crazy.
I'm coming back now.
I can't hear you, Ruben.
I thought they would just forget about me.
I couldn't heal you, Ruben.
That's okay.
I got my value.
What?
We lost the point.
I got my one.
I did my job.
Right, guys?
That's how it works.
Team shooter.
We lost the point.
I don't have a snowflake on you, Mac.
It's okay.
I'm gonna go contest penny with you.
I'm portaling in.
Oh, it's rude.
I had to reload in that moment.
Oh my god, strange!
Why, strange, why are you like this?
Why are you like this, strange?
I'm breaking all the mines as much as I can.
That's a huge ult.
I didn't want my E to hit the penny, so I didn't E there.
We should regroup.
I cannot believe that hit me.
Oh my god, group, please.
I killed Psylocke.
Nice, but we need a reset though.
Our tanks are not... our group is feeding really hard.
Or he got hooked, who knows.
I'm hiding.
Nah, he's been doing that until he locks in this fight.
He missed the hook, there's no hook.
Are you serious?
Guys, we...
Our other tank is not coming back to us.
He missed, he missed, he missed.
Huge.
I'm just gonna put the orb on the fucking Groot.
I don't think there's no other way to live.
Psylocke right.
Yeah, she's still right.
She's low.
Groot, please, for the love of god, Groot.
We only have like... wait, she's just for the Recon, Recon, kill the tank.
Guys, I...
I hate this Groot.
You gotta get the Recon.
I can't heal you.
I'm back.
I'm good, I'm good.
They have...
They have Bucky and...
Oh, yeah, okay.
Yeah, and they have Psylocke.
I don't have it yet.
I have it in 60.
This is fun, guys.
This is so fun.
I'm gonna break the Red's beacon.
Oh, my god.
Groot, please.
Top, top, top, top.
I just got one tapped.
What?
No Red's beacon?
I have to, I have to.
Oh, no, I didn't realize there.
They're gonna Psylocke the next fight.
The Psylocke is up top.
We used way too many ults there.
Shit.
Nice.
Okay, that's a stagger.
They have Psylocke.
They have all their DPS ults and support ult.
I don't know if they have Luna ult, right?
They haven't used it yet.
I think so.
Yeah, they haven't used it.
We have one fight after this, though.
I think, if we can portal it.
I'm gonna look to assassinate a support.
I know I'm here.
Thank you.
I need to keep fruit.
No!
Hold their Luna.
Please.
Oh, no, we're not gonna live through that.
We can portal.
Oh, no, we can't.
Our Strange didn't die.
I have portal, I have portal, I have portal.
Our Strange didn't die, though.
So, you might be a touch.
Yeah, I'm gonna try to go first.
I give you...
Yeah, our Strange didn't die.
It took 20 years to...
I have to be so quick.
I can touch, I can touch, I can touch.
Go in, go in, go in, go in, go in.
Where, where, where?
No way, he countered portal.
Oh, wait, no, they portaled us, they portaled us, they portaled us.
What do you mean they portaled us?
They countered portal.
I'm trying to stall on point.
No!
I got...
I killed Elena.
I got eyes, though.
No!
Ah, shit.
Oh, my God.
Why did our Strange have to die last when he had portal?
Um...
We got ults for this fight.
What did they use that fight?
They...
I don't know.
They don't have portal.
That's true.
No, we don't either.
Fuck.
They used Penny ult.
That's all I can remember.
They have Raccoon ult here.
But that was actually...
They used Luna ult the second last fight.
So they might get it here.
Because I have my ult.
So they might get their ult after the first fight.
So...
I guess like...
Matt could just start the fight off.
And kill everybody off.
Because they don't have Luna ult.
Oh, my God.
I'm just keeping...
I need to keep the orb on our group.
Because all he does is feed.
I literally can't keep him alive.
This is a very rough map for Magic.
I'm probably going to ult and then swap.
I killed their Psylocke.
I'm trying to keep their...
Their Strange is frozen.
I'm fucking ulting.
And he does.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
I had to ult to keep everybody alive.
After I saw Groot fucking ass out.
Okay, we do have a Jeff.
So it's going to be a little difficult.
We have a Jeff?
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Unless...
I'm good.
Penny is half.
Left side is a Strange.
I'm going to look to ult in here.
Groot, look for an ult.
I got ulted, though.
I got Jeffed.
Are you serious?
Jeff, spit me out.
What the fuck, Jeff?
What?
What are you doing?
I'm in my ult.
Jeff ate me and threw me off the map.
Yo,
Bucky.
Okay, we got point.
I'm so mad.
Oh, my God.
I literally had the God play.
And this guy just murdered me.
Just fight on point.
We have point.
Guys, this is why Jeff is not the pick.
Never the pick.
He gave you a heart.
You are...
That is the most...
That is the singular most tilting response he could have given.
I know.
I'm dead.
Oh, no.
There's a...
Did they use Luna ult last fight?
I don't think they did.
But you can try and bait it out.
That Bucky is so low.
Oh, my gosh.
The worst part is I have to save my ult.
I can't use my ult to engage.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
They're gonna use Psylocke ult after this.
I'm broken now.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
They're gonna Psylocke ult us.
Luna, Luna, Luna.
That's huge, that's huge, that's huge.
Bro, this...
Oh, my God, Bucky.
Strange one.
Strange actual legit one.
No, not again.
I might be dead though from this.
Bucky's half, Bucky's half.
I don't think Jeff was the pick.
Why did we play Jeff?
Not enough, but this guy's about to eat six and go off the map.
Oh, my God.
He's getting six.
What is she doing?
Go point, go point, go point.
5% Luna, Luna, Luna.
Oh, that's a waste.
Oh, the fuck.
He actually ate people.
Behind me, behind me, behind me.
She's half.
I'm so low.
Okay.
They popped their infinite already.
Do they have Luna ult?
No, no, no.
They don't have Luna.
I'm getting...
Spider time can die.
He's one, he's one.
Bucky's one.
Oh, my God.
I'm dead to Psylocke though.
Psylocke's one though.
Our group's doing stuff.
Oh, no.
Oh, nice.
Bucky won.
I forced Bucky off the map.
A good amount of time.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Luna ult.
I'm fucking damaged.
I killed the Raccoon.
I'm 1-0.
Get in my ult, get in my ult.
2 seconds, 2 seconds, 2 seconds.
Psylocke's so low.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
Holy fuck.
I was gonna fucking fucking punch a shark and we didn't win.
Dude, I was gonna bam Jeff every game if we didn't win, dude.
I was gonna watch Jaws and fucking punch a fucking shark.
I didn't even see if his heart went away.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I was gonna say God, I wanted to say something so fucked up, but I shouldn't because I don't want to.
His highlight play is him kidnapping me.
His highlight play is him throwing me off the map.
Don't queue, I want to see.
I want to see this highlight clip.
His highlight is him throwing me off the fucking map.
He fucking jumps off.
He didn't need to jump off.
He could have just spat you out.
No, why did he jump off?
Bro, the Groot and the shark Jeff, the Groot and the Jeff were like hyping each other up but they were the fucking most tilted players on my team.
They were hyping each other up.
That was our Groot from the other game that ran it down.
Oh my god, let's go.
I can't believe the Groot and the fucking Jeff were just hyping each other up in the chat.
Oh my god, that Jeff was so fucking, oh my god I'm gonna fucking freak out when I use the bathroom.
Alright, banning Hawkeye.
What's up with these bums banning Black Panther?
Wait, no way this guy just voted to ban Psylocke.
I swear to god if Psylocke gets banned, I'm gonna be so fucking tilted.
80-20 odds.
Please.
Thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Oh my god, that stressed me out.
Wow, we got a Spider-Man?
Alright.
Dude, we had four votes for Hela and one vote for Psylocke from our Spider-Man.
You could've lost it.
I could've lost the Psylocke to the fucking guy.
I think our guy is a Iron Man one trick maybe?
I mean, they banned Iron Man and Black Panther so like, maybe that's somebody's hero pool.
Yeah.
What's up with all these Black Panther banners?
I just realized, guys, I forgot to do the Discord.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why.
This always happens when I fucking play.
Oh, sorry, I was gonna say, I forgot to do the Fugi thing and I was like, this always happens when I do when I do Marvel Rivals.
Oh yeah, the Fugi's break?
No, I just forgot to put it up.
Oh.
Okay, guys, we're gonna put it up.
We're gonna put it up.
Um.
After.
I'm lazy.
Because I'm in game.
I'm not lazy.
I'm just in game.
Wait, the Fugi's are there?
No way.
You guys are lying to me.
Okay.
Okay, I'm locking in.
Oh.
Oh, they're like pre-pushing this.
Nice, Ruben.
We should push up.
We should push up with this.
This Magneto dies.
On the penny, yes.
I put the orb on you.
Okay, you are so low.
Ow, they really hurt.
Penny's half.
Penny's one.
Nevermind.
Where the fuck did you go?
Oh, you disappeared.
I'm putting it on the Spider-Man now.
Oh, you are so low.
I should have left it on you.
Nah, I'm good.
I'm putting it back on you, the orb.
Thank you.
Oh.
I'm not close at all.
She's dead.
Nah, we're good.
Uh, Magneto won.
Magneto's low.
Magneto's so low.
Wait, wait, there's a magic behind.
There's a magic behind.
There's a magic behind me.
It's not you.
I don't need healing.
I can't move my mouse and ping.
I hear the magic and the Psylocke walking around.
I'm fucking so scared.
They're gonna kill me.
No, no, no.
I'm watching you from the rooftops.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm missing every shot.
I'm sorry.
I'm not locked in right now.
I'm locked in now.
That's huge.
I'm gonna ult after this.
I ulted.
Big, big, big, big, big.
Oh my god, are you trying to tell me Mantis is not bad and we are not willingly playing Mantis?
There is a magic behind me and I'm gonna be dead.
I'll avenge you.
We have no heals.
Our cloak died first.
Everything will be fine.
I can put orb on you, Mac.
Oh, they have a Moon Knight now.
Destroy the orb.
Oh, Spiderman.
Poor guy.
I instantly killed her.
There's a dozen left and they've got Psylocke.
Moon Knight won.
You only have cloak heals.
I just saw the craziest rollout from Spiderman.
Even if he's not doing anything, he knows how to do rollouts.
He went and practiced those in customs.
That was insane.
He might not be doing shit, but I was impressed with that rollout.
You're fine because I'm healing.
People are taking damage.
Okay, nice.
He might be useless, but that was pretty cool.
Not gonna lie, that was pretty fucking cool.
I'm gonna jump on the Moon Knight.
The Hulk is half.
Psylocke won HP beyond.
This is where I died though.
Psylocke got me in the support area.
No supports.
I just got my ult too.
That sucks.
I mean, I could ult into Saul if you guys can make it.
Touch the Saul, Spidey.
Oh, shit.
He's like, alright, I guess this is where I die.
He's like, oh, shit.
Oh, shit, I was blowing their backline.
I killed their Mantis.
He's just like, dude, I have to touch, dude.
Oh, shit, I don't want to play.
Well, that's a strange ult.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
Bro, jumped on play and instantly died.
He's just like, God, I have to do it, bro.
Oh, fuck.
I was busy in their backline doing shit, man.
He's doing Overwatch rollouts, that's the only thing he was doing.
The fuck was he doing?
I don't know what their Spidey's doing either, but I'm glad he's not Spidey.
They have a Spider-Man.
They had one.
Yeah, their Spider-Man is just legit.
That's their Jett player.
Wait, wait.
Strange one, strange one, strange one.
Okay, nevermind, he's getting healed.
Oh, fuck.
I'm okay.
I'm doing stuff.
Yo, what is that Spider-Man doing?
I'm trying to get to you.
There's a Spider-Man heading in.
They have Mantis ult, right?
I'm so fucking low.
You have to bait them.
Get the bait the ult out though, anyway.
Okay, perfect.
I'm ulting this.
I'm taking a nap.
Give me a sec, I'm feeling a little sleepy.
I'm ulting this.
Oh my god, I exposed him though.
I froze him.
Whoa, what the?
Yo, this guy loves me.
I hear the Spider-Man, but I just can't see him.
That was such a good freeze too.
God damn it.
The Spider-Man's above us.
I'm trying to live.
It's just range.
What is this guy doing?
Feeding.
Yeah, but he has...
He's so low.
I got you.
Oh my god.
Their range is low again.
And so is their hulk.
Oh my god.
I think we might need a second pink.
I can't do anything.
I'm sleeping.
No!
Oh my god.
Wait, wait.
No,
I lied.
Why did I TP on the cart?
Bro, why are you on cloak and dagger?
Mantis is not even bad.
You're willingly playing cloak and dagger.
I don't know.
That sounded like a dude from Chowder.
What happened?
Oh my god.
I'm waiting right now.
Are you guys destabilized?
We're staggering in.
I would never stagger.
Reuben, you're gonna stagger right here.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm not staggering.
I'm not doing it.
Are you serious?
Spider-Man clipped me off.
I'm going to touch cart.
Okay, I can...
There's a Spider-Man that's just...
Don't look at the hole.
He's just ripping people off the hole.
Bro, why can't our Spider-Man do that?
Okay, look at where our cloak is real quick.
I got you.
Dude, their Spider-Man's low.
So low.
I can't do anything.
I'm getting...
He's one.
I need to back up into the spawn though.
That's a huge kill on Hulk.
Yeah.
This is last fight.
Yeah, they weren't pushing cart, so like...
There's a Psylocke behind us.
Don't work.
He's trying to grip people out into the hole.
Okay, I...
What?
I'm so bad.
Oh my god.
Psylocke's one.
We have to focus on Hulk and...
I'm trying to get back to point, but I'm one health.
Yeah, I can't...
I got you, I got you, I got you.
We have to kill them because...
Staggers are coming in.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, please.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Okay.
Their Maxis is one.
Bro, I'm gonna squish a spider today.
Where is he?
I'm gonna squish the spider.
Dude, I was trying to fucking zone him out the whole time.
And he's just on the ceiling.
Like, what am I gonna do against that?
I just gripped like four people into the...
Four people into the pit.
Look at their Spider-Man stat line.
Why can't our Spider-Man do that?
Like, I...
I don't understand.
Why can't our Spider-Man do that?
He just has cool roll outs, that's it.
Just looks cool.
He can't do anything else.
Guys, our Spider-Man...
Fucking sucked compared to the other Spider-Man.
Spooner-Man versus Spider-Man.
Bro, it's...
It's so fucking sad.
It's so sad.
Oh my god, 11-10.
I don't understand.
I think it's because we have Punisher, too.
We have Punisher.
I like how the enemy Spider-Man looked so cool doing the shit he did, but he had 11 deaths.
I thought he had more kills, honestly.
He was fucking so annoying.
This guy is saying, I've been Punisher this entire game.
Bro, the other enemy Spider-Man looked so fucking cool.
Now we're just gaslighting him.
He's just your friendly neighborhood Spider-Man.
Oh, they have Squirrel.
There's, like, Psylocke to the left side.
They have a Squirrel girl.
Yeah, they do.
Why doesn't he want to play play Mantis?
Mantis is so good.
Oh, I'm a piece of shit.
Oh my fucking god.
Wait, didn't you have the...
Oh, you had the orb.
Wow, you got fucking gapped.
Oh, Strange is low.
Squirrel girl low.
I have an orb on you, Ruben.
Thank you.
Focus Hulk.
Hulk is half.
He was looking for the medkit.
Hulk is one.
He's actually one.
Oh my god, he was so low.
I have to reload, though.
I can't heal.
You're fine.
Wait.
I swear, I'm going to start banning Hulk, too.
I'm going to ban Hulk at this point.
Like, I can't deal with Hulk.
I don't know why I thought my tank was with me up there.
You mean you are one tank?
Yeah, I thought he was up there with me.
I don't know why.
To be fair, it's literally our one tank.
Damn, really?
Really?
We had two DPS and no kills?
Yeah, no, I did it to stay alive.
I was going to die otherwise.
There's a Moon Knight right up here.
Moon Knight is...
He's one.
Moon Knight's one.
They're one.
Can we use...
Oh, Manta's low.
Oh my god, I don't know what to do.
Their tank is just...
Very aggressive on us.
We'll get point with my Night's Salt.
Their tank's really good.
I am kin.
I have to save my ult for...
I have ult.
Oh, he's going to go DPS if we don't...
He's turning.
Oh, I'm so low.
Oh, I'm easy.
Good job surviving that.
I don't know where the Psylocke is.
She's top left.
We can mini-hulk, mini-hulk.
Their Moon Knight's low.
He has Moon Knight all.
I'm going for him.
I have Moon Knight all here.
I put it on you, Ruben.
That hits me?
Keep me up.
Oh, I need help.
I can't.
I'm coming back with Psylocke ult.
I'm trying to heal.
Okay, I got it.
This is the last fight.
Psylocke top left, half HP.
I can't...
Mini-hulk,
mini -hulk.
I don't know if...
I don't know if magic is it here.
Yeah, I'm switching to Psylocke.
Okay.
We gotta kill these guys before they push us, so they don't push us.
Nice, we got it.
Thank you.
Alright.
I'm gonna pull up.
Ruben, you have...
You have the orb.
Thank you.
Oh, I thought he was going good.
Nice.
You almost fell, I saw that.
I almost fell off the map.
I saw that.
Jesus, I got so scared.
I am careful.
Dude, their hulk is just matching me everywhere I go.
That's so annoying.
Maybe it's time to play hulk.
The hulk is low.
The main tank is dead.
Alright.
We're dancing.
I'm popping ult.
Alright, they have...
Psylocke on her.
Oh my god, strange is so low.
I'm going for a Psylocke ult.
Okay.
Psylocke dead.
Got you.
Get the strange.
She has ult.
I know, but he has ult.
He is actually looking for ult.
Oh my god.
Why is this so fucking hard?
Okay, we're fine.
No, I'm stuck.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Why are these games like this?
Grab my ankles.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the 50 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Thank you so much.
I think he's just saving...
He's saving ult for the last fight.
I think that's what he's doing.
He still has it.
I'm scared of the eye.
We can push up.
We have two picks.
I have ult too.
I just killed that guy while he was typing.
Nice.
I'm damage boosting this.
I got one anyway.
Oh no.
That was...
No ult.
We used two ults there.
And the more ult was so good.
Damn.
I got fished.
Yeah.
We have one fight left.
We have Raccoon ult for it.
I can't heal you there.
Oh...
I'm gonna give you the thing.
And then we'll see how it goes.
Yeah, but they live forever.
That's the thing.
There's a Psylocke behind.
Oh my god.
Be safe.
Okay.
They didn't do anything with that.
I'm trying to keep our...
I killed Alana.
Strange, strange, strange.
I couldn't do it.
Oh no, we can't leave.
I'm dead.
Nah, this is winnable.
No, no, no.
Couldn't do anything.
Dang.
Oh man.
Damn.
Oh, that was so close.
No, the Jett player won!
How did we let him win?
Oh my god.
I think maybe a second tank would've...
I don't have a second tank without...
Oh no.
Oh man.
Oh my god, and you diffed that Psylocke too.
Yeah, dude.
Fuck.
I did all that for nothing.
Oh my god, the BM.
He says, don't fail.
Mac, are you okay, Mac?
I'm fine.
Are you okay?
I'm not fine at all.
I'm really kidding.
To go a second fucking tank on my team.
I never want to see this guy play DPS on my team ever again.
Wow, really, kid?
Yeah, that guy should've filled.
That is so fucked up.
I can't believe it.
Our queues are so fucked up.
Our queues.
Can we get five gifted subs to make up for the mental turmoil of that game?
I love Marvel Rivals.
It's my favorite.
I love it.
I wonder what it's like to be GM2 again.
It's okay.
We can climb back up.
We can climb back.
Believe in us.
We'll be fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh my god.
Thank you so much for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
We got Golden Kappa.
Holy fuck.
Holy moly.
Oh my god.
We got the Golden Kappa hype train.
Guys, if you don't give five subs, you're not going to get the Golden Kappa.
I love them.
We're going to ignore Valorant.
We'll always ignore Valorant.
Let's farm Valorant's money.
I need some more water.
I'm so locked in.
I'm so locked in, guys.
I'm pretty sure being in a call has made me less locked in.
But I'm so locked in.
Oh wait, they are in here.
Wait, there is a Fugi there.
I didn't even realize there was a Fugi there this entire time.
Which one is it?
Is it this one?
There you go.
That's them right there.
I want to use the icons, but like...
There you go.
That's them.
That's fine.
I can actually stream this for such long hours.
I just love...
I don't know what it is about competitive games.
I can literally stream competitive games for so fucking long.
Any team where we have one tank, I just can't play Magic.
Yeah, I think so too.
We've been just getting...
I don't think we've encountered a tank player.
Oh no, we definitely have not been encountering tank players.
We got a Lord Wolverine.
Fuck.
I mean, if you start to suck Lord...
If he's Wolverine and he starts to suck GM3...
Then there's problems.
Cause Wolverine is scary in higher elo.
Oops.
No accident opened.
Alright.
Fine.
Thank you for the 100 bitties.
Cosmic, thank you also for the 100 bitties.
And OldManShark, I thank you a thousand bitties.
Thank you.
Jokey, you have a rival's problem.
I see that's someone that's playing Destiny 2 for...
No, I agree.
I do.
It's not okay.
I'm not okay.
I'm also not locked in.
I was more locked in.
I was locked in in the first couple of games.
I was doing some crazy shit.
I was definitely doing some really fucking crazy shit.
In the first couple of games.
Now I'm just fucking around more.
Where is that?
Oh.
I've never seen a portal here before.
What the?
Oh my god.
I don't like this.
Wait, I forgot they can just break our high ground.
Wolverine killed their tank, but he killed himself too.
Hulk is so low.
I'm getting slammed in the back.
There's a Jiff behind us.
Yeah, the flanking Jiff.
That dude is a demon.
Alright, nice.
He's back.
Oh my god, you guys got the golden cap back.
Oh my god, I'm going this way.
I went the wrong way.
I was debating which way to go.
Their Hulk's name is fuck overwatch 2?
Nice, I agree.
Honestly, so fucking true.
I like that game.
Everything is fine.
There's a lot of things above us.
Oh my god, what happened to our strange?
What happened to you?
They kept running me over and I kept backing up.
And I kept getting exploded.
I'm just going to die on point.
Jesus Christ, they like ran at us so fast.
Yeah, I tried backing up, but ow.
I'm your solo tank, dude.
What could you do?
Ow.
They have Jeff ult, by the way.
Oh my god.
So like...
Raccoon, are you okay?
I might die.
We can push up.
Bro, what the...
Okay.
Goodbye.
The raccoon and I both...
He's going to jump off.
It's fine.
You guys got the point, right?
You guys got the point.
That's fine.
Oh, they portaled.
You have no support.
Oh, it's just two of you.
We're coming back.
I can ult on.
Guys, I'm scared.
You're fine.
I have orb on you.
Kill the fish guy!
Fish is to your right.
Kill the other fish!
Get Dr.Shane!
Dr.Shane is behind you!
He's like...
He has no shield, but...
He's getting healed now.
I got you, Mac.
I'm just using this as cover for now.
He has...
Oh, shit!
I canceled his I.
I got you.
Ironman!
And there's no more above.
I'm not going to ult.
I'm going to die on point.
I'm going to go beat up the Namor.
How dare he.
I'm going to eat some fucking fish.
That's for sure.
I started hating things more after Marvel Rivals.
There's so many things I realize I fucking hate in this world.
Shane just turned you into a turbo pessimist.
Yeah!
I was like, you know what?
I'm glad the world's dying.
You know what?
We should dump more barrels of oil into the ocean, I think.
No, BP!
Maybe they're not so bad.
You know what?
I see their point now.
I get it.
I understand now.
I understand.
Dude, honestly.
Fuck it, dude.
More drink rings in the ocean.
Oh, I hate that!
That's a whole another level.
I'm just saying.
I'm not one to use plastic straws again, dude.
So an oil spill in the ocean is fine, but plastic rings is where we draw the line.
I get it now.
I fucking get it.
There's only one guy who wants to take my portal.
You know what?
You didn't say anything!
I'm on Strange.
I said it by picking Strange.
I didn't know you had your cooldown.
I think I'm going to use my oil early.
There's a shark up here.
Bro, there's a shark in the skybox.
I literally, I can't.
I need to use my health pack.
There's a flanking shark behind us.
Why did I get...
Please, please, live.
Nice.
If you need heals, just go into my dance.
Just dance with me.
I'm dancing.
I'm shaking ass.
There's Jeff.
Jeff has ult, by the way.
Jeff is looking for it.
I am throwing it back.
I froze Magneto.
Oh, no.
They broke it.
What do I do?
What if I win these, though?
Just die on point.
I got beat up by Hulk behind me.
I didn't even notice.
I don't know how to give you orbs.
I feel like we should just ban Hulk.
Hulk guy and Hulk.
That's all I care about now.
If hell is open, I'll diff whoever's on it.
I got my hope for this fight.
We can win this.
I can't deal with Hulk anymore.
Yo, what is this guy doing over here?
He's just sticking to the wall.
I thought that wall was going to save me.
And that's why I hid there.
But I realized it did not.
Yes, you are.
Nope.
Jesus Christ.
Please look at me.
We're running over.
We're up too.
We should just go.
I forced Luna ult.
I'm going to ult after this.
You're going to get eaten.
I'm getting eaten.
Goodbye, I guess.
He's not.
He's like 170 HP.
He's 140.
He blew me up.
He blew you?
You did what?
We're up.
You have a freaky ass shark.
Oh no.
I blocked it.
I can't get out of this hole.
No you didn't.
I died next to you.
You're by yourself.
I killed their Luna.
We don't need to regroup.
But we don't have time to regroup.
I'll save the ult first.
Next fight.
I don't think it's worth...
I don't think it's worth using my ult here.
I agree.
Good call.
I don't think we would have won that.
Alright, so our Lord Wolverine is rocking a steady even KD.
I'm going to need this guy to start doing God's work.
I gave him orb, but he's not doing anything with it.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know where to put the orb.
Yeah, I'll just put it in.
You don't know?
I didn't have to say anything.
I thought he'd do something.
I mean, I stopped giving him orb this round, but...
Yeah, he's just not doing anything.
Oh, we have two tanks now.
Nice.
Oh my god, finally!
Okay, your orb privileges are gone.
Did you guys see this robot playing the bongos?
Yeah, what's wrong with that?
Nothing, he's just chilling.
I'm putting the orb on the tanks.
Sorry, they gotta live.
Oh, okay.
I'll give it to you first to see how you do it.
If you don't get a pick, it's going back to the tanks.
Portal!
Goodbye, Starlord.
I'm coming back.
Oh, I saw the Jeff.
Fuck him up!
Kill the shark!
Get his ass!
Please, he baited you guys.
And now we might...
No, I'm back on the hype.
Oh my god, Jeff.
Guys, he literally baited you guys.
Please, come back!
Why did you walk away?
I do.
Oh my god.
Oopsie daisies.
Your ult blended in with the floor.
Oh my god.
Oopsie daisies.
Really?
My bad.
There's a Hulk who is scaring me.
He made me not want to be near him anymore.
Guys, I don't think this is a climbing stack anymore.
No, no, no, no, no.
I don't think this is a climbing stack.
Hulk to my right, Hulk!
Oh my god.
Give me the flake.
Give me the snow.
Got my one.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
I'm a man.
Yeah, you are.
Yo, look at me, Neo.
Okay.
Yo, I need care.
I'm getting shit on.
Guys, I'm getting...
Fuck me, dude.
I got so ulted by the Iron Man in the sky.
There is...
Ruben, you're fine.
You're so healthy.
Wait, he's one, he's one, he's one.
Why?
I never...
I always get so ulted.
I'm so sad.
I'm shitting on them.
Oh wait, that was such a good ult, Ruben.
I fucking swear!
Yo, guys, watch out.
There's a jam.
No, Iron Man's one.
No!
Yo, no supports.
But they also have one support.
That was both their supports, so be careful.
Yep.
I think they're portaling.
Care portal.
I'm so sad.
I'm coming over.
I'm coming over with...
I'm gonna ult on the point.
I'm gonna just live.
Just live and I'll ult on the point.
I am living so hard right now.
There we go.
Just fucking brawl it out, I guess.
No, Namor's one.
Their Luna is still low.
Their Luna's literally right there, just running away!
Please!
Oh my god, I'll kill her.
I guess I'll do the job.
I'll do it myself.
That Magneto's one.
They have no supports.
That's a fucking lie.
Yup, beautiful.
Oh shit.
Honestly, I might be the strange goat.
62% Yeah, maybe the best range North America.
What can I say?
Is this live or pre-recorded?
Oh my god.
Oh, you're now gonna be- Oh my god, I'm freaking avoiding our Wolverine.
I'm avoiding our Wolverine.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
What a good guy.
Alright.
Guys, this is where the win streak starts, right?
Can you stop the queue?
I need to go pee.
How long is the pee gonna be?
You're gonna make it.
Just do it fast.
No, just do it fast.
How long do you fucking pee?
Dude, I washed my hands.
So?
We have bands.
We literally have two bands.
Nah,
he's gonna be fucking squirming in his seat.
This is not good.
Oh my god.
Try to win this game as fast as possible.
Oh my god, just freaking pee.
Like, I pee in between queues too.
No, we got the- Oh my god, remember that guy?
The Mickey Poo guy?
He was not great.
I think I removed him from my brain to protect myself.
He was not doing that great.
What did he play?
He did not do so well.
He was a Black Panther.
And he had very low DPS damage.
Wait, somebody DC'd.
I think it's you.
I don't see your bar.
Your bar just didn't move.
Your bar and someone on the enemy team's bar hasn't moved.
You know what?
Maybe I can pee.
Alright, alright.
I'm reconnecting.
It was me.
I was like, huh?
It was me all along.
I got scared there for a second.
That was scary.
How did I...
I've never had that happen before.
Yeah, fuck Hawkeye.
We should ban Doctor Strange.
Or Hulk?
Do you think they have a Hulk player though?
No, I just don't want to gamble.
I just hate Hulk.
I'm sick and tired of that fucking character.
I'm tired of playing against Hulk too.
You're gonna have a Strange then.
That's fine.
I think I'd rather play against Strange than Hulk.
Why is my Starlord banned?
Stream sniping?
Who's got a tab up?
I just started playing him three games ago.
What the fuck?
I like how he just locked the magic after that.
Maybe stream sniping?
Wait, we didn't ban Hulk?
What the fuck?
Yeah, you can play Psy.
Oh wait, no.
Why do we have so many DPS players?
Okay, I'll go support.
Unless Mac wants to trade.
Alright, Mac.
Do you think...
What do we want?
Magic or Psylocke?
This is all up to you to decide.
You can go Psylocke.
Thank you!
You owe him.
I'll make you proud.
If we lose, we never let Ruben play.
There is no if.
There is no if we lose because we will win.
We will win.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm a little scared of Penny Solotank, but...
Okay guys, I can't mute myself because I realize it's my damage boost.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, that's...
Why did we not ban Hulk?
Yep.
Who would have thought Hulk was open?
My whole time, man.
On a good map for it.
Oh my god.
I'm damage boosting.
I'm breaking the red beacon.
Punisher.
Punisher, I'm gonna give you infinite on this corner.
Yeah.
I have damage boosting in here.
They're all so low.
They're all so low in there.
We can't, like, progress because...
I got slapped.
The turret's one.
They're all so low.
I can't heal you up there.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Okay, I'm just gonna try and keep our...
They're like...
Oh, just change his ult!
They're gonna get rez here.
I think.
Hulk, burn Hulk, burn Hulk, burn Hulk.
Oh, it's unlucky.
I'm asleep.
Wait, how did you not get rezzed?
I just didn't.
Alright, manair.
My rez has been down the whole time.
Does it have a radius on it?
I think it might.
Because I was pretty deep in their background.
I don't know, I don't really play Rocket that much.
I don't know, I understand.
I think you've got a good hang of him.
Alright, nice.
I'm damage boosting this random guy.
Alright, I might go in and out of mute because my mute button is F and I need damage boost.
Okay, bad.
F is my self damage boost, so there is a chance that I might go in and out.
Okay, they used M.O.
Okay.
I have ult here.
I'm backing up.
They fucked up the fish.
Oh, there's the Hulk over there.
Left side Hulk, oh wait.
Hulk is low, Hulk is low.
Ulti in front of us, snowball, okay?
I'm ulting for him.
Just snowball up on us.
I'm pushing cart, I'm pushing cart.
We need...
No, that was behind us!
I die out of my shift.
Yeah.
Can we cap it?
Can we still cap it maybe?
Yes.
This is winnable, this is winnable.
Nice.
Wait, everybody split up.
Wait, what?
Why did all you guys split up?
I'm going right side.
I think everybody came back though.
No!
I thought...
I'm dead.
The damage boost to you?
I have a Hulk trying to run at me.
I wanted to save.
I slept him.
Hulk is one, Hulk is one.
It's fine.
Oh, he's solo.
Dude, this Mantis just ran me down.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
I don't have enough heals for you.
Hulk one, Hulk one.
Dead, bro.
I don't know what you want, we're dead.
There's definitely a Mantis right behind you.
I had no more leaves!
I get four heals, brother.
Oh my god, my leaves were gone!
What do you want me to do?
You were taking 200 damage!
Okay.
They can pull a headshot!
They have so much shields!
Alright, I'm going right side.
Let me know if you're going to ult.
I can damage boost you.
Alright.
No ammo.
Okay.
I put him up.
Oh, Loki one, Loki one!
There's a door.
Hulk low.
Oh my god, that damage boosted the wrong person.
I can't heal him.
Oh my god, I had no...
They used ammo.
Hulk does!
No, he lives.
Do they have medical?
They should, yes, they should.
There it is.
They used poke support ult too.
I don't know if he lives though.
I'm just going back, I'm not going to use anything.
They used three ults here.
Hulk one, Hulk one!
I can't save him.
Oh my god.
We need to reset, but everybody is...
No more, please!
I can't!
No more!
I need heals.
Okay, I got Iron Man.
Can you heal me real quick?
Thank you.
I'm going to go in with...
Oh no.
Where do I go in, where do I go in?
I'm ulting on Kurt.
Okay.
We're fine.
Hulk on your back, Hulk on your back Punisher.
Hulk right behind you.
I stopped him.
We're fine.
I got out.
I'll focus on killing clones.
I'm dead, goodbye.
I don't think we can...
I don't think this guy is blaming the right person.
Yeah, I don't think he is.
I haven't played Loki before, but I've got a good feeling about this.
I don't think we can touch.
Our Penny might...
No, there's no way.
She's not touching that, no.
I might just go a second tank for defense.
I don't think we can run the solo Penny.
No, I don't think so either.
Mag, do you want to do Mantis?
Or what support do you want to play?
I don't know, to be honest.
I'll probably just say Rocket.
Say Rocket?
Okay, I'll say Mantis then.
Oh my god, why the fuck do we have solo Penny?
She has to be a one trick.
I feel like today...
Yesterday...
We always have these weird queues where it's like...
Yesterday, we always get support.
Today, it's literally zero tanks.
It's actually crazy.
All the tank players have actual lives where they're actually spending Christmas with their families.
Yeah, they're all the wholesome guys.
They're all the people that actually have families to spend Christmas on.
DPS players and...
They have families because they're tanks.
Yeah, DPS players and supports have nobody.
We have more than rivals, okay?
We got...
You have your open mic, Ruben.
They must be like, what the fuck?
Dude, I'm so fucking pissed.
This game does that.
It just puts me on open mic sometimes when I tap out.
I have to...
My frames are good this round.
That's very reassuring.
There is somebody behind us.
Okay,
nice.
Nice!
You're fine, right?
Over there?
What's going on down here?
There's somebody behind here.
Yeah, there we go.
Alright.
Guys, I'm gonna smell on a full hold here.
No, don't say that.
Now you're gonna jinx it.
Now you're gonna jinx this shit.
No, no, no.
It's not possible.
My thing wasn't deploying?
Okay, it's not on a 5 second cooldown.
They're above on the right.
Psylocke on bridge.
What?
I died from that far?
There's a Psylocke behind us.
I can't kill these guys over there.
I have to jump.
Oh, their name was half.
Their Psylocke's low too.
I got you.
Give you
infinite.
There's a Hulk in front of us.
Hulk is one.
Hulk is on high ground.
Little baby banner.
Strange is half.
Okay, but he's getting healed though.
Strange is...
Oh my god, he's just getting healed.
Psylocke just killed our Punisher.
Yep.
This is scary.
Psylocke's on the height on the left.
Oh, hell no.
Did I get the Hulk?
No, wait.
I got you.
Yeah, but we're using a lot though.
Haha.
Psylocke behind.
Oh, I got Psylocke ulted in the back.
This is great.
Brother, you're standing in the middle of the opening and it's four.
What do you mean great heals?
My heals are on you and you're dead.
Haha.
Oh my god, he's just dead.
Oh, I didn't get anyone with that.
Do you think I'm Jesus Christ and I can just touch you and save you from any fucking illness, brother?
What the fuck do you expect?
I'm a raccoon with a gun.
Haha.
I don't think that's...
I think you're not okay.
I think we're just...
Why are you wanting more by the way?
Are you just retarded or what?
Oh my god, bro.
Bro.
I told you that Mickey Pooh.
I told you guys.
I told you.
I was like, oh my god.
Okay, look.
I need you guys to use your void slots because I don't have any left.
Like I really need you guys to use it.
I can't.
I don't have heals.
I'm trying.
I'm giving you so much.
I'm doing so much.
I'm trying to.
I'm ulting.
He just showed up and is about to die immediately again.
Okay.
I'm on it.
I'm on here.
I'm just hoping it hits people.
I dropped infinite right in front of you, Punisher.
He's just standing outside the infinite.
Oh my god.
My god.
Get 1v1, bitch.
Bro, he has getting healed.
Oh my god.
Okay, the Psylocke is low.
Nice.
Alright, now we gotta defend this for two minutes.
Whoa.
Oh, thank god.
Now he knows who to blame.
I'm trying.
He wants him to go Psylocke into that.
Yeah, that's a good comp to pick Psylocke into, I think.
Honestly, he might be a genius.
Someone make this an NRG coach.
Fuck, bro.
I can't see that.
Oh my god.
This is where we die.
I dropped infinite for you.
I'm trying to heal you.
He destroyed the rez.
Mantis, help!
Help me!
No, I think...
Bro!
He's blaming everybody who's losing!
He's actually blaming everybody who had to fill around his dumb ass.
It's everybody's fault, except for us.
Except for him, himself.
That's actually crazy.
He's blaming everybody but himself.
What the fuck?
Yeah, the dude would just like peek, fall over.
Don't Q.
Okay, so we got the avoid Mikipoo.
I got avoid slots.
Someone got to get Mikipoo.
Okay.
Mikipoo avoided.
Avoid me, all of you.
Wait, we shouldn't!
Let's not avoid the Punisher, because he's going to piss him off if we get on his team again.
That'd be funny, but I don't mind.
I won't piss him off if we do get him again.
Yeah, you can Q now.
He's like, avoid me.
That's fucking hilarious.
Oh, he's on the enemy team!
Yo, we got to lock the fuck in.
If I'm locking in, I'm muting myself.
I'm deafening in chat.
I'm putting on a three minute delay.
Okay, I'm locking in, but I'm literally going to deafen myself.
Alright, I'm locking in chat.
If I'm locking in, I have to deafen myself.
I can't lock in.
I told you guys, this is why I don't stream when I'm in a stack.
I don't lock in.
I literally need to focus on here.
Okay, I'm banning Hawkeye.
I'm not playing against the Hawkeye.
I never want to play against the Hawkeye.
Okay, I actually have to focus up then.
I definitely play so much better when I'm not in a call with people.
Alright.
That's fine.
That's totally fine.
We have a solo Penny again, but that's okay.
Alright.
We're gonna lock in.
That's- today's the day we lock in, everybody.
Today's the day.
Okay, only if I'm gonna die, but I'll unmute myself just so you know, I don't fucking die.
Okay.
I'll unmute myself after.
If I get like, died 24-7.
Cause I actually hit more.
Uh...
If you don't play...
Oh my god.
Bro, that's fucking funny.
Dude, I just deceived him.
Come on, man.
What is this?
Like, they're trying to deceive us.
I think they're lying.
Okay, focus up.
I actually hit more shots.
I think cause I'm not distracting when I'm talking to people.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll put- I'm putting on the Penny.
She's taking much more damage than I expected.
Alright.
Nice.
Are they on Hella?
Hey, they're on Hella.
He's one.
Nice.
Cool.
We're doing it, guys.
We're doing it.
Alright.
Guys, they lied.
I can't believe they also lied.
That's fucked up.
Oh my god.
They also lied?
I can't believe they would do such a thing.
Lying in a video game?
Okay.
What?
Alright.
Okay.
What is this team?
Alright.
Okay, guys.
Guys, you can still die from this, although...
Guys, okay, I don't think he realized you can still die from this.
Oh my god.
Please.
He's so low.
Oh, nice.
I distracted him.
Let's go.
I told you, guys.
The moment I'm deafened.
I don't know why.
Talking to you guys, I'm more focused.
Legitimately, I can aim better.
I can freeze everything.
Talking to you guys, I'm playing better.
Like, I should be more distracted.
I'm looking at chat, but for some reason...
Like, here, it's just different.
It's just different.
I just play different.
That is not great.
I'm fucking cheating.
Like, look at that.
Holy shit.
That looked like I was walling.
That prediction there.
Alright, let's lock in now.
Let's actually focus up.
Okay, there was no saving him at all.
What?
Oh my god.
I need to look at where my cloak was.
Where the fuck were you looking at?
Where?
Ha!
Okay.
Alright.
We gotta regroup.
Okay.
I hope, like...
Oh my god.
I need...
Please, I can't see you.
Okay.
Oh, that's alright.
He was not gonna live anyway.
Look at that damage.
I don't think he was gonna live.
Oh, Ruben.
You take so much damage.
It scares me.
Oh, Ruben.
You take so much damage.
It's scaring the shit out of me right now.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh, I'm putting on a show.
They have Groot ult.
I know they're gonna Groot ult this.
They're gonna Groot ult.
They have Groot ult.
Right here.
No!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We have three up.
We're three up.
That's fine.
Oh, we're so healthy.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Travis, I have to go now.
Have a good rest.
Wait.
Wait, Viva is 4-6?
Guys, Viva is 4-6.
Let's go!
He has four kills on Hela.
Let's let you go.
Alright, back to deafened mode.
Good luck, everybody.
I actually, not gonna lie, if I was deafened, I think we would actually climb.
No, dude!
I'm hitting like every fucking shot and I freeze.
I don't know.
I will say, when you deafened, I just started hitting the biggest range ults ever seen by man.
Yeah, I think we're all just locked in.
But dude, it's either that or the fact that we really, really wanna beat Viva.
I think we all sat down to beat him.
Yeah, we all just really wanna... He's the only one negative on their team.
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm locking in.
Alright, he locked back in.
Alright, here we go.
Travis humiliate Viva.
Hey.
I'll put it on Penny.
I feel like Penny is...
For some reason, Penny looks like a feeder.
For some fucking reason, I can tell Penny...
Penny looks like the feeder of the team.
For some fucking reason...
I fucking...
I just knew it.
Oh.
I fucking called it, guys.
I fucking called it.
Wait, did our Penny DC there?
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
Oh my god.
I hope I see the Penny walking back.
Oh, he does.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Okay.
Oh my god, guys.
The whole thing, guys.
I knew Penny was...
I can tell playing support has let me realize who's a feeder.
I can tell.
I can read.
I can read the feeder minds.
Alright.
Alright, I'm fucking gonna hide.
Guys, please.
Guys, you don't outlive this.
You don't outlive this, guys.
You don't outlive the damage.
Okay, nice.
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh my god, it's all good.
How did he still play Hella?
He's still letting him play Hella.
Holy fuck.
LOL That's actually crazy that they're still giving him Hella.
That's actually insane.
He should never be on Hella duty.
Goodbye.
Yes, sir.
Oh no.
It's fine, I have ult.
I have ult.
Guys.
Please, I don't want to peek.
Alright, nice.
Let's go, Penny.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go, Penny.
Wait, he lives?
Oh, this is bad.
Like, I don't know where to look yet.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
I fucking did it.
It wasn't even close.
That was so free.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Despite both ways.
Bro, I locked in so hard.
This first grandmastering, bro.
That poor guy.
Bro, you must be so mad.
I hope you lose it.
Bro, I hope you lose it.
You don't deserve it.
Oh my god, he's flaming the support player.
Less damage and the loudest.
Oh my god.
Damn.
Just like...
No heals.
Holy fuck.
He's actually the worst kind of DPS.
Mama Haktur.
Oh my god.
He's that good.
We got Mama Haktur.
There's no way we lose.
We're gonna dive in mines with him.
He goes.
Oh, I can play Mantis.
We at least have two supports.
You know, it's the little things.
Are you banning Hawkeye or Bruce first?
Hawkeye.
Hawkeye and then Bruce because it guarantees the Hawkeye ban.
And then we ban Bruce because fuck Hawke now.
We have a really good Hella player, so I'm not too...
Not too, like, worried about it.
Oh, they got Hella.
We got Hella.
We definitely do.
It's not like three of us are streaming and I'm pretty sure they can look up our streams.
Yeah.
Oh,
he went Widow.
Why hull carry?
It's broken.
Oh, Luna.
I guess Luna Loki could work.
Uh...
I can do...
Do Loki.
I feel like Loki would work in this comp.
Okay,
Loki or Cloak?
I think you should.
This is really good.
We need a double tank for this.
Hmm...
I'll go Cloak, actually, for the heals.
Would you guys prefer I Magneto and then I bubble you whenever you go in?
Oh, yeah, you can bubble me when I ult.
Alright.
Oh...
Just cause, like, I feel like we might need the extra heals.
Loki might be good for offensive, not defensive.
Honestly, dude, filling is kind of fun.
No, it's not.
I don't mind it that much.
Penny over there.
I can't heal you over there.
We also lost one.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
Oh, they DC'd.
Oh, and then he reconnects?
Really?
Oh my god.
Yo, yo!
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
Why did he type?
He was typing!
That's actually crazy.
He, like, typed to apologize.
That's unlucky.
We literally lost that because of...
Uh...
Hmm...
This is just really unfortunate.
Me and the Salak have just been having a 1v1 for like 10 minutes.
I'm trying to keep you guys up.
I'm slowly rotating to the other side.
They're so low.
Yeah, they're all just...
Shut up, Raccoon and Groot.
Penny dies.
Okay.
Maybe not.
She dies.
I think...
I don't know.
No, they got rez.
They have rez here.
I can aggressively ult this.
Okay.
I'm on my way.
I have no DPS up right now.
Um, we're down.
We're down too.
I don't know.
I'm coming.
Our Luna died.
Yeah.
I forced Luna ult.
That's actually huge.
Yeah, yeah.
But we don't have spoilers.
They still... Did they use rocket ult?
They did use rocket ult, yeah.
Okay, so we both...
I'm not sure, actually.
I lied.
I don't know if they used it.
I know that...
Wait, they did use rocket ult.
Oh, yeah.
That's fine.
I'm getting rid of the mines.
I'm dead.
I can try and...
kill you.
I can't heal you.
I can't heal...
Yeah, they rez too.
Oh!
I can't do anything.
I literally can't do anything.
I killed Psylocke.
They walled us off.
Damn.
I have ult here.
You have to play on my ult, though.
I'm done.
The only thing I can do is just try and keep you alive.
I come back with the Megiddo ult.
Groot's gonna have his ult in like one second.
I can't do anything.
I am...
Our Groot is gonna die too.
Our Groot's dead.
You have no supports.
I don't know if I should...
Should I play rocket?
I feel like a defensive ult.
I think I...
I think I ult on Megiddo and swap off.
I'm doing fucking nothing.
Yeah, alright.
Alright.
Yeah, our Widow got hella staggered.
There's three on it.
Yeah, I can't do anything.
I can't heal you there.
I'm coming out.
Okay.
We're giving them so much free space.
They're hard pushing us.
Okay.
I got...
We have to help Ruben with the Bourbons.
Yeah.
We got nothing.
Nice.
That's huge.
We have to push up.
We have to help our...
Nice.
He's low.
They're low.
They're so low.
Oh my god.
They're so fucking...
They're all so low.
Back up, I think.
We should back up.
Man.
There's a Penny to my left.
Penny's hot.
I can't.
I'm ulting.
I'm sent.
I'm done.
I just got no more head units from so far.
I only have solo ulting.
I mean, I'm the only solo healer.
Be careful.
We're both back.
But we're giving them so much free space.
Never mind.
They have rez.
Our Groot is having trouble.
They have so much free space.
That's the only issue.
Yeah.
They're just freely pushing.
Oh, there's a Psylocke there.
Yeah, I saw.
They're all... their Luna's one.
We're coming back.
We don't have Luna ult anymore though.
Psylocke behind.
On my right.
I'm coming back.
Psylocke looking for me.
Wow.
Oh, that's huge.
That's huge.
That's actually...
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Help our Groot if we can.
I'm coming back fast.
Nice.
They have two fights here.
I'm one.
We're trying to heal you right now.
I'm trying to get all ults here.
I have all here.
Oh my god.
Groot, please.
I got ulted by Groot.
You should live this.
Oh, we used double support also.
Killed Psylocke.
Nice.
I'm flexing Penny.
Psylocke has ult.
Groot dies.
Raccoon dies.
Raccoon's one.
Oh my god.
They have one full fight.
Alright.
They have Psylocke ult too.
I don't think we should stay close.
We have no support ults.
I'm trying to get out.
Psylocke's on my right.
Yeah, our Psylocke is waiting for us.
Penny!
That's fine.
Psylocke on the right.
I have assemble.
Assemble!
Oh my god, I just got blown up.
He's looking for ult to Psylocke.
Oh, I think...
I'm just going to die on Karthus.
Do we have one more touch?
I don't think so.
Yeah, that was literally the last fight.
We just couldn't build support ults in time.
Because we double support ulted.
That's fucked.
They did cap an OT though, so we got time.
Yeah.
I just feel like...
I think I have to go Cloak.
Just because of the heal output.
Jesus Christ.
These games are so sweaty now, chat!
These games are so sweaty!
Oh my god.
These times.
They're so sweaty.
When do the games get so fucking difficult?
I'm going to kick some plants.
Kick some fucking plants.
GM2 was such a nice place to be.
And now I'm back here in the fucking dungeons.
What?
Goddamnit!
Because...
All these players...
They're so over Christmas.
They're all just...
Nothing else in their lives, just like me.
Playing Barbaral Rivals.
But I just have a problem.
I just have issues.
With mines.
Careful!
It's fine, he's a tree.
Trees are weak to fire.
Trees are immune to fire now.
No, they're okay.
It's fine.
There's a penny running at me.
What?
He's out.
Oh, there's a red beacon!
You can't get healed up there, by the way.
You know you can't get healed up there.
You guys can't.
Dude, there was a red beacon up there that we didn't get.
Bro, I can't.
Oh my god, they just keep...
I don't think we should fight.
They literally just lock us.
They just keep locking people in there.
Yeah, we need to go left.
Yeah, I can't do anything about it.
Yeah, I can't do anything.
Oh my god, this spot is fucking...
fucking baller.
I think we should go left.
Yeah, let's go there.
We're trying to put pressure on them on the right.
Their group literally just kept walling us off.
What the fuck?
There's also a red beacon up there.
Go left.
I'm just trying to keep you up.
I can't fight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should back up into my bubble if you can.
Oh my god, I'm fucking fine.
Alright.
Oh my god, he threw the mine at me.
Ow.
I killed Luna.
She just got rezzed.
She got rezzed on height.
To your left, Namor.
Alright, Namor died instantly.
Oof.
I took the risk with that ult.
It was not a good risk.
There's always a 50-50 when it comes to the mines like that.
Oh my god.
I don't know where I should go.
Hmm.
I could go low-key here.
I just ulted.
Whatever.
We can't heal you though.
We can't heal you.
Oh, Namor.
I got the Sunlock ult and I killed the Namor.
What the fuck?
Where did that mine come from?
It can walk from...
If she connects her webs, the mines can walk along them from her shaft.
Oh my, that's so broken.
I didn't even know that.
I was like, what?
How did that get here?
Got you.
This is the last fight.
I got like...
Yeah.
Yeah, I couldn't.
I got Psylocked.
I...
Oh, we lost the Luna ult.
Oh, we lost the Luna ult?
Okay.
No way he doesn't die there.
I just think we just didn't have tank waves.
Jesus Christ.
I almost hate the mine there.
I don't have...
I feel scared to ult this after last time I exploded.
We have to go though.
I did a quick portal.
I can't dash because of the Nemoro.
Damn.
There's so many fucking things.
I can't...
I can't live through this.
We're getting so unlucky getting no tank players every single game.
Alright, do we know any tank friends?
Do we...
Call up xQc.
I might have to start doing it every game.
I might just bite the bullet.
And play tank?
I suppose I can.
I'll play Duke.
Fucking strange if it's open.
And then this point...
It's just...
The reason why we're losing is just we don't have tank players.
Ah, it's so fucked.
It actually is.
The fact that we don't... Like, everyone individually are good players, but we just don't have anyone that actually can play tank.
Especially like...
Because the previous game I played tank and went fine, but those tank players were just so much better because they play their role.
Yeah.
I think like... I don't know.
Visually we all did okay.
I just don't think we...
We just don't have tank players.
What is this?
Wait, the sleep guy was the group player.
He was really good.
Wasn't he?
Maybe?
I don't remember.
No, I remember.
He was the tank player.
I don't know if he actually played tank or was a filly.
They have our group on their team from last game.
I don't really know if our group was good or not, honestly.
Oh look!
Oh my god!
We have a strange locker?
Oh wait, that was you.
Oh my god, it's working!
Wait, okay.
We just win this game.
Oh my god!
Bruce or Hawkeye first?
Hawkeye.
Always Hawkeye.
I'm too traumatized.
Oh my god, he's a natural.
Guys, we have a doctor on Dr. Strange.
Oh my god, thank god.
And then Bruce, right?
I'm banning Bruce.
Yeah, they got the hella.
They definitely got the hella.
Dr. Unique!
Yeah, he's a doctor, so of course he's gonna be on Dr. Strange.
There's another 3-stack?
Well, 3-stacks tries to match 3-stack always matches other 3-stacks.
Oh my god, this is it.
If we lose, we're just bad.
No, if we lose, our teammates are bad.
If we lose, it's us.
We're the problem.
No teammate can save us.
We have 4 people on their hero.
How long have I been streaming for?
Oh my god, 6 hours.
Oh my grinder.
Guys, do you think we can win back all the stuff we lost today?
Eternity today.
Guys, do you think we can make it back at least even?
I think I'm either even or up one right now.
We're definitely...
Mac and I are definitely not even.
We need like 4 wins.
We were so good yesterday.
We farmed.
We farmed yesterday, but today our team matches are so bad.
All the tank players have fucking families.
Yeah.
They're celebrating Christmas and shit, man.
Come on, losers.
Get on Rivals, bro.
We need you in the Qs.
Don't have families.
Aw, they're playing Rocket.
Oh, what the fuck just killed me?
Psylocke?
I'm worried now.
But where's their Psy...
Their Psylocke might come for me, so I'm just gonna go into this corner.
Oh, no.
Psylocke in hole.
Is it Psylocke?
He's like half.
I broke the red beacon.
Psylocke to our right.
Where is he?
We got one.
Their Penny's one.
We need a cap soon, though.
Their Penny can die.
Penny dead.
Bro, why didn't you wake him up?
Oh, thank God.
I'm fucking happy.
You like woke him up.
Oh, my God.
I got you.
Okay, huge.
Oh, Dr. Unique, please live.
You're so unique.
Oh, this is perfect.
I'm gonna use my ult after this.
I have to hide.
I'm hiding.
We used Mantis ult.
We double-spoilt it.
I'm damage boosting this.
Let's use everything.
I don't mind that.
There's a Penny up top.
And he lives.
Can you tell Mantis Luna first, then Mantis.
We don't double-spoilt ult.
I literally can't heal this.
I'm trying to shoot it up.
There's literally a wall in front of you.
I'm in the air if you can give a heal up top.
I have to.
I'm trying to...
I can't.
I can't peek now.
No, Groot just two-tapped me.
We can't.
I don't know...
Their Groot blocked the door.
I'm backing out.
I got you.
I got the Groot, though.
Jesus, you're taking so much damage.
Okay, that's Luna.
Wait, did you tell them Mantis Luna?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm ulting.
Oh my god, we're coordinated, Mantis!
We're doing it!
We're coordinating!
I killed three.
That's all I can do.
Let's kill this Raccoon, too.
Fuck this Raccoon.
Fuck him up.
Turn him into Roadkill.
Okay, the Raccoon ran away.
And the fish guy.
Yeah, they used Luna.
I'm gonna go for my ult this fight.
Yeah, it's fine.
Oh my god.
Chat, this...
This game is so much more difficult.
Holy fucking mines.
Yeah.
What did they do?
Groot!
Oh, that's huge, that's huge!
I froze the Mantis Penny, too!
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Oh my god!
Penny one, Penny one!
Alright.
I've never been so sweaty before in Marvelous.
I'm fucking impassioned.
I want my points back.
We will get them back.
I'm 1HP.
We're not 1HP.
I'm literally...
The face of a liar.
Yeah.
Who desperately wants heals.
Oh my god.
No way, bro!
I'm not ulting you.
It's just you.
I'm not ulting this.
It's literally just you that got hit!
That's so fucked up!
Like, I can't do any...
Like, I'm not gonna solo ult for you.
No, no, no.
I'm saying, why did they solo me?
Yeah, they solo ulted you, but I was not solo ulting.
No, no, no.
It was worth that I got that out.
But it's like, why the fuck did they solo me?
Mac!
Why?!
I should have yelled at you to get back here.
The Psylocke above me, I didn't know.
You were literally by yourself.
Okay, I got it.
Psylocke behind!
That's fine.
I have my ult.
I have my ult here.
I killed her.
Nice.
That's huge!
Penny is fucking bouncing up and down.
Oh my god, that's not...
That's fine.
Guys, there's literally just this Penny that's just chilling there.
Penny is solo.
I...
I hate these mines.
There were so many.
Where do I go?
Where do I go to be alive?
My first fucking...
I should have went left instead of forward.
I know.
Please.
It was my one death.
Every other...
I was playing out of my mind until that death.
Wait, what happened?
I walked into all the mines.
It's her.
Then the strange watched me walk into all the mines.
Perfect.
You know what?
Sometimes it happens.
Thank you, doctor.
I don't have health insurance, so...
Damn, should have told him that afterwards.
Maybe he'll do it pro bono.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe we should invite him.
I like this guy.
Bro, I don't mind playing with Doctor Unique.
Yo, guys, I think there's some spider mines in front.
Let's pick him up.
There might be some bombs.
Doctor Unique.
My strongest doctor, bro.
This is the guy doing my brain surgery.
I got fished!
He was the guy, I was like...
Oh my god.
Guys, what happened?
What's going on?
I need to rebook my appointment.
Fuck this.
Okay, Mr. Sleep is not getting the memo right now.
By the way, you have no support in your poor lariat.
I'm him.
I walked into a mine.
Oh my god.
I froze him.
That's fucking karma.
I have spider on me.
He froze him again.
I know somebody hit him.
Please.
Dude.
I can ult this.
Is it worth ulting?
I think so.
Okay.
It's fine, you guys are fine.
I am ulting this for our group.
Oh, I fucked up.
Okay, I don't know.
I don't think it was worth ulting it.
Ah, shit.
I couldn't.
He body blocked me.
I think we got regrouped.
Yeah, we're just staggering in over and over again.
And we used both support ults.
Wait, we can totally kill Penny here.
Yeah, but they have rez.
I'm just gonna go in and ult.
I'm here.
I have your orb on you.
I'm ulting.
I don't see you for...
Okay.
Oh, his ult is still going.
Yeah, nothing crit ulted.
We have three fights left.
Or two fights actually.
We have a crit ult and a snowball in the face.
We don't have support ults, I don't think so.
I gave you...
There's so many fish up there, man.
I got one of them.
What are fish doing in the sky?
Fish got...
I got you.
This might be our last fight if we stall it here.
Oh, their Punisher's one.
I'm trying to find their rez.
Their Namor's still on top right.
Punisher's low.
I'm on point.
Then I can die.
That's huge.
Dude, their Namor's one top.
Raccoon, raccoon, raccoon!
Groot, please!
Groot's on point!
Literally, a Groob and a Namor on point.
Please, Groot and Namor.
I can't survive.
I can't survive here.
We need one on point.
We need three on point.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
That was stressful, guys.
Yeah, a little bit.
Oh, I killed myself.
Alright.
Please, Mantis, you're stressing me the fuck out.
I am...
I just got two-tapped out of spawn.
Yeah, we're not saving Doctor.
I'm not saving that guy.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to...
Whoa, I froze the Groot, though.
Oh, Mantis.
Namor's one.
I'm tipped to mines.
We got our Groob.
We're staggering.
We're literally going in one by one.
Yeah, but we're still staggering.
We're literally looking out.
Guys?
Guys, please.
I'm waiting in spawn.
I don't trust any of you guys anymore.
Oh, mine.
I have ult.
Penny does.
Yeah.
I froze Groot.
I'm trying to peek you for a heal.
Okay, I'm ulting.
I'm ulting this for us.
We have...
Guys, guys, Namor, Namor, Namor!
Please, please, please, Namor!
Guys!
There we go.
Penny?
Penny low.
I'm gonna break something.
I'm dead.
Penny dead.
Rocket, rocket.
There's a rez up there.
I can't heal because I'm on point.
You're getting Luinta's heals.
Rocket's dead.
Their Penny's pretty low.
I froze him.
Please, please.
Oh, thank god.
I'm dead.
I can't...
I was gonna say I can't.
This is overtime.
I'll get there quickly with ult.
Our Groot's going crazy.
Yes!
Oh my god!
So free.
Soon I'm playing out of my fucking mind there.
Honestly, the chillest game I've ever had.
I literally...
Oh my god!
I was gonna break a table if we lost because I'm the most fucking solid in the game.
I was gonna break something.
Wait, you did get the drip.
Of course I got the drip.
Goddamn.
Oh my god.
I'm officially up one.
I was so mad.
It's like...
I was... Okay, the thing that tilted me the most was that I was screaming about the Nemoir and then I saw Ruben not even turn around.
That's...
That's what got me going the most.
Not even just...
Not even just Ruben.
Everybody was just...
I was about to fucking...
I was about to punch something.
Oh my god.
I was so mad.
I was so fucking mad.
Is it Hawkeye?
Hawkeye, let's go.
This guy wants to ban Mantis.
Oh, too bad for him.
It sucks to fucking suck.
Oh, he's gonna flip to Mantis.
I can feel it.
It always does this to me.
Oh, thank god.
Now, who do we ban?
Bruce.
Okay.
Sucks to be that guy.
Why is he not curious about Mantis?
Yeah, they're gonna have a Mantis anyways.
Yeah.
It's just because he doesn't want to deal with the defensive bullshit.
I feel like it's worse to play into Luna with Psylocke.
Because her ult is even better against your ult.
Yeah.
If Mantis has no one around him, you kill through Mantis ult.
That's basically it.
This guy took my fucking Psylocke.
Oh, guess who's tanking again.
Okay.
Do we endorse the Captain America pick?
With Thor, it's actually not bad.
Yeah, I mean, we could try with Thor.
Okay.
We are on offense.
Yeah.
Yo, but I do have the best skin in the game.
Check it out.
I've been so locked in for like four games now.
You like my Captain America skin?
No.
What the fuck?
Why is it yellow?
Yo, I'm Captain Peach, dude.
What country is that?
That's not America.
Is it A for America?
I'm fighting for Peach, buddy.
I don't know what to tell you.
What the fuck?
A for America?
Yeah.
What's the lore?
Dude, we're matching.
Okay, guys.
I just realized I'm going to be on and off mute again because I'm on Mantis and my mute key is bound on F.
Why is your push to mute F?
Because it's close.
It's like so close to me.
I really like having it off.
So I can like press it instantly if I need to talk.
Oh, I'm dead.
Spider-Man just took my butt.
It's okay.
Captain America is on the rooftops.
Alright, that's fine.
Do you know what you're doing?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm...
I'm pushing up with you guys.
Do it guys again.
We can't heal you by the way because it's just me.
It's just me that's healing.
Adam can't do it.
I'm good.
Oh my god.
No more shifting.
I'm going to push cart a little bit.
And then I'll push cart a little bit.
Alright, I'm pushing up.
I'm damage boosting.
I got you.
He's asleep.
Fuck him up.
I just need to waste a leaf just so I can be able to push the top.
Okay.
I got you.
I got damage boost on you.
There's more to my left.
Here's another damage boost.
We really got to break these walls.
We are undefeatable.
I have all here too.
I'm going to wait a little bit.
Oh, never mind.
I got damage.
Almost fell off the map.
Please kill the group.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm shielding you.
I'm okay.
I'm going to rez up.
I hope our cocoon boy is okay too.
I have assemble for next wave.
Let's do it.
These walls are really fucking me up.
I got him.
I am trying to...
There's like people over there.
I don't know if I'm muted or not muted.
I'm just fucking...
That's good because I just damage boosted.
Alright.
I need a rebind.
I'm pushing cart right now.
Okay, I'm coming over.
I damage boosted you.
I'm going to push up with you guys.
I've been standing in the blue orbs.
Why am I not getting healed?
It's fucking poor.
I'm fucking cooked.
The group pushed up.
You only have Adam heals.
Nope.
We got assemble.
Most of us are dead.
I'm healing us.
I'm the support player now.
I'm pushing cart.
Thor is dead though.
We should settle a little bit.
You're right.
America's tank is backing up.
No.
I'm rezzing.
Fucking hell.
No.
We died through this.
No, we reset by dying to the...
Yeah, by mantis ulted.
Did they mantis ult as well?
Yeah, they did.
Sucks though, I had to mantis ult.
Wait, he got off Psylocke.
Actually, this is definitely not a Psylocke map.
Nice.
I got heals on you, but not on the support.
I'm gonna ult here.
Okay.
I am...
I got you.
I damage boosted you too.
What the fuck?
Kill this guy.
Kill him.
There you go.
Get rid of his fucking wood.
There's a Moon Knight to the right.
Oh my god, where are you?
I damage boosted you back.
I can't see you.
Yeah, there's still that Moon Knight to my right.
You got rezzed?
Oh, the Moon Knight's low.
No, I'm dead and I'm more, man.
Nice.
Our Adam didn't drop a heal when he rezzed me.
That Psylocke sucks, bro.
Second chance is over.
Wait, Grizzlow, Grizzlow!
I'm back in.
Okay.
He's so low, he's so low!
No!
Fuck, he's one.
There we go.
He's so low.
No more, no more.
No, you were so bad!
You were actually so bad!
Oh no, oh no.
Why are you doing that?
I'm so sad.
Ow.
That's fine, we got it.
I don't think I can turn back.
That's...
Oh my gosh.
It's fine, it's fine.
We made them waste...
Manta's up.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Two minutes is pretty solid.
Yeah.
Our items did, but that's okay, everything is still okay.
Who's getting fucked?
Fuck them!
Is this worth fighting or no?
For now, I'm up top.
Okay, it's worth fighting.
I'm fucking fighting this.
Raccoon, raccoon, raccoon!
Okay.
There we go.
Penny, penny, penny!
I got her.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm okay.
I just realized they have Chimes.
Solo.
Okay.
I'm so healthy.
Kill them all.
Grid, grid, grid, Ken.
I'm gonna be on them.
Okay.
I damage boosted you.
I still died, but I'm okay.
Wait, I...
Oh, nevermind.
We're okay.
We're so okay.
I feel like you're hearing me cut in and out because...
I hit my F key.
Oh my god.
Come on, man.
Winning this would be my Christmas present.
At least I'm desperate.
I'm gonna do it.
It's gonna be a Doki Christmas miracle.
Yeah, I probably should change my bind.
But like...
The thing is, all the...
All the fucking...
Thank you, Ruben and Doki for...
The thing is...
F is a key is so close.
And only Mantis is the only support character.
Where like, F is a key.
The thing is...
The thing about all the keybinds is that...
They're so...
The abilities have to be close to each other.
So it makes sense to be able to like...
Talk to each other.
Not talk, but be able to access the buttons.
So I...
I didn't know.
I forgot.
I don't know what else to do.
I guess there's cat, but it's not as...
What?
He has open mic too?
What the fuck is going on?
That's the Krampus that they were talking about.
What is going on?
Are they literally mind-boomed already?
Oh yeah, he's super boomed.
Oh my god.
Like, what happened there?
How did they mind-boom?
They literally...
One minute?
That's such...
Honestly, I'd be mind-boomed against us too.
I mean, it's just kind of hopeless for them.
How are they supposed to win?
Oh my god.
I need to self-heal myself.
I killed him.
Nice, thank you.
How do you mind-boom?
Like, you have one minute.
That doesn't make sense.
It's Christmas.
It's Christmas?
Yeah, what the fuck?
Remember what we said about...
Oh wait, guys.
Guys, we're sort of trolling now.
Guys, if they think they're going to win, they will stop mind-booming.
We need to keep making sure they have no hope.
Their Strange really wants me dead.
I damage boosted you, man.
I'm alright.
We need to not give them hope and hope they still feel like shit.
Holy shit, he got exploded.
Yeah, he did.
Yeah, fuck their Christmas up.
I need this more than them.
I mean, they're already playing Marvel Rivals and losing.
How much worse can it be?
Don't worry, I believe in you guys.
We gotta make sure they stop trying.
I can't heal.
Wait, are you ulting?
What if I...
I was gonna say, what if I just hit the nastiest sleep of my life there?
That shit worked, right?
Yeah, I got him.
Oh my god, the defensive Magneto ult.
What do you want me to do, Sylak?
Fucking run in and open?
Dude, the fuck up thing is I hear the I need healing thing and I can't do that.
That's not in my kit.
I literally fucking ran in the open for him.
Sylak trying to flank.
She's on our backstage.
Okay.
She just dropped.
Okay, before we Q mech, we gotta figure out who to avoid from that team.
We gotta figure out who the fuck blew the fuck up.
It's Provy.
It's Provy?
Okay.
Yeah, but then they're saying like somebody refused to swap and stuff.
Uh, I don't care.
That guy is the fucking Grinch incarnate.
I don't want him on my team on Christmas.
Yeah, but we also don't want someone that doesn't swap.
You know how it's like, all it takes is one bad day?
Whoever that didn't swap was his third bad day.
And like, he was the bad day.
Sylak?
Yeah.
Whoa.
Oh my god, there's a Spider-Man too!
Oh, that boy's swinging!
What the fuck?
When is this team?
What is going on?
Yeah, that guy's dead.
Oh!
Goodbye.
Ah, fuck!
Oh, I'm okay.
That's okay.
I have ult.
I have ult for you.
I mean, not ult, but damage boost.
I don't think I should be up here.
Whoa.
Oh.
How?
How are we?
Okay.
Ha, they're all one!
There's a Spider-Man behind us.
And a Sylak.
Wow.
What a game.
What a fucking game.
Worth the loss!
Wait, they have zero tanks!
Okay, okay.
Holy shit, I'm being warned.
Alright.
And okay, aFatBiH said, asking a negative DPS to swap to tank is yapping, and the eSymp said, I need to be normal.
I think this guy might be off the goop.
A little bit.
He might be gooping a little too hard.
Is he okay?
I don't think so.
Only a- wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm female.
Alright, I got you.
I'm getting you good.
Oh my god, 27% accuracy magnus, only a female can do that!
You're a good one!
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Dude, look at this guy's record!
Wait, I didn't, okay, Will's not quoted.
Did one of you avoid him, or am I avoiding him?
I avoided him.
Also, I guess I should have put their masses, like...
27% is not ideal, not gonna lie, I'm sorry.
He's 3 and 8 for the day.
27% is not ideal for your accuracy if you're on that.
Are you quing it?
Yeah, I'm looking his stuff up.
I'm sorry, bro.
Okay.
I'm getting reports that he was a classic COD lobby player.
Bro, no, if you scroll down, he was having a...
I think it's Christmas.
I don't think he's okay.
I think before then he was happy.
If you scroll down, before then.
Let me see this.
Before he was happy, and then he started Christmas queuing, that's when things got hard for him.
Dude, he gets a natural debuff.
Why is he practicing versus AI?
God was real.
Damn.
What a name.
Katamatic.
Is that the Mercy Katamatic?
I got this guy on my team the other day.
Katamatic.
He's going to be so annoying.
Okay.
Do we ban Thor?
Nah.
Why would we ban Thor?
Are we really about to waste a ban on Thor?
I'm banning Hawkeye.
Can you play anything else?
I'll ban Thor.
Alright.
We'll do Thor Hawkeye then.
Okay.
Cause I'd rather...
Unless they'll do Hawkeye.
Do you think they'll do Hawkeye?
Nah.
I think they'll do Hawkeye.
You're really going to bet that?
I'm a gambling man.
Okay.
I'm banning Bruce for you.
We are not banning Psylocke.
I'm never listening to you again.
This is my first game with Hawkeye not banned.
Oh wait, we have one tank.
Is this even a good Hawkeye map?
I don't know.
This is...
I mean any map is a good Hawkeye map.
If you believe hard enough.
Definitely not.
If you're good enough, any map is a Hawkeye map.
IMO.
It's gotta be a really good Hawkeye player.
That's really it.
Maybe I'm just an asshole character.
I'm...
I'm not saying...
I'm not...
I'm just saying every map is a very good Hawkeye map.
Am I the only...
I'm the only healer guys.
Wait, what?
I'm the only healer.
And our other tank is Captain America without a Thor.
Guys...
Guys, can we have one more healer?
One more healer.
Pretty please?
I still can't get over the fact that the guy was like, you're the only good healer player.
That shit was so fucking funny.
I'm going healer instead of Magneto.
That was the little tank cap though.
I'm putting it on the Captain America because I feel sick.
Panther!
Watch out!
There's a Panther and Iron Fist and there's a...
Bro, that...
I just watched you guys get murdered right before my eyes.
That shit was scary.
Yes.
Yeah.
I'm scared.
I don't think this is the game.
This Panther and Iron Fist are so poorly made.
I was jumping but I think I was literally jumping into one spot.
There's a pillar.
Nice.
He's so low.
Wait, who woke him up?
Who was it?
Seriously?
Guys, I'm never listening.
I'm never letting Mac gamble.
I'm never letting that happen again.
That Gru is one!
That Gru is literally one!
Okay, thank god.
I was going to fucking punch somebody.
Alright.
I will actually find one of you guys and beat you.
He's over there.
Oh my god!
I saw that Captain America actually run past him.
Oh, fine.
We beat you with the friendlier team.
What the fuck?
That came out of nowhere.
Did you start talking shit to her anymore?
Yeah.
We slammed you last game.
You had that friend.
We slammed you.
Like, what the fuck?
That's so real.
You had a streamer on your team and we fucking beat you up.
I'm going to ult first, okay?
I'm just spinning.
I got slept.
That's fine.
Wait, I slept you?
How the fuck did you ult?
I'm frozen.
We're fine.
I had damage for one second, but we're okay.
There's a guy right above.
There's nearly a Panther.
I can't save all of you.
I'm alive.
They never miss and I'm scared.
Oh no.
Yeah, we have no supports though.
Just peek our Mantis if you can.
You say you're crazy.
I'm coming over.
I'm spinning.
Bro, get that guy.
I still can't believe he was like, Hey bro, we fucking owned you.
And you had that frag.
That was such a whop.
This guy just dies.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
I'm going in their spawn!
I'm on HP!
Help!
I'm helping!
I basically let them so far away.
Help Hawkeye!
I dragged the Iron Fist away from us.
I did it guys.
Yeah, you were just fucking booking it.
I saved us.
I sacrificed myself just for all of you.
Because I was fucking terrifying.
Bro, that was actually...
Guys, that was so fucking terrifying.
That was so fucking terrifying, chat.
I did not deserve that.
Oh my god.
Bro, you guys are fucking...
You guys are spin botting for me.
Gotta lay off on the Adderall, please.
I have 3M.
Oh shit.
That's fine, we better win this then.
If we don't win this, I'll be so very sad.
I want that Black Panther dead.
I'm gonna go save our Captain America and I'm coming back.
Solid one on the left.
Oh my god.
Please, Magneto.
Please, I'm gonna beat him up.
Alright, we better win this with the double support ult that we just did.
I can freeze anyone on the left side.
Panther.
Nevermind, it's Panther.
I killed him.
Nice.
We gotta just focus.
Oh, nevermind.
This might be where I die?
Yeah.
We can still win this.
You're up one.
Yes, you can still win this.
This is Starlord.
You know what, you're right.
We took the gamble.
We had the better Hawkeye.
Yup, exactly.
Bye guys.
Even when I lose, I win.
We took the Hawkeye.
We took the Hawkeye dip.
Should we BM and match chat?
No.
Karma will get us if we do that.
Do you guys want to ban Hawkeye now?
No, I 100% Yes, fucking crazy.
We never have a chance.
It's lucky we're good.
I think we're just absolutely destroying them.
Oh my god.
Chat, I'm not willing to take the gamble of whichever team has the better Hawkeye.
It's actually so fucking frustrating.
If a team has the worst Hawkeye, it's so frustrating to play as when you have the worst Hawkeye because you can't do anything about it.
You literally can't do anything about it.
You have to watch your Hawkeye get fucking destroyed.
And lose.
It's not worth it.
Yeah, you might get the better Hawkeye, but 99% of the time, you do not.
It's just not fun.
It's not fun at all when you get absolutely destroyed by a better Hawkeye.
It's fine.
Play slow.
You don't have Mantis yet.
Alright.
They have a Venom.
Alright, I'm back.
I don't know where he's trying to land on, but he's there.
I'm not sure, but that dude was swinging.
Yeah, he swung somewhere.
He fucking swung!
I don't like how we're giving them so much free space.
It's actually crazy.
Venom!
19 inches of Venom, cut!
Oh god!
Hey, can you...
Please!
I was healing you as much as I could.
Yeah, I know.
It's just not great.
Alright.
Alright,
I'm coming back.
19 inches of Venom back.
Venom!
Oh, you're all dead.
Oh.
I hear...
Yeah.
Yeah, I heard him.
Oh my god!
I killed one Flanker first!
Oh my god.
Watch out.
Nuked by Venom.
Yeah, this...
This comp might not be ideal for two Flankers.
Yeah, they have double tanks.
Venom's one.
Venom has no... Oh my god!
The Black Panther gets shielded!
And my Ashley...
Alright, I'm coming back.
We're manned in solo, so don't take too much damage.
Alright, I'll spin.
Walk above that.
I got the Luna ult.
I'm gonna break his ult.
I broke it.
Nice.
They used Luna ult.
Guys, the Venom is...
I'm looking for it.
Oh my god.
Oh, I should have ulted that.
That was pretty huge.
I didn't think, like...
I should not have done that.
I thought we were gonna lose that fight.
Nah, that's fine.
I'm close to Mantis ult.
Alright.
I get those.
Oh my god, Hawkeye, please.
I just need you to diff everybody.
You're, like, literally our carry.
Oh my god, he has no more shields.
Oh, there's the...
Oh my god, okay.
I'm fucking leaving now.
No, not the building collapse behind me.
I hate that mechanic.
Oh my god.
Good luck, everybody.
Good luck.
He is not low.
Someone shot him while he was shielding.
It could have been me.
I fucking just shoot when things are getting bad.
No, I think we do need a second tank.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
I'm going in as a support and then I run back.
Nice.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna.
Please.
Oh my god.
I'm going back on the point.
Nice.
Please.
Oh my god.
Venoms, I just won.
Oh no.
It was so low.
Yeah.
I have champs in January.
Free agent team.
Hell yeah.
Hell yeah, no money, let's go.
I don't think that's a hell yeah type of thing.
I don't think he knows what that means.
Ow.
I'm stuck on the payload.
I'm fine.
I'm not fine.
I'm standing behind so I can't...
No, I got froze.
I have to leave here now.
Luna can die.
I slept.
It's just a Captain America.
If you can peek me, I...
I'm cooked.
I'm out of boosters.
Alright, we won.
We won or you're going to die.
I don't think anyone wants to swap except...
I'll go Penny.
Fuck it.
Alright, we're going to go Penny.
I'll put my orb on.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I can play around on mines.
And he'll blow up.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
W.
Oh my god, this is a pick.
This is...
Magnio.
That's right, they can't do shit now.
Oh my god, it's just win.
Venom?
Oh my god, guys.
This is it.
Yeah, W swap.
This is two fights.
Where's your mines?
I'm going to stand next to them.
Yeah.
Panther?
Pyro.
I got a squid on you.
What is that, Captain America?
I'm keeping you alive.
Because you have the mines.
He's hitting my mines.
Groot.
Groot's eating mines.
I'm going to ult here.
Yo, they're low.
You meant his ult first.
Oh, fuck.
That's why, yeah.
I didn't have it.
They used Luna.
Oh, their Penny's low.
Okay, that's good.
I have...
I can ult here if you all live.
What the hell?
Can you walk up?
Can you keep me up?
Oh my god.
I have to use this or I'll die.
He's one.
We can make this last fight.
Oh, damn.
He ulted me the moment I got up.
Oh, that's crazy.
I have to heal our Hawkeye.
Hawkeye, please.
You're stressing me out.
I'm on it.
I'm on it, but I die.
I die for it, though.
They had Mantis ult, too.
Oh my god.
I fucking...
Now I wanna...
Other Luna, how much heals you have?
The fuck is he comparing dick sizes?
That's what I say!
Dude, there's so many dick measures in this game.
How much heals I have?
Just wait until the end of the game.
You had two tanks.
I had one for like 80% of that game.
Like...
No fucking wonder you have more heals than me.
You have a venom that feeds out of his fucking mind.
And you just put an orb on him.
Yeah, how many heals do you have?
I have 22k.
Wait, Ruben.
Oh, dude.
14k?
Okay, I'm healing.
Okay, we gotta break the penny traps then.
Unless... Wait, actually, they're playing...
There's no way they play Penny on attack for this point, right?
That's fucking stupid, but it can work for them.
Are they playing Penny or not?
Yeah, they are.
They're playing Penny and Groot.
Okay, my frames are a lot better this round, so we win.
Nice.
I can't...
We can't heal Captain America here.
Nice.
I'm gonna go for a stun on Cloaker.
Close stun.
Aw, thank you.
One last fight, one last fight.
We got...
Oh, Captain America, you're fucking crazy!
Just like America.
Okay, we're fine.
I've got the mines, like, fucking wrapping the corner.
Kill Groot, kill Groot, kill Groot.
Groot's stunned, Groot's stunned.
Wait, I'm gonna die.
No, you're not.
Penny won.
Penny won, Penny won, Penny won.
I'm ulting.
Penny's still...
I'm trying to not give them any more scores.
Okay, I'm backing up.
I can't reload.
I have ult.
I got stun.
I have to...
We Luna and then we...
And then Mantis later.
Luna, Luna, Luna, Luna dead.
Groot, focus Groot, focus Groot.
Focus Groot, focus Groot, I'm on heals.
I'm on my...
Penny next.
Actually, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak stun.
Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, and then Penny.
Get her out, get her out.
Never miss.
Nice.
We're so...
We're so good at this game.
Guys, I feel like I've never tried this hard before.
I'm nearly calming.
Look at their supports versus us.
What bums.
Calling focus.
Oh my god.
We're just so talented.
Merry Christmas, it's 5am.
It's 5am.
Don't gotta tell me twice.
Merry Christmas.
I really don't know how much this really matters now.
Yay.
Hey, 50% accuracy, I'll take it.
I'm like, starting to get better at headshots.
Because like, I got trained to do body shots for Apex, so like I'm not used to at all doing like, headshots.
You have to completely readjust.
Yeah.
So imagine like, you were probably good at headshotting before if you played Overwatch.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I readjusted my aim to like, body, like just having it center body for Apex.
And now I have to readjust to headshots again, which is freaking hard.
The annoying thing about this game is I do it a lot of times I'll aim at the head and it'll be a body shot.
It's the offset.
The crosshair offset.
And also mouse access.
I'm getting fucking ran at by a Panther.
You're fine.
He's on me again.
I'm dead.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
Fundy.
You're scaring me, Fundy.
I'm just gonna stare at this Panther.
Can you peek me so I can damage you?
Yep, there we go.
I'm just staring at the Panther.
I just wanna Captain America fucking die.
Oh my god!
Magneto, please.
He's just frontlining everything.
Oh my god.
I can...
We can force this if we have to.
I'm forcing this.
Alright.
I got you.
Black Panther behind.
Hawkeye one.
No way you headshot me while I'm spinning.
We got Penny.
There's no mines.
We're fucking free!
We're free!
Oh shit!
Okay, thank you.
I'm ulting as soon as I get it.
We need to get rid of Penny.
I'm very free.
I have no more mines.
Too easy.
No Penny, let's go!
USA!
That's what they get for not banning Hawkeye.
That guy has 41k.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, you're back!
I need one more win.
And then I'll be...
I'll be up, I think.
I'll be up again.
I think we get eternity tonight.
Okay.
Love it when we don't ban Hawkeye and I'm the one with a shitty Hawkeye player.
Now they know how I feel.
Poor guy did what he could.
He had 19 deaths.
That's crazy.
Wait, BP?
BP?
Black Panther.
Oh, Black Panther.
Oh my god, you guys all our DPS were farming.
How the fuck did we struggle that much with that amount of kills?
Oh, it's like the same team.
They got Fungie now.
Wait, was Fungie on our team or last game?
No, we played with him.
Oh, Deathcook.
I'll be Mantis then.
See, I don't have an ego.
I'm willing to give this one trick to one trick.
I'm sorry, man.
He had 12k damage.
We are not banning Black Panther, bro.
We're banning...
No, we are not banning Black Panther!
Oh, thank god.
Okay, do we get Hella?
I don't know if they're gonna do Hella.
You're gonna be the one guy that got Hulk.
You're gonna be that 20%.
Do you believe in yourself enough?
I just don't fuck with Hulk players.
No more.
Jarvis got Hella.
Thank god.
No.
Hawkeye bullshit.
That's crazy.
Oh, we got Thor one trick.
Then we'll get Howard.
Honestly, I won't be surprised if Howard the Duck is in Marvel.
I looked at NetEase games when the stuff they did...
This is not their first Marvel games.
This is literally their third Marvel game.
I'm glad they...
The other two Marvel games they made, the 3D models they used was like not the...
It was more realistic Marvel realistic models.
So I'm really happy they went with a more cartoony comic book style for this one because it definitely works a lot more.
It's such an improvement from their other Marvel games.
Yeah, the stylized shit is so much better.
Alright guys, get ready for me being muted unmuted.
Get ready for the best Captain America gameplay you've ever seen in your life.
Oh, nice.
That's gone.
Woah!
Captain America won!
I'm gonna cap.
Holy shit, I'm him!
I capped.
Cap point, hold corner.
Alright.
Mac, I can't see you for damage boost.
It's okay, I'm just being a bastard.
Here, I got you.
I leave now.
I'm playing solo.
Oh, that's fine.
I don't need to live anyway.
I broke a nest.
Nice.
I damage boosted you.
You're by yourself, Ruben, just so you know.
Nah, yeah, I'm chillin'.
I'm Captain America.
I'm chillin'.
Alright.
I'm fuckin' runnin' around.
What are they gonna do to me?
Kill me?
They kill you?
They're all going home.
Oh.
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, I'm just fuckin' I'm throwing leaves around and hoping things will be okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Luna low.
I'm gonna ult this.
I think it's worth, yeah.
Yay.
Alright.
I'm fuckin' going back.
Oh, I might be dead though.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh my god, you're so healthy.
I'm gonna get rid of this fire nest.
I'm trying to get rid of this fire nest right now.
I got rid of it.
I'm gonna ult here.
Where are you?
I got you.
Alright, this is where I die.
Assemble!
Oh my god.
Where was my assemble?
Assemble!
Where was my assemble, Ruben?
Yeah!
I lived, I did my job.
I hope you die next game.
Beautiful.
No, don't let me die!
No, please.
Wait, Mac has zero deaths.
He's better.
He's actually doing stuff.
Bro, my chat was like, it's cause Mantis isn't an Avenger.
That's so fucked.
Why did Starlord didn't die?
I'm just running around.
This is the funniest thing ever.
This hero is so silly.
We always get insta-queues.
Starlord Ping would play with 200 ping!
Crazy!
Damn, we should've avoid that guy.
Damn.
Poor guy is playing for both teams.
EU player thinks NA trash so he switch and he's Who the fuck is he stream sniping?
Me?
I predicted him being us.
Who the fuck is he stream sniping?
Hold up.
I have a plan.
That was not my plan.
What's your plan?
You're fine.
Oh my god.
How did you die?
I'm gonna die here.
I just let myself die.
I was like, who do I want to get killed by?
The Starlord?
Or the Psylocke?
Just group up here.
Alright.
It's fine.
He's so healthy.
He's half.
Oh, he's got healed.
Can't believe you get healed.
Oh, Ruben, you're taking so much damage.
He's asleep.
I'm gonna ult this.
Here you go.
Oh my god.
Yeah, but we might have to use ours after this too.
I feel like.
Oh my god.
Please get a nice.
They have Psylocke and
Psylocke and and Penny on.
And Starlord.
I'm gonna assemble all over the place.
I'm gonna ult behind them.
I'm giving it to everyone.
Are we okay?
Alright, that's cool.
I just assembled so hard.
I killed two, but I killed myself.
That's fine, that's fine.
We killed three in the back.
We gotta kill the Penny.
Oh my.
Penny's one.
Guys, are you guys okay?
Please, I killed the freaking Cloak.
Because I'm like thinking, who else could he be stream sniping?
It's only us three that are streaming.
Four DPS.
Four DPS?
Oh my god, he's right.
I got you.
That Starlord's low, by the way.
He's in the air.
Yeah, he's so low.
Might be healed now, though.
Don't overextend, he said.
Oh shit.
We're fine.
I gave damage boost back.
He tried to hook me.
Guys, I can't do any headshots if they don't push up.
Let me know when they walk in and I'll drop.
Where are you?
Oh, they did everything.
They did everything.
It's everything.
Do we live?
Ensemble!
Oh my god.
That's actually everything.
What the fuck?
Wow.
I didn't even know what to look at.
I was so confused.
Which one was my loot hold?
Dude, Captain America is so fun.
Oh my god.
Holy press Q.
OCE player?
Nissan?
Holy shit, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Yeah, GM2!
Top .09%.
Who was their player?
That was like...
You avoided them?
I mean, all their DPS lineup their stat numbers are not that great.
I feel like...
Their entire stat line...
That guy was horrible.
He kept trying to 1v1 me.
He's just getting slammed.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We did it.
I got to feel like...
In GM2 again.
To see what it's like.
GM1 next.
Whoa, okay.
I hope so.
I want to end top 500 this season.
You will.
Mac, what?
Okay, I know Ruben will gas me up no matter what.
But Mac, do you?
But Mac, I know you'd tell the truth.
Do you think I have what it takes to be Eternity?
Yeah, your support is actually good.
Oh, thank you.
Really?
I mean, to be fair, you're queuing with me so I'm dragging you down with me if you don't think I'm good enough.
Nah, yeah, it's fine.
You're good.
As long as you don't play tank, I think we're fine.
Yay!
What happened on tank?
I haven't seen it yet, but she said she's horrible at it.
No, I had less than an hour on tank.
Let's put her on Captain America next game.
See what happens.
Just a little experiment.
Yeah, we'll just 5v6 next game.
I'm still thinking back about that time.
The guy was like 27% accuracy.
Yeah, that's a female player.
I'm still thinking about that guy.
You're one of the good ones.
Just remember that.
He's like, yeah, you're one of the good ones.
I just can't.
I can't help but think about that chat.
One of the good ones.
What the fuck?
He's like so misogynist but yet not at the same time.
What?
How is he not?
I feel like I just changed his world view when I said I was female.
I'm a female player.
God damn.
Also, we got to GM2 and now we're sitting in a fucking Overwatch queue time.
What is this?
We are the remaining GM2 players playing on Christmas.
Did we all get GM2 back that game?
No, no.
Mac is ahead of us by a couple.
Yeah, because he's higher elo.
How is your bar so low compared to us?
What's wrong with your internet?
My bar?
Yeah, your like yellow bar for me.
What servers are we on?
All of them?
I still haven't put East back on.
The Oregon server is fucked because I'm getting like 70 ping to it when normally it would be 40.
Yeah, yeah, the servers are horrible.
They got to fix something.
I know Reg a shitload if I play projectile characters and my ping is way higher than it should be.
My ping goes from anywhere from like 80 to like 140 sometimes.
That's weird.
Yeah, in other games I get like 20 to 40 ping in other games.
And if I'm on Texas server I got 8.
Which is just, I'm doing the worm when I play on Texas.
So fucked up.
Dude.
We're climbing guys.
Can you bring us some?
Guys, I can't believe we're climbing.
I don't know how that feels like.
I don't know what that feels like anymore.
It's such a new experience chat.
That's my fucking news.
We started on GM2.
No, please I can't.
We have to end on GM2.
Guys.
If any, GM1 is a bonus, but if anything it took me 6 hours to get back here.
It took me 6 hours to get back here chat.
Honestly like, I don't know what is up with, I think like competitive wise, but like when I stream competitive games, I don't get tired.
I can stream it for a very long time.
Now I know how designful felt when he went 24 hours.
If I have enough players to play with, I can actually just keep going.
I can legitimately just keep going until I get what I want.
But like for any other game, I get tired after a while.
Like when Trevor was saying how when you YouTube VTubers, you get tired after 4-5 hours and you call it a day.
I'm like, true, but for rival rivals, I can keep going.
I can just play I can play for as long as I want.
I know, I shouldn't.
I shouldn't, it's not healthy.
I can't help it.
Also, CaptainGira, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
It's Christmas.
Yeah, that's why we're gonna have a Christmas karaoke later today.
I was just setting up stuff for it too.
I don't know what to do.
Also, for those who are new here, for those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm doing my Marvel Rivals grind on Twitch because I did a 3-day stream on Marvel Rivals when it first launched where I got to top 500 within 3 days.
And now I'll just do the rest of the grind here on Twitch because I don't know when I'll be able to get to top 500, like end on top 500.
I feel like I'm gonna be playing this for a fucking ever.
Oh, what'd he get?
A chocolate chip what?
Yes, please check me out on YouTube and follow me on Twitter if you guys like wanna check me out more.
I usually tweet out when I'm streaming on Twitch and it's gonna be GorillaStreams most likely.
So like, like impromptu streams with no schedule and stuff for Twitch streams.
And also, buy my merch.
You know, I have an Android.
I have an Android pre-order.
For those who are like, whoa!
She might be a pretty big deal.
Wait a minute.
She seems, she actually seems pretty important if she has an Android deal.
Alright, where the fuck is my thing?
Is it this one?
Yeah, look guys.
For those who are new here, who don't know about my Nendroid.
Yes, this person might not look like me but this was me.
They're like, wait a minute.
That does look like you right now.
This was me.
Do we have enough sales on this retro jokey version?
Who's that?
Who the fuck is that?
You can tell who are new here who's just watching Marvel Rivals.
But this was me, but now it's not me.
I mean, it's still me.
It's still me.
But like, I look like this now.
But we have more, we have a lot of sales on retro dokey.
We might get current dokey.
Yeah, so yeah, that's me.
I'll put it here while we're waiting queue.
Guys, now.
Oh, yeah!
I was gonna say, now I know why I got a 15 minute queue earlier.
But it's okay, we're in.
This is a fucking...
This is a hard game.
This is gonna be a hard game.
Yeah, but we have Kelvin.
We have Kelvin.
We have one above all.
And they have Jesus.
Wait, they have Groot God and LCQ Jesus.
Maybe his name is Groot God to get us to ban Groot.
Oh, that's true.
I'm gonna ban Groot.
Wait, guys, can somebody look up Groot God 69's profile and tell me?
Yeah, someone check really quick.
Come on, go, go, go.
Someone who has Marvel Rivals up right now.
Look up Groot God 69 and look at their statistic.
Are they a Groot one trick and now ban Groot.
Our guy is taking half an hour to load and I'm scared.
Oh, it's not me.
At least it's not me.
At least it's not you DC.
Some people are like I'm launching it right now.
I'm...
Alright.
Guys, pull up the info faster.
Guys, it determines whether or not we ban Groot.
It's the choice.
The most important decisions of our lives right now.
Elicit saw LQC Jesus and was terrified shameless.
I Googled Groot 69 and I don't feel so good.
Guys, no.
You missed out the God part.
Guys, this is not, technically this isn't stream sniping.
It's called gathering intel.
We're nearly just scouting up their stats.
Exactly.
Completely different.
I mean, pro teams do it.
They scout out people, what they play and everything.
Yeah, they try getting other people scrim vods and checking them out.
Someone's like, GrootGod69 has 81 wins out of 114.
Holy fuck.
Is it on Groot though?
Is he on Groot though?
That's the important part.
We don't need to know their stats, guys.
We don't need to know that he has an 80% win rate, guys.
That's unnecessary information.
We need to know.
Bro, we waited a half an hour for that game.
This is an entirely different match.
This is a completely different...
How the fuck?
Everyone from the last game just got tossed into limbo.
No.
The fucking GrootGod Intel there was no reason.
It was pointless.
Our guy dodged because he was so scared of the Groot.
He was scared of GrootGod69.
Alright, who are we banning?
Hawk?
Yeah, Hawkeye.
And then Bruce Laughter.
I love how I still don't know what he plays.
My chat has only told me that it's an 80% win rate.
Oh, he was a strange player?
Oh, so he was fucking with us.
That's a genius.
I can't believe your chat.
Bro, you play everything.
You don't even main Starlord.
You literally play everything.
Should I toss a 5% vote in for Hella?
Wait, are we not banning Bruce?
I guess not.
That's 5.
Oh, they really are target banning you.
Can we...
got to?
You don't even...
You literally started playing Starlord today.
Ain't no way y'all play only DPS.
I play support.
Do I ego and stay on DPS and hope that Gati 2k support or celebrating Christmas?
No, no, no, no.
I got it.
Iron Fist, baby.
Okay.
Oh, but your fucking Psylocke is insane, though.
Yeah, I know.
With your Psylocke, when your Psylocke's open, I'll support.
Okay, bet.
Thank you.
I'll make you proud.
I'm playing Jeff, though.
Okay, Mack, do you want Luna?
Mack, do you want Luna?
After we should talk to all those Jeff players, you cannot.
You've lost your privilege as a Jeff.
We can't threaten to turn them into fucking soup.
I saw how you yelled at that Jeff player.
He deserved it, though.
I'm one of the good ones.
Oh my god, you don't even like Jeff.
You can't be one of the good ones if you don't even.
Black Panther's above you guys.
Guys, guys.
I'm soulbinding us.
Thank you.
We lost Bob, though.
Bob.
Hey, Bob.
We lost.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
We can catch this.
Oh my god.
I got the hella.
We gotta get Groot.
Oh, no.
I got Thor.
We gotta get Groot.
He's literally so little.
I gave you...
Oh my god, Groot.
Never mind.
You didn't have it.
Groot stood in front of me like three times.
I might need a little snap.
Villager?
Soulbinding.
Oh, I fucked up.
They're all really low, though.
I'm on the point.
Because there's a Black Panther.
Oh, no.
He was just chilling above you.
I'm gonna try...
Call out when they use emo, okay?
Oh, Panther.
You might need it.
Did they use emo yet?
I don't have soulbinding.
They used Luna.
Oh, you might need to rez us.
I'm gonna go try to run away.
You gotta hide.
We're dying on point.
We're losing point, though.
So I don't know if you should rez now.
No, I'm not.
Oh my god.
Yo, I need a heal please.
You're so healthy.
I was just too deep.
I'm fucking...
I'm gonna give it a buck.
I could've healed you, but I'm not in my heal mindset right now.
No, you're good.
That was on me.
No, I definitely could've pressed E.
You were like right in front of me.
It was 100% my fault.
You don't understand.
As Adam, it's very easy.
I died.
Okay.
Alright, I'm just gonna...
heal our Kingston.
I'll give you orb and see if you do anything.
I froze Penny.
Yeah, Penny can die.
She did not die.
I tried to heal him.
I have no heals.
I sold out for him.
Oh my god, I'm fucking... I'm scared now.
I broke it.
I got heal.
Oh, we should fight this.
We need to fight this.
Panther one.
I'm ulting on point.
They have Luna ult.
They have double Luna ult now.
I'm going to hide.
Alright, Mercy.
Go hide, Mercy.
Oh my god.
We... you might need to put up now.
We're all dying.
And if you can...
Soap on us.
Soap on us again.
There's mines just everywhere.
Oh, they're Black Panther squad.
I was not able to do anything there.
Alright, maybe you...
I'll get healed eventually.
Yeah, I know.
I think it's a swap angle.
Our tank was taking a lot of damage.
Alright.
Don't worry, now we have double the healing.
You know, I missed the first Q that we could've got.
I feel like that would've been a lot better.
I think that game would've been a lot...
There was just...
There was like a penny...
Spider nest, and there were a bunch of immortality fields.
I just don't think the Holy Bob might be a good...
I don't think he's a good group player.
Wait.
Oh, I just pressed that.
I did see him do a little bit of silliness every now and then.
Why is it always Hela that bitch and moans?
Look, he gets Hela banned like 90% of the time.
The fact that the one game he gets to play Hela and he fucking loses, I fucking bitch and moan too.
Alright.
Nice.
I am Brute.
Hello, Top Riot.
Oh my god, this Hela still...
Oh, he's fine.
Our Hela killed him.
You're still healing.
I was just getting...
Fucking...
Forged by Hela.
Oh, I'm fucking...
Skating.
I'm skating over.
I have cloak off for this fight.
Nice.
I have ult too.
Hela, top left.
Heal first.
Can you heal our Hela?
Okay, nice.
Hela, top left.
Yeah, I'm pressuring her.
I got our Hela.
There's a guy to our right side.
I have no idea who he is.
Oh my god, Groot, please.
I can't see...
Hela, top right.
I ulted before I died.
I ulted the Groot.
Oh my god.
He's alive.
There's still a Hela on the right high ground, I think.
Oh, let's all press Q.
Ah, shit.
No, I don't think... That's 6 ults.
That's 6 ults.
They literally use every ult except for Pantheon.
Can he ult, maybe?
Alright, I'm coming back.
Alright, I'm putting on our Groot.
Jesus.
I'm healing our Captain America, so...
Yeah, I got them for now.
Alright, Hela.
That's a huge pick.
I'm trying to speed you guys up.
The Panthers won.
This is so low.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
If you beat this up, we...
We're locked in.
We're locked in the wall.
That's actually crazy.
No.
What do you want us to do?
There's 200 million people!
Oh, I'm dead.
I should've shifted.
I'm ulting this.
You just need to kill Penny.
That's a good gap.
Just kill Penny, please.
Oh, he's gonna live.
Back up, back up, back up, please!
Captain America!
I'm so fucking scared.
I have ult for this fight.
They used Groot ult on us, right?
No.
They did, okay.
I'm pretty sure they didn't.
Unless our Groot did.
I'm just forming a little triangle on point.
I might be dead, though.
Just die on point.
Die on point.
Don't let them cap it.
It's fine as long as we don't stagger.
Nice, good pick.
We can go in with a pick.
We should start going now.
Yeah, there's Panthers coming back.
No, no!
Captain America, don't worry!
You have the orb!
I'm shredding the Groot.
I hear someone behind me.
Oh no!
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm reloading.
Oh no, we lost.
You can break the wall!
I'm breaking the wall!
I'm trying so hard!
We got locked out.
We actually got locked out of the wall.
That's actually so unfortunate.
That's what I mean, these walls are so strong!
There's nothing we can do!
That's so annoying.
I wanna burn the fucking trees down!
Supports can't break the wall!
I was actually just shooting that thing.
I saw that, dude!
Supports can't...
Supports can't do anything against the wall!
Let's see, this is why deforestation is okay.
If I can cut it, if I can...
You saw me just shooting the fucking walls the entire time!
I saw you, I was watching you.
I just danced and tried to watch it as I danced.
That was so sad.
Did we avoid...
Oh, I think we have all DPS players again.
The Gattic guy is the... yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Guys, I'm okay with being GM3 again.
No, no, no, we're getting it back.
Alright, Hawkeye?
Yeah.
Alright, we gotta start avoiding other DPS players too.
Okay, looks like we're not banning Hella because our guy really wants to play Hella.
But isn't that the...
Isn't that Hella from our last...
No, that's... he's the fucking god Hawkeye!
Right?
That's him!
Oh yeah, it was.
Okay, I'm not banning Hella, bro.
If he was a fucking god on Hella, like Hawkeye that time...
I'm banning Bruce.
We'll see who gets it.
I'm not 100%, but I'm pretty sure that's our Hella from last game.
Chat, is that our Hella from last game?
My Starlord's gone again!
You motherfuckers!
Damn.
Oh, it was?
No, our Hella from last game was Jervis.
Because he kept complaining.
Oh yeah, it was Jerwin.
Yeah, he was like, please, please, please, please!
Yeah, it's Jerwin, yeah.
Please, please, please, please.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Okay, we don't want him.
Yeah, because Gatik only plays Captain America, so I don't feel...
Oh, okay.
I don't feel confident in her.
Not confident about that.
It's very situational.
He played Cap last game, too.
Yeah.
He plays... he's a...
He's an Iron Fist Cap player.
What an interesting hero pool.
I mean, Captain America is like Iron Fist.
You both beat the shit out of people.
He's like Tank Iron Fist.
Yeah.
Oh, Jerwin is on the enemy team.
They're trying to break this wall up here.
On me?
They're probably done.
My aunt did the stupid shit, goddammit.
What the fuck?
We're trying to help you guys, but...
Whoa!
Okay, I'm fucking okay, I guess.
I'm dead.
You're not, though.
Whoa.
This is dangerous.
We're gonna get hit by people in the back.
Those who died early.
That's what I'm worried about.
Are they still on that high ground?
I can't...
Oh, yeah.
We're so...
fucking split up there.
This is so awkward to heal.
I just got fucking one-tapped.
I'm gonna go low-key here after my ult.
Because they have Black Panther.
And I can't fuck with that.
I'm gonna be fine, yo.
Come on.
Show me your fucking...
Oh my god, I...
I healed you as much as I could.
I'm pocketing our fucking...
uh, health.
Can't there's one other Venom diving me?
I'm just getting...
Yeah, I can't...
I'm solo-healing.
What?
Uh-oh.
No!
I'm ulting this.
We have to push up.
And I really don't want to play fucking...
No way!
There's nothing I can do!
I mean, there's Venom.
I just have to switch.
There's Venom just hard-focusing me.
Oh my god.
We can still have... I'm gonna low-key too.
Because of the Black Panther.
And we have Hella...
We have Hella for this anyway.
Alright.
Surely this guy dies.
He's blind.
I'm blocking Hella.
No!
I can't.
I can't go through.
I need somebody to open this door.
I got it.
I just got...
fucking killed while in a Luna ult.
Hella no burden!
I'm on the point, but...
Oh my god, I'm fucking... I'm fucking swapping everywhere.
I'm fucking switching.
I'm healing.
Ow.
I've just spawn-died six times in a row.
I'm so mad.
This is a little awkward here.
Don't worry, Hella.
My low-key clone will tank everything for you.
My low-key clone will continue to tank things for you.
Yes!
Oh.
There we go.
Venom is low.
Venom is one.
We gotta push up.
I have...
There's a Panther above us.
I know.
No,
I needed to...
I'm good.
Damn.
Where the fuck is our Hella?
I need to clone her!
No!
Did she die?
Did our Hella die?
Oh, she did.
I was trying to clone her.
Oh my god.
You can walk around this.
Okay, fine.
I'll do that.
Just walk through it.
I walked through.
Oh, shit.
Are you serious?!
I'm through!
Jesus Christ.
I actually threw that.
Even through your ult?!
Oh my god, I'm so sad.
I'm actually so sad.
I actually threw that.
I can't believe I'm not tall enough for it.
Oh my god.
We gotta get points.
I like...
Ulted as Hella and then I didn't realize I don't go taller than the rock so the rock blocked me the entire time.
I...
I thought people would avoid the cat.
I don't think he's the problem.
He just doesn't...
He's literally filling for us.
The gothic guy is literally filling.
Because he's a DPS player.
I thought I'd be taller than the fucking rock.
I don't... I don't know.
I never had to do that.
You know the rock that's on the side?
I thought when you're on the rock and you ult as Hella that you go above it.
But you don't.
I really... gothic shit.
I want gothic to play.
Because he's an Iron Fist player.
I wonder if he's good at Iron Fist or not.
I don't know.
I feel like we need to avoid these DPS players.
I need more avoids.
I have...
I think Reuben has avoids, right?
You have avoids?
I have one.
I thought we were going to be TPing.
Please.
There's a panther.
Panther's low.
Panther's literally low.
Panther's one.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Strange can die on the left, I think.
Okay.
I'm going on the flank here.
Oh my god.
He's so low over there.
I killed their Loki.
Nice.
Strange is low.
I have a panther on me.
All right.
Stand near this if you need...
Panther.
Panther and Strange.
Strange is low.
Oh my god.
He was so low.
I'm going to ult here in a sec.
Good ult.
They all walked out of it.
Never mind.
My ult sucks.
It's okay.
I killed Luna.
Wait.
I'm back.
Hello.
I can't do anything.
Damn.
No!
You can get another kill, I believe!
Oh my god.
No.
Oh.
I knew it.
I knew you could get another kill, but I might be dead now.
Okay.
I'm getting...
Oh, that's huge.
That's huge.
That's terrible for us.
I don't think it's worth...
I don't know if I should contest.
I killed Penny.
Okay.
I'll copy you.
I got one.
Oh my god.
Guess I don't copy you.
She doesn't even need LOS for that.
So dumb.
I got frozen in that?
Okay.
Yulted?
Oh no.
What happened?
Yeah, their Loki ulted and copied me.
That's okay, guys.
GM2 lobbies are hard.
No, no, no.
We win these.
It's okay.
What?
Okay.
I just got jumped.
Maybe we should just dodge this Q.
We're literally playing the same people over and over again.
Is it possible to dodge a Q at this rank?
No, you can't.
You just look at the list.
And see if they're in game.
I'm actually tired of playing against these same people.
I just shoot my gun and hope for the best.
I just...
I just shoot my gun.
I just shoot my gun and hope for the best.
At least I can get that guy.
Oh, I just got one-tapped.
Oh, portal, portal, portal.
What?
No, that's the enemy portal.
Goodbye, Overwatch Neil.
Goodbye.
No.
Fuck.
I think I have one more before I do rank.
I think.
Before I do.
Depends on how...
Depends on how fucked the the matchmaking was.
Yeah!
Holy shit!
I'm hanged by the thread!
Wait, wait, wait.
I wanna dodge that.
I don't wanna play with these failures and against them.
Okay, two more wins and then I'm GM2 again.
Oh, you deranked?
Yeah, I deranked.
Fuck.
Why are they just in team?
They're not even queuing.
The team that we just had and against, they're not even queuing.
What's wrong with them?
Are they all dodging too?
I'm so sorry.
If you're saying things, I can't hear you.
I think they're dodging.
Okay, no.
One of them is queuing.
The others are queuing.
Alright, while we dodge this queue, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Alright, sounds good.
Guys, while Doki uses the bathroom, we should get five gifted subs and farm Valorant out of all the money they have left.
I fully agree.
Me, personally, I'm always down to make money off of Riot Games.
Yup.
Come on.
Get the five gifteds rolling in.
It'll be the funniest prank.
She'll come back and she'll be like, Whoa, where did all these five gifted come from?
And she'll never know.
What?
Oh, shit.
Ren!
Thank you for the five gifted subs!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
I'm starting to hit it though.
I'm starting to...
Oh no, I fucked up.
I accidentally moved my layout around.
Oh no.
Oh, there you go.
I fixed it.
Guys, what if I just run ads?
Guys, I'm gonna run a...
I'm gonna run...
I'm gonna run a two minute ad.
Just out of nowhere.
Hey guys, you know how to get out of ads?
Subscribe!
Yippee!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, wait.
Someone gifted five and you got five?
Oh my god, Mary, thank you for the ten gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
Sorry, Kat.
I hear you over your ads.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Thank you for the five gifted subs!
Thank you!
No ads here!
I don't really run ads before so there's no ads.
I'm just like, whoa, ads!
This is like the one few times I actually ran an ad.
I just figured, wait, how did I increase viewers by running an ad?
How does that happen?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it's Provy!
Guys, remember that guy?
Oh my god, he lives rent-free in my head.
He still lives rent-free in my head.
I fucking love when my voids pay off.
Oh god, no, not Medic!
What's wrong with him?
He's so bad.
I played with this guy yesterday, so look, he's so fucking bad.
He's a Punisher one trick and then he was like, dude, this guy's missing me with his turret and I'm taking damage and we're like, you know it's splash damage, right?
Like, you don't need to hit people.
And he's like, what?
No!
I'm scared.
He didn't know that his character had splash damage.
I'm banning Hawkeye.
Get Hawkeye out of there.
Get Hawkeye out.
I'm...
I'm worried.
I'm worried we're gonna let Misogynist win.
Guys, no.
No, it's not gonna happen.
You better have good accuracy.
I'm worried it's gonna happen.
You better have a better than 40% accuracy.
Don't want him to think he was wrong earlier.
Oh, we have three support players.
Well, one of you guys better go tank, I guess.
I'm making Medic go tank.
I don't think...
Unfortunate.
Allegedly.
We have the mental boom improving.
We have...
Yo, guys, hear me out.
Honestly, we have three supports.
Let's just fucking go goats.
Just go goats.
What's the worst that could happen?
It goes for this game, it's like two tanks and one DPS.
Guys, I don't think Medic wants to go.
He'll do it.
I don't mind.
I guess we just run.
He'll fold.
Oh, he's not folding.
He's not folding.
I don't think you understand.
We need a tank.
He says we need a tank and stays Iron Man?
No, no, that was Doctor.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna freak out.
I was actually gonna freak out.
Oh, they got...
Okay, now we extra gotta win this game.
They got the homies.
Well, the homies has an actual team comp.
Homies run RNG.
The fucking homie really wants to win.
Oh, hell no.
Yeah, like, we're keeping you alive, but like, it's definitely very difficult.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
By the way, I don't know...
You're literally in front of everybody, so...
The homies...
The homies get an actual comp, and the medic went fucking Widow.
That's actually crazy.
I think we...
Oh my God.
I mean, I can... I guess I can go tank.
Maybe if I flirt with the enemy team, they will let us win.
I don't...
Yeah, you know what?
You think my plan sucks?
I think your plan fucking sucks.
They just win.
That's okay.
You're not getting healed, by the way, Mac.
Woohoo!
We might have three healers, but one of them is a fucking raccoon.
That's a huge ult, but we can't do anything about it.
Ow.
That was actually a huge ult, but we just can't do anything about it.
You're being blocked by everything.
I froze... Oh my God, I got knocked everywhere.
Alright, it's time.
I'm pulling up the Magneto.
It's time.
Alright, important question.
Do I start flaming, even though it's Christmas?
Bro, you are not a Widow main.
I pointed it out to you yesterday.
You're a Punisher one trick.
Allegedly.
Who didn't know that his turret had AOE?
It's time.
I just don't even know how some people get to this point.
Oh!
Oh my God, he doesn't even know who you fucking are!
That's fucking crazy!
That's actually crazy!
Oh my God!
Ow.
Remember when we asked for more support players, and then we ended up getting... Oh my God.
It's okay.
Can we kill this one?
I'm okay with this game.
For some reason, I thought I was healer, so I tried to shoot our Raccoon.
This guy just burped in BC.
Oh my God.
That's...
What a gamer.
Oh my God.
Yo, FenixMelo dies!
We can forfeit.
Maybe if we forfeit...
No, no, no, no, no.
We lack the fucking...
Guys, we have four bits.
I have all of them.
Oh no!
Alright.
Alright, I don't know where the arm went.
Well, I don't know who you're telling that to, because it's definitely not me.
I'm fucking thinking.
We are not letting FenixMelo get out of here.
He's getting out of here.
I'm sorry.
No, FenixMelo dies.
I don't know what to tell you.
FenixMelo's gonna die right now.
Get fucked.
Wait, I got you.
I got you.
I held right click so good.
I'm ulting.
I don't have shield for you.
Guys, I'm kiting.
Oh my god.
I was trying to wait for the shield.
I'm blocking as much as I can.
Wait a second.
No, that would be stupid.
Okay, I was gonna say I'm blocking too,
but...
Oh, he's so low.
They're so low.
Wait.
Fuck, he's low too.
I'm fucking... I'm going for it.
Oh, he's so low.
Groot's one.
He's boxing himself in.
Nice.
I don't know if we should push up that much.
I don't think we should push up.
I don't have shield too, so...
Okay.
Alright.
They have eye, by the way.
At best, I can try and shield too.
I got a pick.
What's going on back there?
Alright.
I don't have a Star Lord ult.
I'm going.
No!
Oh my god, I saw that.
That was gonna be the best ult of all time too.
No, he dodged it.
Wait, he's so low.
Nice.
Keep shooting, keep fucking hitting.
Okay, I kind of went crazy.
Oh my god.
You went crazy there.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
I'm just...
I'm clicking buttons.
Chat, there's an F key, so they don't hear me sometimes.
That's okay.
Alright, this is fine.
Nice.
Nuh-uh.
I don't wanna...
He's aiming for me.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's gigantic.
Oh my god, I'm him.
Yes, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Alright, looks like we're about to have a couple.
Bro.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just pressing buttons.
You're being greedy, trying to farm my ult.
I have shield.
I'm gonna give it to you now, just in case.
Oh!
Let me know when your next shield's up, and I'm gonna ult.
12 seconds, 12 seconds.
Watch out.
Fuck you, Zed.
I have it, one.
Okay, I'm going.
I got you.
I'm trying to... got him.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Can we push this far, though?
We're talented.
Oh my god.
Time to switch things up.
You did a troll.
Like the whole first half of the game.
What the fuck?
Who fucking me?
No, no, no, I'm better.
Okay, I'm better, okay.
Alright.
I was gonna say.
I fucking worked so hard for this.
What did they say?
You win, Black Widow.
I don't even want to hear it.
Don't antagonize him, please!
No, I know.
He's just talking.
Talking some crazy shit.
Don't antagonize him, please!
I mean, I guess it'll be a good Christmas day with someone trying to, you know, cause some problems.
Bro, what's wrong with you?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What's Christmas about?
My brother, it's about God.
If you ain't celebrating God, you're not doing it right.
Worship him.
I'm turning into a fucking priest mid-game to try to keep this guy's sanity intact, bro.
Yo, I'm making a portal.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Worship God.
Yo, they have a Luna?
Yo, I'm gonna jump scare this Luna, okay?
What the fuck is this?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm dead.
You guys took the wrong portal.
I jumped in your portal and you guys took the wrong portal.
I jumped off.
We're resetting.
We're resetting this.
My portal's right here and the Luna's right there.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That is so easy to see.
Wait, you guys actually...
That's two.
That's two picks.
You're up one.
You're literally up one.
I'm going from main.
I didn't realize you were gonna live.
I fucking jumped off the point.
There you go.
I gave you a bubble to kill that one.
Fuck you.
Fuck that one guy.
Good bub.
I thought that you guys are all gonna die so I just jumped off.
I went through that portal and I was like, where am I?
And then I fell off the map.
How did you...
You were able to retake the portal.
I was gonna be like...
I just didn't even process where that portal dropped me.
I was still looking around, taking in the scenery.
I'm playing above him right now.
Yeah, I gave you a bubble just in case.
I'm just being a bastard.
There's a bunch of them.
I'm out of gas!
That's bad.
I need a bubble.
Okay.
Ow.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
I can't tell.
Runes in a corner.
He built a house.
He's dead.
He's dead though.
I got ripped to death.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I'm fucking...
I'm doing this.
Okay, I forced Luna ult.
I forced Luna ult.
I was not gonna hit that shot but he still ulted.
Here, I gave you...
Let me know when you're ulting.
Not yet.
I got you.
I'm gonna fucking shit myself.
I don't have another bubble so good luck.
At best I can do this.
Focus so fucking low, bro.
Oh, I'm fucking... I'm so low too.
Focus low.
Close low.
Nice.
I'm just playing on this.
I'm on the strange right now.
No, I'm dead.
I couldn't get in the puddle.
Bro, I'm fucking 1v1ing this fucking strange and he's whipping my ass.
He's like whipping my ass right now.
Oh.
Okay, sorry.
I blocked it for myself.
Oh my god.
I go away now.
I go away.
There's a...
He's right up here.
He's up there.
He's just chilling up there.
Oh my god.
My hands.
I didn't know you could stand up here.
But the guys won.
Okay, I don't know if he's done anything.
I'm just...
Alright.
I have ult though.
Is it worth it?
I have a really good ult cooking up.
I can ult too.
Oh.
Oh my god.
No.
I have ult for next.
Oh my god.
Fucking strange.
I have bubble.
I have bubble for you.
Fuck you.
Okay, you know what?
I don't know what I'm doing, but it's fine.
I'm gonna push the cart.
I'm gonna be a cart bitch.
I'm running it down.
I am gonna be a cart bitch.
Our healers are not here.
Wait, there's a... Okay.
I bubble you just in case.
This guy wants a Starlord gel.
Insta diff.
Okay, I'm coming pushing up with you.
Nice.
Just in case.
I'm pushing cart a bit with our team.
Oh no.
You're back though.
Luna's one!
Oh my god.
She's actually one.
I'm bubbling you.
I'm gonna double kill now.
They have strange ult.
I can try to shield it.
I'm trying to whip him.
I'm whipping him too.
Oh my god!
There's no way!
100% win rate Magneto.
Oh my god!
Misogyny defeated!
We defeated Misogyny!
I got 18 for that?
I got 17.
That was not a 17 point game.
From how much... I'm avoiding medic.
I'll do it.
I'll fucking... I have...
I don't think I'm drunk.
He's still playing.
There's no way.
It's like he's passed out after drinking.
Oh my god.
Who do I have to avoid?
It's actually a Christmas miracle.
I avoided the medic lolikid.
Is there anyone that I need to get?
Do what you feel like.
Do what your heart desires.
I'm gonna actually use the bathroom I did in last time.
I just got water.
You lied.
Why is the avoidance teammate so out of the way?
Okay, now that Doki's in the bathroom, we should get five gifted subs to farm Valorant out of their money.
Also, I have no slots.
I just have Mikipoo, VivaPalestina, and Provy.
Pretty stacked avoid list.
That was such a hard game.
We both had to go tank.
Oh my god, chat.
That was actually crazy.
We won though.
You have 100% winrate on Magneto now.
I can't believe.
I can't believe I won a game on tank.
I literally never used a bubble on myself and I literally just bubbled Mac the entire time.
I feel like Mac just took...
I was like, okay, here's a bubble for Mac.
Here's another bubble for Mac.
Here's one for Ruben.
Just for good luck.
I feel like Magneto is pretty easy to get a hang of.
You just, you know, you just press his buttons.
Yeah, literally, that's what I did.
I just pressed his buttons on repeat.
Oh my god, we have a tank player.
We have an actual tank player.
We have a Magneto hero portrait.
He also has a board portrait for Strange.
Oh my god, he's an actual tank tank player.
Does somebody want to play Magneto?
He asked for all the DPS players.
Man.
They're just target banning you.
Okay, Hawkeye?
I guess my Starlord has rapidly become my best character.
According to just everyone who's suddenly target banning me.
I've never seen anyone ban Starlord, besides now.
Yeah.
You literally must have pulled up your stream and just saw all the Starlords.
That's basically it.
Hawkeye's no issue.
Pick your hero.
Did he just say Hawkeye is not an issue?
What the fuck is wrong with you and what queues were you in?
Okay, I like this.
It's alright.
I can't believe we made it this far, chat.
We actually won our first GM.
The fact that it was a GM tank game and we won.
Like, what?
We actually won a GM tank game.
That's actually fucking crazy.
I have good frames.
It's meant to be.
I wish this game got like 600 FPS, bro.
Dude, I'm told.
I try not to stream.
I don't like streaming Marble Rivals that much just because my frames drop too.
I haven't played it without streaming yet.
I get like 240 to like 300 while streaming.
When I stream, I get like 200, but sometimes it drops to 100.
But it's not like often.
It's just hanging around 100 in the middle of a fight.
It's really annoying.
Oh, if a strange portal opens, my shit goes double digits sometimes.
Oh, fuck.
Alright, I put it on you, Ruben.
You better impress me.
I'm gonna Pug Champ all over the place.
You better...
Oh.
Oh, we forgot about...
I'm just gonna shrug them early.
We forgot to ban Hulk.
We forgot our one rule.
Luna one.
Luna's so low.
Mag.
Hulk one.
Ironman one.
Ironman one too.
Ironman's so low.
Wow, he was literally one.
Mag low.
They have no healers.
Go.
Hulk.
Make a minion.
Leave him.
Just let him chill.
He's having a good time.
Alright, Ruben.
It really depends on if our tank ever takes any damage for you to get healed.
I bet.
And at the moment, he's taking zero damage.
I think they're gonna go hype.
I think it's hype is where the party's at.
Are they going hype?
Uh, yes.
Oh, I'm falling down.
I'm out of there.
I got you.
Oh, he's hulking out.
They have a tank now.
Settlock.
I got you.
Hulk on point.
Oh, he fucking bubbled.
Hulk is low.
Hulk is half.
Hulk is right here.
He's half.
He's so low.
He's actually one.
Oh, shit.
Oh, huge rez.
I'm gonna fucking...
I got him out of mech.
Fuck you.
I got you.
I'm just killing all.
I got the turret.
I love this orb.
You're fine.
Punisher.
Punisher is one.
No more?
I mean, this is just great.
This is so nice.
Why can't our games be like this?
I'm having a great time just chilling up here.
Yeah, you gotta have a break after the stressful game last time.
Yeah, I'm stressing out playing Starlord, dashing everywhere right now.
I'm just vibing on a turret.
With a raccoon.
Oh, behind us.
Behind us.
Back, back, back.
There's a Magneto just slowly walking up.
Oh my god, I get to play Psylocke and do whatever I want.
This is so nice.
Oh my god.
I don't have to fill.
This is beautiful.
They should have both.
Yeah, they didn't even do anything.
I'm gonna pop mine and they're both gonna pop theirs.
Who the fuck is talking?
I wish I knew.
I wish it don't be in the top left.
Who are you?
It always happens.
Is it Magneto?
No, it's Ironfist.
Oh, okay.
This game is so buggy, bro.
You gotta say your name first before we know who it is.
I'm gonna pop my ult.
No, don't use everything.
You're making space.
I love having a tank player.
It's so nice.
And he's comfy solo tanking too.
Yeah, he's just nice.
I gave him the snowflake, by the way.
I know where the health packs are.
I'm gonna break the pole in the middle.
Nice!
There's a Magneto.
To our right.
Alright, time to dance.
I'm dancing.
Okay.
Good luck.
You popped the second defensive ult.
I think we die here, maybe.
We're down.
Yeah, yeah, we just back up.
It's fine.
I can engage on them whenever.
We have max ult for...
and they have zero defensive ult.
This is it.
This is your time to shine.
I'm gonna peek and break the turret.
He didn't give you infinite.
Yeah, what else is new with these fucking Raccoon players?
I got one shot at him.
This is where I die.
Nope, this is where I die.
Not from the Psylocke ult.
Yo, can you play Mantis?
You think that Lucio would like to play Mantis?
Oh my god.
Yeah, I think they're gonna get their spoil soon.
Can you use Mag?
Rocket,
give me infinite here and I can push tomorrow.
I don't think he knows what you're talking about.
Oh, there he goes, there he goes.
We're double healing, pocketing you.
Mag dies, Mag dies.
Oh my god.
We got fucking...
I thought our Mag would bubble me next round.
I don't think he has it.
Because he bubbled himself.
This just wasn't our map, guys!
What is he saying?
Is Mike...
Sounds like he's in a submarine.
I think I can touch.
Alright.
I don't think we should use anything.
Oh my god, did you get headshot there?
I just insta-died as soon as I touched.
Yeah, you got headshot, there's no way!
I'm like, you know, I ulted there for some reason.
I think after...
After my ult, I think I'm gonna swap because this Namor...
Okay, maybe that was just a really good Namor map against Psylocke.
Yeah, I mean our Iron Fist is just doing nothing, I think.
Tis the Iron Fist player.
That has to be our tank.
You can go Mantis.
The rocket's enabling me a bit.
Also,
I can go Buggy if Psylocke doesn't work for his fight.
I'm gonna follow you two.
Where are you going, man?
My Magneto's following you guys.
Nice.
They already destroyed the platform.
Mantis, Mantis, Mantis.
Psylocke on the left.
Psylocke one.
Our tank is on point.
Namor one, Namor one.
Psylocke and left all.
I'm pushing up to you guys.
That was a nice blink.
I'm gonna hop onto it and start breaking walls.
Do they have Luna or Mantis ult?
Yes, they do.
You force it out and I'll use mine after.
You died so fast.
Oh my god.
I hope he's forcing stuff right now.
Punisher, Punisher.
Namor.
I froze somebody.
A Magneto, a Magneto one.
Namor's one, Namor's one, Namor's one.
Namor's actually one.
He's so low, he's actually low.
There we go.
Oh my god, I love this hero.
Okay, okay, okay, I don't know if we should push up so close.
They should still have support ult.
There's a Psylocke under us, I think.
I got you.
I'm backing up.
Where are they going?
They're going right side, they're going Mania.
I have to use this.
Oh, that's huge, that's huge.
Namor, Namor, Namor.
I'm ulting after this.
I'm dead here.
I'm gonna...
I killed the man.
Wait, we win this, we win this.
Oh my god, Ruben, you fucking...
You fucking popped off.
Yeah, it's just that easy.
You pushed the button.
It's just that free, what can I say.
That's crazy.
I did that in my sleep.
You were so quiet, you were so locked in.
You literally stopped talking.
You were so locked in.
If I stop talking, that's how you know something's going on.
You literally stopped saying words.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Look at us go.
Back to GM2.
Let's go, we're back in it.
Oh wow, that was an instant kill.
I'm so happy we had a tank clear there.
Now it's all going to be downhill.
I like, some of them I don't even recognize.
I'm like, they must have just woke up.
Top 1 GunZ player.
That's not Carter, is it?
Guys, we don't have... no.
We have 3 support players again.
Oh no.
I'm banning Hawkeye.
Alright.
Always ban Hawkeye.
No, I can't.
I have to go through another...
3 support players.
Why did this guy ban Black Panther?
Oh, thank god.
Dude!
Do we ban Hawkeye?
Do we do it?
Black Panther?
Why?
Do they actually...
I'm going to be the one guy to ban Hawkeye.
Bro!
Fuck!
I mean, they left Hela open.
So I guess I just have to terrorize them on this.
You gotta do something to make them remember.
But we don't have a tank.
Oh, wait.
I'm pretty good at this character too.
Wait, we didn't ban Mantis.
No, sir.
You're playing Punisher?
How are you not going to do more damage?
I think you should go to federal prison if you don't do more damage.
You have a turret and full auto.
Why are you on my dick?
No.
The answer is no.
I just flipped the strip.
I just used your logic.
Oh man, I'm sad we don't get Mantis Luna.
Let's hope this Loki can sustain without a Mantis.
Yo, okay, he's going to get five if he doesn't get more damage.
And if he does get more damage, he gets nothing.
I'm a master of the deal.
I'll give it to...
You read the book.
I don't have...
I'll give it to her tank.
Okay, I'll freeze somebody.
And I will bubble you if they...
They blocked my freeze.
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up, that's fucked actually.
I dropped down a little.
I got a little scared, not going to lie.
Okay.
Our Loki's dead.
I don't know how.
Oh, because they're over here.
I got you.
Yo, nice.
Okay.
Oh my god, someone be wanting our fucking...
I hear some footsteps near me.
There's like a Luna or someone up there.
Yeah, there's...
There's a Luna and a other guy in our spawn.
There's a Luna, right?
Yeah, I was like, why are these footsteps?
Dude, it's so satisfying to save people with bubbles, man.
It's so much fun.
I'm going to put it on our tank.
Our tank really fucking needs these heals.
After what I just saw, that shit was crazy.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god!
Top one guts player!
Fucking doing it.
That timing is insane.
I'm out here.
I just got camera diff'd.
What happened?
I was walking on a corner where my camera was covered.
Oh, I'm fucking...
Magic, hit her twice.
I'm going to... I'm ulting on point.
I'm ulting on point.
We're letting them free cap.
Oh, I'm getting in your ult.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're going to have a lot of ult still for them after this.
Strange, strange, strange!
I'm trying to keep you up.
I'm trying so hard.
Oh, that's not you.
I forgot you're a non-punisher.
Oh my god, magic solo!
Oh, nice!
Magneil, Magneil!
I froze him, I froze him!
God, I froze him because of me!
Top one gunsie player, nice!
The guy's just lurking on Hela.
He's actually so strange.
If he's going to lurk, I can give you...
Oh my god, I can give you Orb.
Where are you?
I'll give you Orb first before I give it to Ting.
I might be able to build ults here.
I missed the...
I forgot I'm alive!
What?
Ah, shit.
No, I didn't see the heal up!
I almost have ult too.
I have to reload, man.
Fuck me.
I'm coming back, but I don't know if we're going to be able to cut guard it.
I can...
I can maybe stall?
Oh, our Punisher has ult.
Yeah, I'm ulting.
Stand into this ult!
Punisher!
I'm so safe!
They're going to have...
No!
What?
How did we get off?
That is the most depressing thing ever.
I can't believe we got off with all Ting and DPS and support.
And I was one of them.
I was coming back.
I'm so sad.
That's okay.
Two minutes, that's super doable.
Oh, man.
I'm so sad.
I got off because I was like, I'm going to heal on the side.
That is so sad.
He's like nonchalant.
The fact that we lost the point and just went...
Weepy!
Yeah, bye.
Bro.
I can't.
I can't with my Punisher.
I can't heal you, by the way, up there.
Oh!
Venom on me!
Look up!
I can't.
I couldn't heal you up there.
Venom's a problem.
I have to just stand on the edge.
Arm.
We have to regroup and have one push together.
Or not, actually.
So when...
I can ult and touch.
I just got headshot over.
Are we touching?
Okay, I'm going in.
We have hell ult, though.
They took it all.
Venom on HP, beyond.
There's nothing I can do.
We have almost...
That's huge!
We're coming back.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
I killed their Manta.
I am Captain America!
You're Captain, you're him!
Wow.
Not the Wailord.
There's support.
There's a Luna at the backline.
Kill the Carnage Johnson!
I killed Luna.
You did not kill Venom.
I see him walking around.
Oh, sorry.
Luna.
I think it's just magic.
Magic, magic, magic, magic!
Magic's one!
God, I love Captain America!
You ran into him and went America!
Oh, dude, I got 90 to all two!
Can you own up like a man to our agreement?
What's your damage?
13k.
14 kills.
Less deaths.
Now why?
You're not a man.
You're a little boy.
I'm her friend.
I bet you cheat on your girlfriend.
I know, right?
Wow!
Who hit you?
What a sweetie pie!
He agreed to our agreement.
I'm better than him at everything.
Wait, I didn't even agree!
I told you to get off my dick!
I didn't even agree!
Where's the five gift cards?
I don't know.
You give me five gifted and you get nothing.
You're in the right place.
It's over now.
Oh my god!
This poor man!
Portal!
Let's go back.
I love VCs.
That's ours!
That was ours!
I was like, I don't know where he is.
Oh my god!
Yeah, I know.
That scared me.
I legit thought that wasn't ours.
I went through so much trauma.
Get the Groot!
Literally Groot!
What the hell?
Is he playing Fortnite?
What the fuck?
Oh no no no!
Damn!
Top one gun player is fucking you down.
I just got Mantis headshot into a Hella headshot.
Like, what the fuck?
I'm gonna take my anchor off on my Teemo.
Yeah, fuck her up!
I'm like, so awake now after that.
I'm gonna start shooting tanks with stat pads so I can damage them.
You're really gonna let him win?
You're really gonna...
Nah, I'm killing tanks.
I'm stat padding.
Damn, you're like risking your life for this now.
You're motivated.
There's some passion right there.
Damn!
Oh, he's catching up.
He's gonna catch up now.
Oh, this is huge.
Yo, check out this boulder, okay?
Just give me a second, I'm waiting for the Luna ult to end.
And the Mantis ult too.
Oh, we have a double Luna.
Mantis ult should have ended.
I got her.
Oh, she's coming over.
No!
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Please, I got magicked.
There's magic Penny and Luna and Mantis.
I don't think we're winning this.
Oh, you're stat padding.
Maybe you'll win this.
I'm stat padding.
We have four minutes.
I'm coming back.
You gotta back up, back up, back up.
Back up if you can, back up if you can.
Oh, that's good, that's good.
That's good, that's good.
Oh, I knocked him back as he went for it.
I'm a mechanical genius.
By the way, I cannot heal you from up there.
I'm faking.
I give you an orb.
Jesus Christ.
Look at that Penny.
I made him overextend.
I have ult soon.
Nice.
I'm reloading.
We haven't won!
But you did a nice job!
Oh my god.
Their entire team is back now.
Nah, check out this boulder.
Yeah, I'm checking it out.
Hold up.
It's gonna be a boulder moment.
I'm getting dived.
Yeah, but you only have low-key heals.
Nah, it's chill.
Oh, it's not chill.
They're so low.
We gotta regroup.
Oh my god!
There's so much damage.
Oh, I missed it.
Okay, I'm not peeking.
I'm not cocky anymore.
Yeah, but what if you did it one more time?
Yeah, we need to kill the healers.
We still have it!
What just killed me?
That was a Mantis one-tap!
We have two fights left.
I can get all, but they have all two.
They pushed it really far.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Okay.
They pushed pretty far, so...
No, there's a Helmeteer left!
There's a Helmeteer left!
I have to ult.
Yo, Punisher, look right!
Shoot her ult, bro!
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Just fight on point if we can.
I'm coming over.
Punisher, I'm coming over with ult.
You just two-tapped me!
I got two-tapped!
Dude, what?
We have to back up, we have to reset, we have to reset, we have to reset.
I'm not ulting, I'm not ulting this.
Let me just reset.
This is good that we died to that.
Yeah, I'm resetting.
No,
no, no!
Let's see if we can two-tap them.
We got time, we got time.
We wait for our Luna, and we win this.
I don't know if you guys...
I don't know if you guys can wait for me.
Okay.
I'm about to die.
Hello?
I have to go in with ult then.
Gotta go.
I'm on it.
I'm ready to put on a show!
My ult ends in three seconds.
We can definitely stall this for long now.
I might die from this.
Yeah.
You only have low-key heals.
Where are my shots coming from?
Damn.
Oh my god, we had so many picks too.
That thing's just about to die.
That's unfortunate.
Bro, this guy is still talking about it!
Hey man, I'd expect that from Punisher.
Bro, he lost it!
He's like, I'm just damage though.
Okay.
I'm minus 12 in GM too.
We gotta win this next one.
I'm not demoting.
The worst part was I wasn't even getting slammed by their Hello.
It was their Mantis.
Their Mantis would randomly headshot me across the fucking map.
Oh my god, that guy had a lot of damage.
Holy shit!
Yeah!
That guy was...
Wow.
I think if we had a Mantis though, it would have been easier.
With the damage boost.
But I think this guy is a low-key one-trick.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
There's no way to win that.
Man, that game was going so well too.
It would have been less painful if we weren't so close to winning.
I know!
We actually got so many picks but we couldn't kill them.
They had double support ult.
But we didn't.
It would be fine when low-key a Mantis was banned.
How do you even one-trick in these ranks?
You can't.
Don't worry.
People can.
Because you one-trick a character that never gets banned.
That's how.
Because who the fuck would ban low-key?
It's such a dogshit hero.
Okay, it's not dogshit.
But when you have other options.
When you actually have other options.
When you have Luna, Mantis, Cloak, and Adam.
Why would you pick low-key?
Why would you pick any of those characters when you literally have the other stuff?
Hawkeye?
Yes.
I guess I'm the only person voting.
Let's go.
Grab Hulk next.
This is a really good Ironman map.
Adam is meta depending on what is banned.
If Luna's banned, you play Adam and Mantis.
In high elo.
I'm going to shit my pants.
It's going to happen.
No way.
The 20%.
Bro, he took your one trick.
That's so fucked up.
Let's see.
Damn.
Oh, he wants to play Adam?
Okay.
I was going to decide which one.
Please give him a Star Lord.
Yeah, but what if he wants it on his Christmas day?
Fuck his Christmas day.
Spider-Man it is.
Mack, please.
Mack, I will...
I just had to threaten terrorism.
I will find out where you live.
You are not holding me hostage in this lobby.
As the person in my sack, I refuse to let somebody hold me hostage.
I'm on Mantis.
I'll be randomly muted.
He went Spider-Man.
You made him go Spider-Man.
Oh, that's okay.
O.W.
Neal is the goat on Spider-Man.
Oh,
wait.
They also have...
Grits won!
Grits actually won!
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
Mantis is dead.
Oh my god, I'm so low.
He's doing the wall shit.
You are not rezzing.
No, they're one!
Oh my god.
Got him.
Wait, I'm...
Oh my god, there's a Nomura.
There's Nomura over here.
Oh my god.
Nomura just two-tapped me from so far.
Fuck.
Alright.
I'm gonna get five picks here.
We got so many picks too, but we didn't play on point.
So, Starlord's looking for you.
I... yeah.
Oh, he missed!
He missed!
I'm damaged.
I slept through it.
Grew one!
Damage boosting you?
Ah!
Oh, he's dead.
He got...
I killed Starlord.
Wait, he's so low!
Thor's low!
Thor one!
I got Thor.
Oh my god, I hear a Nomura right now.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
Alright, I'm heading over to you.
I got damage boost on you.
And I'm damage boosting your Spider-Man.
Eventually, that'll hit something.
And then I slept the Thor.
And the Thor...
Thor should be a little bit dead.
Nope.
Yeah, I'm not sure if it's possible to heal me.
Yeah, no.
That's on me.
I got you.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, what?!
Does he fucking breathe to me?!
No!
I'm dying.
Okay, good job.
No, I'm fucking bleeding.
Okay, that's fine.
I have ult on me.
There's a Groot literally on my ass right now.
Oh my god, Spider-Man.
I hope you live.
Oh,
Ace, please.
Here, Reuben.
I'm giving you damage boost.
Do something with it.
So is one.
Oh, he missed again!
He's so bad at Groot.
Please, we can't let this happen.
He's literally asleep.
He's asleep.
He's everything.
Here we go.
Oh my god, I'm like...
How is this Groot still alive?!
I'm...
Here, they have Born.
They have Born again.
Oh, beautiful.
Alright.
No more, no more, no more!
To your left, to your left!
Alright.
I'm using mine.
Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor, Thor!
Oh, he got healed.
Beautiful.
Fucking...
I fucked it.
Oh, we got back out.
We got back out.
We don't win this.
No, we don't, we don't, we don't.
Um...
Me and...
We're trying very hard.
They have no support ults, so I just went for the kill on their supports.
Oh my god!
I didn't realize they're... all of them are here.
They're right...
Where are you?
I don't have... I got you, I got you.
Nah, I don't wanna.
I don't even know...
Do we live this?
Yes, okay.
I'm probably dead.
Just gonna get out.
Okay.
Thor is so low, too.
Why?
I couldn't...
I don't have enough heals for this.
Only 60 seconds left.
Oh my fucking god.
Got it.
Oh my god, he's so low!
Adam is so low.
I don't have enough heals.
I got... nice, nice, nice, nice.
He might have Born again, though.
I'm gonna use this ult.
I'm pushing this.
We are undefeatable!
Use it.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna wait for Mantis ult to end, and then I ult.
I just don't...
I got two guys, I think.
This is the last fight that we fight here.
Yeah, this is the last fight.
I'm...
Can we even touch it, though?
I'm... aw, shit.
Yeah, I don't think any of us can touch it.
I can't... I can't see you.
I can't.
I was gonna try to go for the touch.
I might be able to... aw.
Aw, that's fucked.
Aw.
That's fucked.
Neil tried taking my Psylocke after going 8 and 5.
Nuh-uh.
Nope.
I think he's just a... I think he's literally a Psylocke player.
I think he might terrorize.
I mean, I can.
Yeah, he fucking got you.
He fucking got you.
He terrorized you.
To be fair, he actually filled the last...
He filled last time we got him.
To be fair.
He took Luna.
This Mantis out-counter ults me, so like...
Yeah.
If I ult, she'll ult, so then you'll get your DPS ult after.
Is Captain America good on this map?
I don't know.
See that, Starlord?
Not for long, you don't.
What am I doing?
I don't know.
But I believe in you.
Thank you.
Okay, where is my HP?
Same.
I don't see.
You guys are like so far away.
Oh my god, he just got a heal.
Fuck.
Thought he was alone.
Okay.
You guys are way too far.
Like, you're everywhere.
So we couldn't... Adam and I couldn't do anything.
Can you touch or no?
Wait,
Mantis no sleep.
Nice.
But we can't help you there, though.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
We have to fight closer.
They get so much free push.
Where was that?
I have to always use my heals.
I need to use this.
I had to use that.
We were so low.
I have to get picked here.
Oh no.
My HP evaporated.
That's unlucky.
If I didn't use it...
If I didn't use it, we'd all die there.
Yeah.
Okay, what do we avoid after this game?
I can't heal anybody.
I'm gonna heal on your right.
I don't have a lot of heals left.
They're slow, though.
Oh my god, they're so low.
I have nothing.
I'm about to melt.
I'm done.
I'm kicking them.
Oh my god, do we have rez?
We do, thanks guys.
I don't have enough heals for this.
I'm eating so much shit.
I know.
I literally just got my ult.
What?
No wait.
Hold up.
Assemble!
Oh my god.
I'm damage boosting you.
I'm assembling.
Oh my god.
There's assembling all over the point.
You guys are taking so much damage.
Oh my god.
I couldn't assemble hard enough.
I can't.
I can't do anything.
I'm trying to touch.
No.
I just had two tank players.
I just had two
tank players.
What do we do about that?
Oh thank god.
I almost...
I'm almost like...
Wait, do we avoid people?
We should avoid people.
Wait,
I'm negative 30 but I'm still GM 2?
How?
Oh you avoided me?
Alright.
Hey 42% accuracy.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Never below 40.
One thing I don't understand is when Overwatch players would always name every account they have that's not Overwatch Overwatch at the end.
Why would you want to out yourself as an Overwatch player?
I don't understand.
We're in Marvel Rivals.
Why do you want to tell people you're from Overwatch?
There's no reason to.
It's so fucked up.
Like you just hate yourself I think.
Okay.
We have a tank player?
Or that guy was feeling...
Oh we have double tank.
The damn pocket link was the tank.
Played Thor really well.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Even our other guy was fed up with Neal last game.
If Neal randomly gets better, I'm gonna...
Even he was fed up!
Oh my god!
That's fucking hilarious.
Even he knows what the problem was!
I'm gonna lose it.
Nice.
Alright, now who do we ban?
Banner?
Bruce?
Banner.
Thank god.
That means Hela might be free then.
That's fine.
Yeah, we win these.
Yeah.
Black Panther?
Where the fuck is a Panther player?
Dude, what's up with these Black Panther bans?
At least I get to go Shylock.
Mantis isn't banned.
Nice.
That's what I like to see.
Guys, after my Christmas stream, what if I just stream more Marvel Rivals?
I don't know.
What if I just do more DJM after my Christmas stream?
Oh my god, and my frames are good this game!
Alright, let's go.
I'm like counting how many hours of sleep I'm gonna get before my next stream.
And Neo might be on Hela, we're fine!
Oh my god, bro!
He does not like Neo.
Magneto!
What the fuck?
I just slept out of a dodge.
Oh my god, Ace is taking a lot of damage.
I'm trying to get in your LRS.
I got you.
I literally have to...
Punish her dead.
Neo!
You died to Neo!
You're gonna let Neo out Hela you?
I ain't even on Hela.
He got that.
Okay,
I'm going bottom real quick.
I'm just a little bit worried about the Hela.
Jesus Christ.
I literally have this guy.
Just teleported when I swung in.
There's some guy on high ground.
There's Neo on high ground.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, our Stalker Strange has a fucking vendetta against Neo.
This server is so fucking bad.
Oh my god.
This is West Coast.
I have 70 ping to West Coast.
It says I have 90 ping or 80 ping roughly.
It's Oregon.
That's not good.
I just need a little bit.
Oh my god.
Everything's fine.
Wait, can you tell them Luna, Mantis first.
Mantis ult first.
Luna, Mantis ult first, okay?
Don't do it first.
No, I said Mantis ult first.
Yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Oh shit, I didn't...
Oh my god, I didn't realize she was up there.
That's fine.
No, I didn't realize Hella was that close.
We can still fight this.
I have my Luna ult.
They use Luna ult.
It's recontestable.
I'm gonna I'm gonna go in with my Luna ult.
I'm going in now.
Okay, my man.
Go!
Let's go!
Have they used their ult?
I don't know.
I know they don't have Luna ult.
I'm focusing Mantis.
Okay.
There's a Groot on point.
Stay on point though.
Oh my god, this is beautiful.
Okay.
Nice.
They have They have Groot ult.
Punisher top.
Wait, no, they don't.
They just swapped to Groot, right?
Um, no.
They were never Groot.
Oh, okay.
I felt like they were very non-existent as Groot.
Okay.
Yeah, be ready for a Groot ult.
I don't know if I have anything.
No!
I might be dead here.
I'm so low.
Can I help you, Ducky?
I don't.
That's a Groot ult.
Woah!
Mantis one!
I got Mantis.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
I got Neal.
We got Neal!
Let's fucking go!
I got Neal, nothing changed.
Okay.
They're walling.
Then I can die.
Oh my god, I have to fucking reload my head.
Oh my god, I got you!
I'm dancing!
I'm fucking dancing!
Let's go!
Keep shaking ass, you're doing great!
Look, watch me dance!
I've never whiffed my Psylocke ult harder than that.
I think I didn't see anything.
I was too busy dancing.
Luna has the goofiest ult I've ever seen in a fucking shooter game.
Sometimes I don't know if she's actually hitting her targets.
Her circle adder moves extremely fast or so slow.
I tried dashing and then ulting and then I didn't have dash.
I love that she dances for you.
It's just so funny to me.
It's such a meme.
I don't have to...
I'm not sad whenever I see her dance.
I wish Zenyatta would dance when he does his trance.
It just makes me so happy.
If only Zen can also dance when he does it.
It would make the game so much better if he just starts dancing when he trance.
Yeah, Zen just breaking it down.
It should be a skin.
I still love the fact that Ace was like I'm gonna fucking lose it and you'll get better at this game.
That was so funny.
That was actually so fucking funny.
It was just like, he knows who the weak link was too.
Jesus Christ.
They let us push this far?
Oh my god, Nioh!
Aw, Nioh was one.
What the fuck?
Penny is one too.
Oh my god.
They got it so fast.
It's crazy.
I have it too.
It's time for my turn to dance.
That's looking right.
Nioh just tried TPing up to me to 1v1 me.
Good effort, good effort Nioh.
A little silly from Nioh.
Good effort.
Good job, guys.
Nioh, get off the game!
Oh my god!
This guy is a professional hater.
Holy shit.
I can't even blame him, Nioh deserves it.
So true.
Oh my god.
I get it.
He gets it.
Everyone wants him gone.
Oh my god, that poor guy.
This is how he spends his Christmas.
For those who want the character arc of Nioh, he was really bad at DPS on our last game, and then I think us and the tank avoided Nioh, and then the one time when we got a game, Ace was like, if Nioh randomly gets better, I'm gonna fucking lose it.
And then, a bitch troll not to go hella here.
Nioh might be on hella work fine.
The thing is, he didn't say anything before.
He had said nothing about Nioh before in last game.
It was just...
It was...
When we got to this game, he fucking went full on straight hater.
We didn't know how much Ace hated Nioh until now.
He literally said nothing last game.
And in this game, he was like, oh my god, I fucking hate you, Nioh.
Get off the game.
I can't believe he was silent hating Nioh in the last game.
It was so much... He had all that hate within himself, trying to keep it in until he goes on the enemy team.
I think... Oh my god, that was crazy when he was like...
I love how... I don't know if it's the sleep deprivation or like, Nioh might be on hella, so we're fine.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub and the prime.
I really appreciate it.
Bro, waited for this one moment.
Yeah, he fucking waited for that.
John, thank you for giving us sub.
Tier 1 sub to Thunder.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah!
It was waiting for you.
Oh my god, this is a diamond game.
Oh my god, we have a diamond game.
And they're like, we can't find anybody here.
Okay, if we lose this, we lose a lot.
Because we're in a diamond game, just saying.
No, we just lose.
The Smegma Smuggler.
What a gamer.
Do you think they'll both fail for...
We have Asianlover69.
He's not shy but look, he loves.
Look at these names, welcome to competitive shooters.
Daniel is not doing a lot.
These motherfuckers!
Five names in a row!
I'm doing Bruce.
I love Daniel.
I love how, as a stack, we're just trying to control the queues.
Oh my god, these guys are such bums.
To be fair, I won't be surprised if they're stream sniping me.
If they're stream sniping me, because I'm like, number 5th right now on Marvel Rivals.
They can literally boot up the stream.
They can literally open up my directory and just see me.
Yeah, I'm in Canada, bro.
Yeah, it's crazy.
I'm fish right now.
I tend to confuse people.
Alright.
I give it...
Why do we have Captain America?
It's not even like it's recent.
It's like you've been there for a while.
Look at that.
I didn't give all my left big game.
Holy shit.
Bro is bad ass.
Dude just reminded him of his trauma.
No, I did back in the day.
Holy shit.
I can't believe they banned my fucking Psylocke, bro.
We just got double targeted.
Yeah.
You gotta teach them a lesson they don't forget.
You play everything else.
It doesn't matter if you ban my Psylocke, I'll just be unhappy and I'll steal shit on you.
Oh wait, they have Groot.
Oh, I'm gonna shotgun the shit out of this guy.
They have Groot.
I'm putting this on the fucking Groot.
I feel like out of all of them, Groot is the feediest.
Nevermind, I should put on Captain America.
God, I love having a shotgun.
Okay.
The hell is just looking at me?
Alright.
I'm putting it on Captain America.
Oh, I'm frozen.
Nice.
Oh wait, yeah.
Hella's not banned.
Yeah.
Wait, you could've played Hella this entire time.
No.
You could've played Hella this entire time.
Alright, I have no idea.
Someone in my chat was like, in love with you, Mac.
Bro, this is my chat.
Nah, that's so real of them.
That's so fucking real of them.
Guys, Alpernator has his own stream, guys.
You can tell it to him on his own stream.
Oh, that's huge.
That's huge.
That's actually huge.
Oh my god.
Oh,
I can ult after this?
You can ult.
Oh, after this.
Dope, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'm bodyblocking this.
Oh my god, I fell.
No shot, there's a giant pillar here.
Why is there a pillar here?
I'm sliding, I'm moving.
Dude, that pillar has fucked me over so many times.
Strange, can die.
I'm gonna slap him if I have to.
Dude, I am legit just spamming my shock wards.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
We're so healthy.
I've legit just been using...
Somebody's probably gonna accept the name.
Oh, Groot.
Oh, Captain.
He's going American.
I'm like, really worried.
Yeah, they're bad.
Strange one, strange one.
Oh my god, I fucked that one guy in particular.
Rocks.
Our cat might die.
I'm not using my ult.
Oh, that's a really good ult for us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I knew he was gonna use more.
Oh yeah, tell our Mantis he ults first, I'll ult later.
I wanna keep my Luna if we can.
That he ults first?
Yeah, he ults first.
I'm keeping my Luna ult, because it's better.
It's better for the next round when we have Luna.
Yeah, cycle him.
I'm down with that.
Alright, here we go.
That Raccoon wants to die.
Alright, here we go!
Here we go!
We don't die to this!
Didn't get a chance to save my ult, but that's fine.
They respawned Spider-Man.
I was in the air.
I'm trying to keep you up, but I don't know if I can.
I killed Iron Man.
That's huge, that's a huge ult.
That was a huge ult.
Oh no.
We have to reset.
I don't think we win this.
Wow.
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I don't think we win that.
I didn't realize that so many of us died.
I thought we still had like 5 up.
Yeah, yeah.
We had to regroup.
This is like our last fight.
So we can't die here.
I need to make sure we're all...
No.
He's using heals.
He used a mirror kill.
Oh no.
I've only killed one.
Nice.
I have my ult here too.
I'm gonna use it right after.
I'm using it now.
I don't know where he just went.
We had to get something.
Can I just come back?
Oh no way.
I love headshotting.
I couldn't.
That's unlucky.
Need this 100 men killed.
Please.
The rest of my coffee.
Oh my god, that's so lucky.
I'm talking to this guy with like 1 HP and he flies away.
I'm begging you guys.
I literally just saw him.
Okay, but a bug.
I just haven't seen that guy.
I think I just saw him.
Yeah, I literally just saw him.
Oh sorry, whoops.
I pre-answered yours.
I'm stream sniping them.
I helped you answer your question.
Oh my god.
I'm going to put on Captain America.
Because I feel like he's going to fucking die.
Oh, this is going to be a really bad map for Iron Man.
I mean, he doesn't have Hulk.
So he shouldn't be too...
Oh, I see you, I see you.
I... oh my god.
I can't save him though.
I'm trying to group behind you.
Group behind you, group behind you.
Oh shit, well I got my one.
I'm being ran at by a strange.
I'm in the air.
Please, please don't...
I'm trying to, I'm trying to, I'm trying to.
I had to look at Captain America.
Oh no.
I think we might die though, maybe?
Yeah, unless...
Oh, they haven't capped it yet, they haven't capped it.
Strange one, strange one.
I got strange, I got strange.
Hella close right, hella close right.
Shotgun time.
Someone shoot the Iron Man, please.
He's one.
I got him.
Alright.
Okay.
This is fine.
They have, they use Groot ult.
But they have Raccoon ult.
I can't see our Captain America.
Fucking hell.
Our Captain America scares me.
Nice.
Our Captain America scares me so fucking much.
I have to fight this.
I have to fight this here.
Oh man, I got frozen.
I stalled as long as I can.
But I'm gonna die on the point.
Oh, I stalled for so long though.
We still have point, we still have point.
Just die on point if you can.
Don't leave point, please.
Don't let my efforts go unnoticed.
Honestly, I come back with my ult.
We can win this.
Oh no!
Nah, okay, nevermind.
Oh, I'm not dying.
Gotta wait for Groot.
Actually, I got you.
I'm trying to keep...
I can't wait for them to fix this crosshair shit.
I got you.
I have it on...
Oh, we have Thor now.
How does one...
Please.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That is...
Don't care.
Groot, focus on Groot first.
Oh no.
I might be dead to this.
No.
We have no supports.
We have Mantis, but he's trying to LOS.
I already killed the...
Hello.
Nice.
I'm coming over with ult.
Thankfully, I have a shotgun.
Thankfully, I have a shotgun!
Thank god.
LOS our Mantis if you can.
I got you, Mac.
Okay, nice.
They're walking left.
Okay.
Thank you for letting me know.
Jesus Christ.
I have to use this.
We were all so low.
Bye.
No!
I couldn't get out of that.
We were down three, though.
We should reset.
It's fine.
We have one fire here.
They have...
They have I.
And they have...
I don't know if they have Luna.
I think they have Luna ult, too.
Yeah, they did.
They have Hello ult and I.
And Luna.
I froze Iron Man!
I killed him.
Nice.
I'm shooting it.
He's low.
No way she's one!
I can't.
I won't be able to grab.
I'm ulting.
No, I used everything.
That's huge.
No, I got eyed!
Oh no, I got eyed.
There's two of you there.
I come back.
I got eyed.
I killed both supports.
I did all I could.
Are Thor...
It's just Thor, though.
I don't think he lives that.
He's got...
No, he ulted and he put him off point.
He left point!
All he did was ult.
He would have killed them both in one with that ult, too.
Oh my god.
GG.
He ulted.
That's unfortunate.
Oh my god.
I hope they fix that.
That sure has to count.
That's actually crazy that he ulted that.
Jesus Christ.
Are there... do you rank there?
Did I do rank on that?
No!
No, I didn't!
Oh my god, I did it!
I just sucked the edge.
That's why I said the diamond queues are bad.
That was rough.
Oh my god.
I'm literally at zero points.
I need to win two games in a row to be back to GM2.
Bro, these games have been rough, though.
Okay, if we win this next one, I'm out.
No, we need to win two.
Okay, if we win the next two, I'm out.
Okay, okay, okay.
When we win the next two.
If we don't.
If we win one...
There is no if.
When we win both.
Okay, Mac, what's your ideal?
What's your ideal situation here?
Huh?
My brain was off.
I didn't hear shit.
We talking about getting off?
Oh my god.
Wait, Mac, are you done?
Huh?
No.
You're not.
Okay, if we win two, I'm out.
I'm fucking... I'm out.
I'm out.
I'm out for the day.
Bro, we're not going to Zineful.
Bro, I bumped into the Zineful.
And he was at his 24 hour mark.
And apparently, I broke his last streak.
Like, that shit was so depressing.
He got off at 29 hours, apparently.
He was Eternity yesterday, Mac.
Yeah, he said he went from Eternity to D1.
Back to GM2 before he got off.
They have a Pope on their team, dude.
The Pope.
Oh my gosh, the Pope.
Like, I'm not...
We're not going full Zineful.
I'm Luna Snow.
Whoa, a magic player.
I shine in darkness.
His name's Saber, so you know they've gotta be good.
Man,
that game really hurt.
Like, extra.
We win these next two.
So fucked up they target banned both of our characters.
And then they won.
Okay, to be fair.
Okay.
Everybody, we can flex.
I've shown that I can flex to a tank.
We got Luna?
Okay, I'm banning Bruce Banner.
Fuck no defensive ults.
This shit's fucking hard as fuck.
Alright.
Guys, what the fuck you mean?
Oh god, dude.
I literally won on my one tank game today.
I literally won that game.
Alright guys.
Most likely, if we win this, I'm out.
I'm not even gonna...
I'm not even gonna entertain a second game.
I'm fucking tired.
I'm hitting my tired streak now.
Alright.
If we don't, I'm fucking getting my GN2 back.
Oh, it's this fucking mad.
You guys like this map?
What map are we?
No.
I think everybody hates this map.
Dude, it's so ass.
They actually learned nothing from Overwatch hybrid maps.
And they just made another one, but worse.
And the meat walls.
No, those are the worst.
The walls are the worst.
They actually can fuck your entire team over.
And they have a cooldown.
The battle starts in 5...
4...
3...
2...
1...
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Woah.
They got a bookie.
Here we go.
Woah.
I'm good.
Okay.
There's no one playing there.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, our poor Groot.
He's so low though.
Wait, wait, wait.
If he can get strange, he's won.
He's actually won.
Nice.
Oh, I'm on.
I got you.
Okay, I don't got you.
Raccoon's low.
I swear to god, he's actually won.
You fucking make him extinct.
There we go.
Roadkill.
Get him out of here.
I'm gonna call the animal control on him.
I got you, man.
I damage boosted you.
You can chase him if you want.
Oh, that's the entire team.
Don't chase them.
Nah, I'm chasing.
I'm him.
No, the meat wall!
Fuck the meat wall.
I am...
I damage boosted you.
I slept the strange too.
He's dead.
Alright, I'm pushing cart with Raccoon.
Only one ult too.
That's so good.
Guys, I need to increase my accuracy.
It's 38.
Oh shit.
She's throwing.
I can't be throwing with 27% accuracy.
Close the meat wall.
Nah, that'd be fucked up.
Right here.
I killed the rocket.
Oh my god, I used...
Okay, I got rez.
Just live.
This is winnable.
It's not winnable.
I don't think it's winnable.
Oh my god,
he's so low.
The strange is actually so low.
I can't boost with T.
He has no healers.
We can finish this.
We're getting a little silly with it.
I got the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was so winnable.
Fuck you, yo.
Oh my god, I'm fucking insane.
My accuracy is at 33%.
I'm insane.
Okay, I...
And he has to know I was slouching.
I was lying back on my chair slouching playing Mantis.
I'm locked in now.
We're unlocked.
Feet up on the desk and everything.
Yeah, basically.
Eating ice cream with one hand.
Moving with the other hand.
Okay, now I'm sitting upright.
Okay.
This is good.
I'm gonna ult you.
Fuck, he's low.
Nice.
I hear footsteps somewhere.
Yeah, he's on the left.
I'm like...
He's one.
I don't know my left and right.
Oh my god.
I damage boost you too?
I'm gonna go back to the cart.
Here's damage boost.
If you need it.
I'm Groot.
Oh, I don't have anything for that.
I'm hiding.
Oh, nice.
That's huge.
That's so fun.
I only have one support.
No!
Goodbye!
Wait, it's winnable.
We have both...
Oh wait, we don't have supports.
But it's still winnable.
We have all supports.
Rocket.
I'm beating his ass.
I punched him out.
I don't know now if it's winnable, but I'm coming back with heals.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Go to sleep.
We're fucking him up.
Oh my god.
I'm shooting shit.
We're actually doing it.
I accidentally ended up in their spawn because I dashed through the side of the strange portal and I just was there.
Guys, it's not looking so good.
I have 32% accuracy.
Guys, please.
Not a good look for women.
Good luck to women?
I'm sorry.
As the women representative, I'm so sorry.
Guys, for those who want context, we bumped it.
For those who are new here and didn't see one of our matches, for context, we bumped into this guy that was in the enemy team.
And he was flaming this other female player on his own team and talking about it in the match chat.
And he was like, 27% accuracy.
Yeah, that's a woman.
And then I was like, but I'm female too.
And I had 47% accuracy on Mantis.
Like, she had 27% and I had 47% on my team.
And he was like, yeah, but you're one of the only good ones.
You're one of the good ones.
I was just like, holy fuck.
Like, what?
It doesn't look like it.
Because I was like, the fuck you mean?
That's a female player.
He's like, that's a female player.
Bucky, I'm going to tag him.
He's walking to you.
I hit him a little bit.
I shot him a little bit for you.
I got you damage boost.
Oh, nice.
Bro, that poor fucking...
I'm going to break their ass.
I'll break their ass.
I'm trying to help you there.
I got you.
You're safe.
I've never played this fucking ahead this up in a while.
Do you see that Magneto?
Yeah.
This guy is not...
I gave up.
This guy gave up.
I'm fucking farming my accuracy on him.
Let's go.
We're going for 70%.
How did I actually drop down?
I hit like three headshots in a row.
That's actually so fucked.
I can't believe it.
What the fuck?
Look at this raccoon.
Bro, I don't think they're playing the game anymore.
Merry Christmas, bro.
Merry Christmas.
Look at the raccoon, bro.
How am I supposed to hit that?
I want my accuracy.
Let me hit you.
Bro, let me...
Oh look, there's a Dr. Strange here.
I'll give you damage boost and...
Thank you.
Hold up, I have a plan.
No, the Pope!
There you go.
You think I killed the raccoon?
Bro, this is sad.
This is so sad.
I feel like we should avoid everybody on the enemy team.
This is actually...
I just want to know the context of what happened over there.
Yeah, what happened on the 19th?
I think it's Christmas and they know we deserve it.
They had 2-2-2.
What happened to them?
Bro, what's going on?
This is a Christmas miracle.
I think this guy wants the Agamotto.
There's no way.
Oh, I found a hole in the wall.
I'm Groot.
Oh, he's coming over.
He's definitely looking to I.
He's coming over.
He's going to I you right there.
Uh oh.
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
I don't want to die against that.
I'm 1v1-ing the Pope.
Oh my god, not the Pope.
The Pope has aimbot!
You're fine, I ulted.
If you lose to that, it dents on you.
I don't care, I'm stat-padding.
Sorry if you guys want to be friendly, but...
I'm stat-padding too, don't worry.
My accuracy keeps going lower.
I don't understand.
They're actually making my accuracy worse.
I'm going to lie and say that I didn't notice.
How are they making my accuracy worse?
I'm literally hitting my shots.
What happened?
He was just jumping at me innocently like he wanted to be friends.
What happened in the team chat?
I need to know.
He wants to show you something.
Who boomed and why?
You liked that.
Merry Christmas.
No one in the NA team is saying anything about what happened.
I don't know if I want any of those people on my team.
18?
Really?
I got 20!
Yo, I'm happy with 20.
Okay,
I can either leave right now or give Ruben another game.
One more game.
That wasn't a real game.
If I lose this, we're playing until I'm back to GM2.
There is no if.
We will win this one.
If we lose this, we're going until I'm back to GM2.
Okay, bet.
Say less.
I'm jumping off the map.
I'm picking Jeff.
We don't lose a game.
Not possible.
Somehow there's less GM players now than there were two hours ago.
Three hours ago.
It's Christmas!
What do you...
Okay, fucking and!
You're going to be grinding rifles!
Get that Christmas SR!
Bro, it's like that trauma shit.
Enthiruses SR.
Okay, the biggest reason is because on Christmas, a lot of the biggest streamers don't stream on Christmas playing Marvel Rivals.
Because they actually have things to do on Christmas.
So there's no stream snipers that are like, this is how I'm going to get on Shroud's team and become the next biggest streamer.
So we don't have that.
So now there's less GM players because they don't have a Shroud to stream snipe.
Oh, I get it now.
That's basically it.
See, I'm done celebrating Christmas.
So now all the Christmas SR is mine.
No, I think it's like people who actually want to grind the game that's on.
Or just, you know, they're depressed.
Okay, get to that.
What's the opposite?
Maybe they already celebrated.
I won't say it.
We'll never know.
Maybe they already celebrated Christmas.
Well, that's true, but they won't be on NA servers.
Because that's just, that's just like, wanting to lose.
This guy has CBP in his fucking banner.
Do we have a tank player?
Aww.
Uh oh.
Lord Hades, you're a tank player, right?
Lord Hades.
Lord Hades, 0-9-3-5.
He's about to hover Wolverine.
Okay, Hawkeye?
Yeah.
Stands for chicken bacon.
This guy's stream sniping!
Who's he stream sniping though?
There's so many.
One of us.
Who is he stream sniping?
He just repeated, he just answered my question.
Yo, what up Maddie?
How you doing?
Reuben on top.
Yo!
Oh my god.
Wait, did they know exactly what they're, what we're banning?
Nah, it's chill.
No, no, if they stream snipe our bans, then they are working with us.
Yeah, yeah, they're working with us.
Sorry, Lord's about to be gone.
Alright, we'll see.
Oh!
Oh my god, I get to play.
Wait, actual perfect bans.
Okay, but would Lord Hades play tank?
Would Lord Hades play tank?
I hope to god he does.
Would Lord Hades do the thing?
No, I didn't peep.
Listen, if you did peep, just so that you don't double ban, that's chill.
Oh shit, there he goes.
Wait, then he knows our comp exactly.
Nah, he's not peeping though.
Yo, I'm on Punisher right now guys.
I'm literally on the front page of, I'm literally on the front for Bible Rivals.
Guys, I'm on Punisher right now by the way.
I can't wait to punish your entire team with a shotgun.
Okay, you said don't peep in my eyes.
Ahem, fuck!
Maddy Figgs, no!
No, you know exactly.
This is why, well.
It's fine, we can just be better.
They know our comp, but we're just better players.
We pick the most random heroes and then swap, literally.
Nah, Maddy Figgs is chill.
Maddy Figgs would not leave our comp.
Yeah, but what if there's five other teammates?
Wait, oh yeah, they have Chime too.
Ah, fuck.
Chime is for sure stream sniping and counter swapping.
Watch, they're gonna have Namor, Loki.
I don't know what tank is good against Psylocke.
They have your stream open on the side so they know where you're invisible at.
Ah, fuck.
On the second monitor.
Oh, and now my frames are bad too, shit.
Okay, you didn't have to say that to us.
We didn't have to know.
They have Iron Man.
They have Iron Man?
Wait, did we not ban Hulk?
No, we didn't ban Hulk.
The strange ban went through instead.
Oh no, not the Hulk.
I literally can't get out of this choke because of the Hulk.
I'm almost back, just try not to die.
I can't get out of this choke.
Who banned Hulk?
Who banned Strange?
Who did it?
I killed their Mag.
Yeah, but I can't do anything.
I'm just insta-dead, bro.
Oh my god, who banned Strange over Hulk?
They have two tanks too.
That's unlucky.
Oh my god.
And they have Iron Man ult.
Oh my god, they have...
Iron Man's one, pushed him away.
Oh my god, crew, I can't see anything, dude.
It's all good.
Nice.
They have... they're gonna do a combo or something.
I damage boosted.
I can't heal you, Ruben.
I got you.
I don't know what that is.
Oh my god.
I jumped into it.
That's crazy.
I don't think we win this, though.
They used... I don't think we win this.
I just died without using my ult.
Ah.
I didn't go in with the Mantis ult.
They had... they had Psylocke ult, so I'm not gonna go in.
He's gonna... yeah.
Yeah, I...
I just woke him up because I feel like... there's no way.
No, I can touch.
Yeah, I can definitely touch, don't worry about it.
Or... do you wanna touch or do I touch?
I'll touch.
Okay, okay.
I'm not gonna use my... I don't know if we win this here.
Do we use ults for this?
This is winnable.
Hey, okay.
Okay, I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
You can peek me.
I'm ulting this in.
I'm damage boosting.
I got Psylocke.
We can try and chase the Hulk.
I'm damage boosting you.
Okay, he got away, he got away.
Oh, I'm dead.
It's fine.
Our bike bucky is okay too.
Jesus Christ, the fucking...
The only bad thing about it is that my... our heals don't outheal this.
I can't see you guys for heals.
I see you guys, I see you guys!
That's a huge ult!
Why?
Oh my god.
I'm just dead, man.
Iron Man is so bullshit.
Groot, Groot!
Yeah, she's won!
Oh my god, please!
Please, no!
I almost got my ult!
I had no...
The Mantis ult, that... we were definitely way too pushed up there.
I can't have Mantis ult for the next round.
Not a round.
That was just a really good Iron Man map.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I can't see the strange fucking picture.
Who was it?
Give me names!
I don't know.
I definitely think I voted for...
I'm gonna look at the vine.
Yeah, we're gonna flame that guy.
I'm not gonna flame him, but I'll remember him.
Nah, flame him.
He's on my personal int list, but like, I won't actually flame him.
Oh shit, she's got an int list.
I won't int, but like, he's there.
In my mind, I'll be inting.
I'll be inting his reputation.
I'm gonna remember you.
I got my list and I'm checking it twice, exactly.
Oh my god, it's 8am.
Holy fuck.
What you opening up?
A cough drop.
I've been talking for like 9 hours.
Or 10, honestly, I've lost track.
That's so irresponsible of you.
I've lost track of time.
Guys, how long have I been streaming for?
So many things happened today.
I'm damage booster you, Max?
I damage boosted our Bucky.
Alright, he's asleep now.
He just insta killed me.
Dude, I got slapped.
Oh my god, not the whole smash.
Oh, I got stomped.
Alright guys, we're gonna be gaming until I'm back to GM2.
No, no, no, we're not losing this game.
That's one.
I damage boosted you, but I don't know if it's gonna do anything.
Um, I'm on point.
There's nobody here.
Oh my god, he's solo.
He's actually solo.
I ulted.
Judge!
Jesus, what's going on?
There's so many things on my screen.
Oh my god.
There were so many things on my screen there.
I actually over sensitized there.
Over there?
There, yeah.
I'm flanking so I can catch one.
You have to rely on...
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh, I used my sleep accidentally.
I thought that was the last guy and I just triple stacked up there.
There's people in the corner.
I'm gonna damage boost you, Ruben.
Okay.
They're in this corner and I'll damage boost you too, Max.
Oh, shotgun, care.
Okay, I got your heals.
There's a Psylocke on me.
Oh, fucking Iron Man!
Holy shit.
I got Psylocke, I got Psylocke.
Nice.
Damage boosting you, Max.
And then you get the regen too.
And I'll damage boost you too.
You both have damage boost.
Wicked.
I'll give you another damage boost too.
My luck.
Oh no.
You're by yourself.
I'm trying to get up.
Oh, fuck.
Got you.
Oh, he's so low.
I killed Iron Man.
Hulk didn't get many.
Nice!
No, no, I fell asleep!
Ah!
Wait, I have Mantis Law for retake.
No.
And we can all regroup.
Alright.
Ow.
What the fuck did Breakout was doing?
What the fuck?
I'm fine.
I gave you damage boost.
I almost got all.
I have all too.
I just got stunned.
You got damage boosted.
Oh no, our Tendi!
That's not good, that guy just ate Iron Man missiles.
That poor guy.
I'm gonna try to look for a flank.
Wait, we got one.
Wait, that's huge, that's huge, that's a huge fight.
Where are you?
I got you, I got you.
I'm on the point and he's asleep.
He was asleep.
He got everything possible.
There we go.
I'm keeping my Mantis Law, I'm keeping it.
I'm zoning Psylocke.
I'm coming with you, I'm coming with you.
I'm damage boosting you for it.
Iron Man slow.
Huge, huge, huge.
Yeah, okay.
I'm on the ball.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm like forehead to monitor for this game.
Me too, I'm like sitting upright.
I'm so fucking locked in right now.
Oh.
Boop.
I'm so glad that anytime I did die to the Iron Man that round, he died immediately after.
That was so nice.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
We're so, we're so okay.
We're so okay.
Guys, remember when I was a humble Luna one trick?
Look how much I evolved since hitting Diamond.
Look at me.
Thank you so much.
What's up there?
Oh, and this is a really bad Iron Man map.
Isn't this a good Iron Man map?
This is not a bad Iron Man map.
I feel like it's a pretty terrible Iron Man map.
No, this is a very good Iron Man map.
Look, if he wins this round, it's a terrible Iron Man map.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't use this.
We fucking go up for this.
Solox one.
Here, I give you damage boost.
Can you give me damage boost too?
We got the point, we got the cap at least.
I'm at low.
Here you go.
I give you damage boost, Mac.
Solox on the right.
And I give damage boost to you too.
Oh, behind you Reuben.
Fuck.
There's a Magneto that's asleep.
They're gonna come in for him.
Oh my god.
I can't see shit.
I'm trying to get you.
Oh no!
We gotta just die on point, I think.
Yeah.
This is cool.
That's fine.
They have no support ults.
They have no support ults, no Solox ult.
They're gonna have Mag and Iron Man.
We have low heal too.
Okay.
I'm giving you damage boost.
Yeah, I'm gonna look for an ult here.
And I'll give you damage boost too, Reuben.
Okay, we're good.
Alright, goodbye.
I'm ulting.
Are you serious?
That hits me?
Nah, I still think this is winnable.
No, it's not.
Yeah.
Unless...
It's winnable, it's winnable, it's winnable.
I killed three, I killed three.
Yeah.
We have low key, we have low key.
I'm coming back, I'm coming back.
Good shit.
I'm coming back to you.
Bro, I've never felt so much rage at that.
That was so bullshit.
I gave you both damage boost.
Thank you.
This Iron Man...
Wait, no.
No, he didn't use ult.
Iron Man's low on the right.
He did use ult, he did use ult.
Okay, okay.
I got Ike's ult.
It's fine.
Nice, that's a pick.
Iron Man half.
Nice.
I damage boosted you, Reuben.
Big.
Okay.
I'm looking for you.
I'm damage boosting.
I'm damage boosting you.
Huge.
I healed you too.
Psylocke, Psylocke ult.
Nice.
Oh my god, I hear so many.
I'm backing up.
Oh my god, Punisher, you're not them.
You're not him.
You know who is him?
Me.
I got my Psylocke ult again.
I damage boost.
Hulk to the right, Hulk to the right.
He's jumping in.
Yeah, I'm on him.
Hulk ulted.
Oh no.
I can ult this.
It's fine.
Just make a mini.
Make a mini.
Oh no.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm gonna hide.
I can go crazy.
Yeah.
That's fine to use Psylocke too.
I come back with Psy.
Nice, nice, nice.
Don't use anything.
No ults.
Oh wait, wait, we can fight.
We can win this.
I killed two.
I killed both supports.
Psylocke, Psylocke, Psylocke.
I'm coming back.
Nice.
Oh my god.
It's that easy.
We clutched the fuck up.
We actually win this.
Oh my god.
We fucking...
Everything was riding on that game.
If we lost, we would be stuck queuing for another four hours.
We all fucking clutched it up there.
Holy shit.
That was...
So much stress has been relieved.
Taking off my shoulders.
Oh my god.
You're ranked up.
Plus 19.
Don't even give a fuck.
Plus 18.
I'm fine.
I'm done.
GG's guys.
GG's.
I'm up.
I'm up two games.
That's all that matters for me.
I'm up.
I think I'm back where I started.
I'm up four games.
I'm happy.
I'm up two games.
I'm happy too.
I'm so happy.
I'm fine with that.
I'm just gonna go to bed, guys.
GG's.
We'll do this again tomorrow, I guess.
Yeah.
Guys, I'm just thinking if we grinded normal hours, do you think we'd actually climb?
Probably not.
Well, I climbed.
These matches have been some of the hardest matches I've ever played.
These are the matches I actually calmed.
I've never calmed this much before.
I'm honestly just impressed at how many games we played.
Coming from Overwatch, three games an hour tops.
We played so much.
We played a lot.
We played so many games.
This is awesome.
I love when I'm playing a game and I get to play the game.
It's fucking insane.
Yeah.
It's just very addicting.
Are you guys still going to play more Marvel Rivals?
Are you guys done?
I need to level up my second alt account.
Oh, you're fucking weak.
You're not gonna play on your main.
You're fucking...
Mac, if you keep playing on your main right now, I'll raid you.
If I keep playing on my main right now, I ain't okay.
Ruben, I was gonna offer it to you, but...
Shit, you know what?
Okay, I guess I'll keep queuing on the main.
I'm ready to go on your main!
That's a good deal!
Bro, Ruben, I'm sorry.
You missed the opportunity.
Fuck!
You missed the shots you don't take.
GG.
It's fucking over.
Wait, Mac, are you actually still gonna keep going?
I'll take it.
You're gonna keep going?
Yeah, I'll take it.
You're gonna fucking doom queue.
Let's go!
You're gonna wait.
You're gonna doom queue this shit.
Okay, GG, guys.
You're gonna be the next Designful stream.
Yep, you already know.
Alright, GGs, I'm gonna talk to my chat before I go.
Alright, GGs.
Bye-bye!
GGs.
That was fun!
I had a lot of fun playing with Ruben and Mac today.
We broke even and are up two games.
That's all that matters.
We actually ended on such a nice game, too.
That shit, all of us just locked in.
I'm up two games.
I'm fine being GM2 for today.
We'll get to GM1 another time.
I had a lot of fun playing.
I was up.
I streamed for 10 hours.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm so...
I love Marvel Rivals.
I'm so addicted.
I'm so sorry.
Kobato, thank you for the 10,000 bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate...
Alright, if you've seen some of the games...
I'm fucking...
If you've watched the entire 10-hour VOD and some of the games I fucking went through, like, there were some fucking ELO terrorists in my lobbies.
Like...
I would play out of my goddamn mind and I got the most ELO terrorists there.
It didn't matter.
I got fucking Neil.
Anyway, for those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out there.
But I'm going to be doing a lot of my Marvel Rivals rank grind on Twitch.
And please follow me on Twitter if you want to keep up to date.
Exclamation point, Twitter.
I mean, everything is just DokiBird, so it's not really that difficult.
If you want to support me via other means, I have merch!
Exclamation point, merch.
I also have an Android!
Yes, that's me!
I actually have...
Yes!
I'm a pretty big deal.
Hee hee hee.
I have an Android there.
So, yeah.
My merch and stuff.
It really helps a lot.
And whatever stuff...
I have a Gamersubs code.
When you use my code, you get 10% off.
And I have my own custom PC case.
So you do exclamation point.
I also have a custom PC case and custom keycaps.
Yes, thank you so much for all the follows, for all the bitties, for all the subs.
For milking Valorant's wallet.
Because they have too much money anyway.
I really appreciate it.
Please subscribe to me on YouTube if you like more of my content.
I'll be doing a Christmas stream later today.
I went to sleep and then fucking set up my Christmas stream stuff.
And then...
Wait, 9, 10, 11, 12, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
Okay, I can sleep 7 hours.
And then I'll have time.
I have 2 hours to set things up.
And then maybe after the Christmas stream, I'll play more Marble Rivals.
Who knows?
Anyway, thank you guys.
Thank you all for coming.
As always, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, thank you so much.
There's so many people watching today.
I can't believe I was on the...
I was like top 5 Marble Rivals streams today.
Bye, guys.
Oh, to be fair, there was zero competition, to be fair.
It was late night queues.
Late night DJ queues.
And like, there was actually zero competition.
Alright, bye, guys.
Bye.